[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey everybody all right we've been
pre-gaming well not that much I mean I
mean I've drank maybe like an inch is
that even an inch that's less than an
inch all my ice is melting and it's not
hot in here I don't really understand
like why because it was a lot of juice
and the The Ice that was in the ice
maker had been in there for a while you
know how it's got a hole in the middle
of the house
so it melts faster I put the ice in both
the drinks it was it was all the ice in
the ice bucket is it out of is it out of
water no I fixed it oh okay let's go we
gotta because I refilled it got filtered
water I got the machine hooked up and
everything but it's making fresh ice we
got a whole system fresh ice cubes asked
last longer because they're more massive
yeah yeah they got Mass
if they've been sitting there for a
while the hole in the middle gets bigger
well what is happening it's like is that
I mean I use the ice machine all that
I'm not drinking all day don't be
alarmed but it's like I put it because I
have ice water right so I'm drinking
like ice water all day so I go in there
every now and then refill it yeah and so
if it says like that it needs water I'll
put water in there but if it gets full
and I haven't refilled it in a while if
it gets full like if you don't do
anything it'll kind of start to melt
back into the water reservoir tell you
what people if you've got a two-story
house you got a big house [ __ ]
getting those little portable ice makers
that I got at Sam's only for like 90
bucks is a lifesaver it's nice having
the little fridge and a little
refrigerator up here and everything I'm
gonna build a whole [ __ ] snack
station up here yeah because all I need
is a little microwave I mean all yeah
pretty much I already have a coffee pot
up yeah you don't have to go downstairs
and do the [ __ ] yeah because that's pain
in the ass well like I said we don't
have like food or anything really in the
um in the refrigerator it's mostly just
it's just yeah it's Tom sodas and like
mixers are in there and like sometimes I
keep cookies cat food in there like if
she doesn't eat the whole can or
something and I gotta set the bar up in
there I want to get a nice bar we used
to keep snacks in there but we haven't
really been been buying that many snacks
because you know we're trying not to get
like yeah we're on the fat so red we're
on regimen
because you can't call it a day because
that's like not bad
[ __ ] I got and Chicks suck
everything has to be gendered and
divided divide you know divide [ __ ]
warships from ferry boats just like
just like that and it's all these
experience
clearly defined world you know but uh I
got cookies got the I got my famous
lemon cookies for the lemon cookies yeah
lemon cookies from [ __ ] Dollar Store
Dollar General those are good they're
good I got them in the I got them in the
[ __ ] freezer we just haven't been
raiding them oh I didn't even know they
were in there I never look in the
freezer oh I got chocolate chip cookies
in there from from don't tell me that I
got lemon cookies see if I'd have known
that do you see it's probably better not
to see that's why like when I lived
alone yeah I never bought cookies or
nothing like that because I said if
they're in my house I'm gonna eat them I
started popping them steroids and all of
a sudden I needed a shook a [ __ ]
Sugar Rush sometime well you didn't work
out you know what I did I might have
mentioned this before but you know what
I did that because I'm like well I can't
because if I start eating cookies I'll
just like eat all the cookies and it's
just like like I said that's why I don't
buy cookies I don't buy snacks or
anything like that
um sometimes I'll buy like you know like
a can of nuts or something like that but
I don't like try I love cookies but I
can't eat them so what I did was I
bought
I don't usually like hard candy
oh you had to turn the fan turn the fan
on yeah but I really really like there's
this coffee flavored hard candy I think
it's called bali's best or something
like that and you can buy it in like
five pound bags from Amazon for not that
expensive I get those and if I want
something sweet I just pop one of those
in my mouth and eat it because it's only
they're only 15 calories each and
they're really really nice they're like
really sweet and they're really Savory
and I really like them so if ever I'm
like really hungry and like I kind of
want to snack I'm like man I really want
a cookie or something like that I just I
just have one of those and I'm just like
it's much less
calories you know what I mean and that's
yeah or or gum or I chew gum that works
too those
okay it looks like people yeah people
are still showing up we're gonna start
getting a [ __ ] crowd here everybody's
sending hearts and stuff Jenny can go
through the comments in a bit
and we're looking forward to uh
this show this is a paranormal show
which is [ __ ] real popular on um 13
o'clock that people voted for this one
didn't they uh yeah big time I think I
think this got I think a couple of the
other I can't remember what the other
topics were but a couple of them got
like one boat but this one got like we
were talking about this before the show
started that we need to start bringing
paranormal back a little bit we've been
going off on tangents we know but look
man the show's Gonna Last for as long as
we last we're probably gonna be doing
this show until we die yeah
so probably we probably oh my God we got
a lot of it's been going on a lot longer
than I thought it was gone really I
didn't really consider it I didn't
either I just kind of like thought I'd
do it I didn't really think about like
how long we'd be doing it but that's the
thing I kind of felt like once we got to
a point where a bunch of people were
listening or like showing up and
interacting and stuff like that I'm like
well obviously we have to keep doing it
now right yeah because we don't want to
like let everybody down because now we
have like four or five four mats as it
went and tried some experimental [ __ ]
and it just boils down to just live
streaming these things and [ __ ]
around and drinking and talking about
these cases
but uh we need to start bringing
paranormal back a little bit more
regularly I think we went down True
Crime a little too too much
everybody loves True Crime but parent
almost [ __ ] awesome too and you know
most of the cases are [ __ ] but we
can make them funny but there are some
foot there are some cases that uh
are weird you know
there are some of them that I believed
in that Jenny helped helped debunk like
the [ __ ] Ted serious remember him put
the [ __ ] oh yeah we did a show about
that yeah I thought there was something
the photographer guy that was like yeah
he could put a put an image on a piece
of film with his eye yeah that guy was I
thought it might have been some kind of
sigh ability but he was a fellow drunk
so you know yeah
he he also drank before he works what
made me think there might have been
something to it is that he wasn't always
successful he would set up a big thing
okay I'm gonna try to do it I can't do
it today
I always kind of Wonder though it's like
oh my God I lost my slide yeah probably
I don't know
but you know [ __ ] where'd it go gonna do
it and they had a big old thing and then
he couldn't do it and he admitted that
he couldn't do it just can't do it today
I don't know why
and um and he was drunk like he always
was
but you would think if he was a fake
that he would have faked it you know
what I mean well like I said I I would
say as coming at it as a skeptic I would
say well probably he had some kind of
like technical difficulties yeah maybe
with his little scam that he was doing
right so he was just kind of like oh the
spirits are not speaking to me or
whatever the [ __ ] they say I I figure
that's probably what happened the way I
interpreted it at the time was is like
that he was getting old and that he
couldn't do it anymore that too yeah and
I kind of feel like maybe in a Converse
sort of way I might have been psychic I
think they know that that will um
contribute to their very similitude if
they're saying oh well you know it's so
catches catch can I don't really know
like when the spirits are gonna like be
communicated so like people that are
already inclined to believe it will be
like oh man like he could have like done
all this stuff but he didn't do it
because they weren't speaking that day
but I kind of feel like they know that
so I think they'll like take a bullet a
couple times I was inclined to believe
it of course because you know I had to
Paranormal stuff happen to me as a young
kid and then if if I worry about it too
much it comes back Jenny's seen it yeah
she wasn't impressed really
um and well you had talked to me so much
about it that I was when it happened I
was just kind of like oh that's neat
yeah the one who freaked out was uh was
was Dimitri he did yeah Dimitri got
scared because Tom do it again and I was
just like
he was just like I almost got like I was
getting lost in it again and I said no
no I can't do it I'm kind of scared of
it you know it might do something bad
that's the only thing see because I
don't think it's I'm not saying I don't
think it's paranormal it's just I think
it's you yeah
um you know an aspect yeah that's what
I'm saying it's one aspect of my
personality so in that sense yeah it is
a little scary because if you got like
really mad because I haven't told you
before I'm like look at you if you get
really mad at me one day they'll like
fling a brick at my head or some [ __ ]
like that so I'm like I'd be scared of
it because of that yeah but just scared
of it because of what it's doing I'm at
no I'm not scared of it you guys know
that I'm ex-military you know [ __ ]
from good infantry units and I you guys
know you regular listeners know that I
have a dark side
um there are parts of it that scare me
you know that I could go into a rage and
you know
I don't think I'd ever kill a person
that I cared about I don't even think
any other aspects that's what they all
say but I just can't trust it you know
what I mean that's what I'm saying right
that's what I'm saying that might be
that's to the extent yeah I don't think
you would do that like you've never done
anything like that in the past but who
knows there are aspects of me that I
wouldn't trust around me
yeah exactly and I've known you for a
long time so I know that about right
so that's the only thing I'm saying I
don't think you would do anything bad or
anything like that but I felt if you I
felt like if you were really really mad
if you're really really mad even if you
weren't even mad at me particularly but
something like that might happen and it
might result in Lex Friedman had a guest
on his channel
a couple weeks back and I was listening
to it and this dude is on to some on
onto some real [ __ ] he was talking about
Stuart hammeroff and he was talking
about
um that other guy that Stewart works
with he's got that Nobel Prize Roger
Penrose yes sir and he was saying that
time space isn't real
it's a mathematical [ __ ] Construction
and that reality is only based upon our
senses and our ability to compute math
and that still isn't real
time space isn't real and neither is
mass energy so he's kind of like one of
these guys that's the holographic
universe
and he says things that you aren't
looking at don't exist
they're kind of like uh
um yeah they're abstract that goes way
back though right and he and he's saying
that we'll never really understand the
unified field you know he's a he's a
[ __ ] physicist okay he's in these
universities he says we'll never really
have a unified field until we understand
how Consciousness works
and that Consciousness is is like a
major element that we're not computing
and I was he started saying about you
know things that really keyed in with
some of my Early Childhood experiences
with uh what what has termed Poltergeist
experience but it's rspk it's recurrent
spontaneous psychokinesis all right and
um I know it's a reality
that I think probably anybody could do
it if you're in the right mindset it's
not something you could do
on command and it has to adhere to
certain laws
you can't look at objects that have to
move which boy that's difficult isn't it
you're moving things that are only in a
state of kind of neutral existence
whenever something's moving and you're
seeing it arrive you never see it really
depart
remember that when that happened and
then when you see something in midair it
doesn't really it looks kind of blurry
and
it's always at the periphery of your
your your conscious awareness
so could it be like in Star Wars where
you got Darth Maul fighting a dude and
he points at an object and throws it I
don't think it's possible
because I want that thing to go remove
yeah because there's too many other
people looking at the object it has to
be something that is being moved from an
area where nothing is looking
so it's in a gray Zone
and I noticed that back then when I was
a kid
there's more activity in rooms where the
door was shut nobody was in that room
although Lois and red and [ __ ] did see
things move just but they weren't
looking directly at the object when it
launched well I mean nobody really is
because you don't expect right because
like I said when we had it happen in our
old house it's like I didn't expect the
remote control to fly off the [ __ ]
coffee table no one was looking at it
why would you yeah and I did and I
ignored it until you guys called it out
I wouldn't have noticed that and the
first literally the first thing I
thought when it moved I thought I had
kicked the table
and like you know made it like I
remember the sound that it made when it
hit boom
you know what I mean boom it sounded
louder than it than a remote well it
sounded heavy yeah which it was not like
a brick
it's weird yeah it was a very weird
situation it was weird but like I said
it didn't really scare me because I just
the first thing I thought was huh I was
like well I didn't kick the tables do
you guys kick the table no yeah and then
I turned to Tom I said do you do that
[ __ ] yeah
so because of this if you're regulars to
the show
because of these things that have
happened on and off over the years and
some of the weird [ __ ] that happened
with the television during that time
remember that
that's something yeah do that TV used to
[ __ ] turn itself on all it got it
yeah and then a couple times it turned
itself on in our room while we were
sleeping I woke up and the TV was on
remember yeah that was crazy it was
usually the one in the living room which
is weird because we hardly ever used
that one we usually use the one in the
bedroom the one in the bedroom came on a
couple times in the middle of the night
yeah just like out of the blue but I
mean the first time I thought well maybe
Pookie sat on the remote or something no
but she wasn't literally turning on yeah
yeah I was gonna say maybe the bedroom
ones were that but like the living room
one I don't think that was and it would
turn that would turn on turn on and when
you'd find it it was like an obscure
screensaver it wasn't a channel
it was like it was a pretty screensaver
that was like when you were on certain
we were trying to program stuff it was I
I can't and it would do it and it did it
regularly for a certain period when all
that other's weird I mean it was several
times a week it wasn't every day several
times a week but it was probably like
every other day or every third day like
I would go out in the morning to make
coffee and be like well there's that
[ __ ] TV is on again yeah and it did
it regularly during during that period
of phenomenon did it regularly for about
three or four months it was when you
were writing the book yeah and then it
vanished and it didn't happen for
several years yeah it's just it wasn't a
normal occur yeah so I'm saying that's
you yeah I don't think it's ghosts or
demons or nothing like that that's why
it's not scary because I think it's you
I mean it's scary in the sense that like
I said if you got super mad yeah then
you know yeah maybe that never feeds it
when I get kind of worried about it and
it starts getting stronger and then I
get scared and it'll get stronger and
then I gotta stop it
you know maybe if you're just like
emotional maybe if you just like chilled
out and be like well yeah I did chill
out man yeah that's what I'm saying the
more attention I gave to it the stronger
it would get yeah you gotta be like
[ __ ] control it
yeah that's the only thing that bothers
me about it I don't you know I don't
think that you know I I don't think that
when I was younger
13 14 it was a lot more frightening
because I thought it was an outside
force I thought well yeah I thought it
was basically a demon or a ghost
so I didn't think that I could have any
say in it but then once I started it I
just go oh okay
this is an aspect of
what I'm thinking about yeah and then it
and then when I act actively tried to
get it to do things that I wanted to do
it just vanished
it won't do that it doesn't work that
way it kind of like
it collapses
yeah the ability collapses so that's why
when you see Star Wars you damn Jedis
and [ __ ] trying to do this [ __ ]
from my experience when you're
consciously aware of what's happening it
actually
makes it go away
can you imagine if people could actually
do that
I mean that would be just like
well that's what Scientology was
actually about they were trying to
induce it yeah good luck what's his name
Prince that black dude I talked about
earlier [ __ ] the show he was like one
of the top scientologists he knew about
it and joined Scientology to try to
learn how to do it but he said he turned
out turned out he says the the what's
happening in Scientology is the exact
opposite of what you need
to [ __ ] Foster that yeah exact
ability I don't want 300 300 000 later
yeah I figured out that they were full
of crap they're full of [ __ ] it's not an
ability as as what you would think it
was is it's more like a uh a side effect
it's a it's a phenomena
and it's directly linked to
consciousness
and I haven't seen this at an early age
I started to kind of I had I fell into
the Trap of believing everything
okay anything that was paranormal I
believe it for a while
but now that I know more about it no
there's only certain things that are
paranormal their own and eventually
they'll be found out to be something in
in the uh
in the natural universe so that's kind
of where I'm busy with it
there was a time in which electricity
static electricity was considered to be
paranormal well we'll get into that a
little bit because one thing that I
found really fascinating and one thing
that because you know when we're doing a
show on spiritual and spiritualism and
seances we've covered like different
aspects of this like I feel like on
other shows like a very long time ago as
I mentioned we did a show about Houdini
and seances and stuff
um you know so we're going to cover all
that stuff I think we just show about
the fox sisters and I'm going to cover
that a little bit but it's just kind of
like I wanted a little bit of an angle
and an interesting angle that I found
actually from a BBC documentary from the
early 2000s or the mid 90s or something
they were kind of pointing out the sort
of symbiotic relationship between
spiritualism and scientists that were
involved in telecommunications yeah and
how like a lot of that technology like
fed into the belief system so I kind of
want to get into that a little bit too
because I thought that was really
interesting a lot of the technology
probably most of the technology okay
look at this way all of the technology
that we've grown up with today
would have been considered paranormal in
the Roman era
yeah they'd have been like what this is
Magic this okay in the 1700s
people would report seeing angels
in the Darkness
and if you actually analyze with the
trouble they're talking about [ __ ]
Sparks
that's what they're talking about
they're talking about
they're talking about Sparks from static
electric somebody bit into a Wintergreen
Lifesaver
walking across a wool rug wearing the
wrong clothes touching something and you
see a flash of light from the heavens
and this and that and an angel spoke to
you the Angel's telling me to put some
shoes on yeah yeah what they're talking
about is the [ __ ] spark you know I
mean from that which is funny that they
didn't know that because it's like so
obvious I'm not gonna [ __ ] on people in
the past by the time the 1700s enrolled
around you had Franklin involved they
were they could make those Sparks yeah
and he was like the dub he was spinning
spinning glass discs with uh wool
touched on to them yeah you could make a
sport but they still kind of thought
that was paranormal
which made sense that they thought it
was paranormal because in the Roman era
they thought Zeus could throw lightning
bolts from heaven when you saw a damn
lightning bolt that was the power of God
so any spark was God
the hand of God
so that they they didn't see reality the
same way we see it today but see that's
what I always find so interesting is
that you know that people before the
Advent of you know the scientific method
they saw this [ __ ] but they didn't know
what it was
um and so the stories they came up with
to explain it or like really really
fascinating to me right they could only
explain it through the the mechanisms of
the cultures that they grew up yeah and
if you believe in stories that Zeus
threw lightning bolts down from Mount
Olympus any spark you saw had something
to do with God
spiritual paranormal
so you're stealing the power of Zeus
yeah stealing God's power which is
electricity
so
if you could make a generator in the
Roman era and create and run Motors and
make light bulbs and things like that
they would consider that heresy like you
are stealing God's power to do this yeah
you knock that off stop it
for stealing Zeus's power so well yeah
I'm sure that happens and they would
believe what they're saying yeah well
they didn't nobody made electricity back
then but if you showed them electricity
what could be done explained they would
go nah we don't like that you stole
God's power he's going to be bad okay
you can't do that yeah because we know
it says right here in our books
that Zeus throws lightning bolts and now
you're making lightning bolts you're
gonna piss Zeus off and you're going to
bring all that's his gig yeah
you don't have permission and he's going
to punish us so you have to die yeah
that's what they would do
you have to be real careful about belief
but here's the thing man I'm gonna try
to find this dude I'm gonna go and look
at it now
and give you guys uh uh something to
watch okay which is uh
he's a scientist and he's he in he was
on Lex Friedman's show it was I got a
lot of respect for Lex Lex is a young
scientist
he has his own show
and he's a nerdy little dude but he
works out because he believes in the
Greek ideal of being mental and physical
so I like that you know a lot of those
guys up in MIT they're just gonna get
too mental you have to you have to
approach life from a holistic standpoint
you got to be mental and physical the
Greek ideal but let me go find that show
I'm going to tell you guys his name and
you can check it out
slasher Fred says since you're doing a
discussion of spiritualism and seances
one of these days you should review the
movie which board matter of fact I'll
check tomorrow but I think that which
board is in next week's patreon poll
like for the next movie retrospective
because I actually really like that
movie it's one from what 8687 and I've
been wanting to do it for a while so I
think it's in the poll if it doesn't
come up in the poll like we might do it
for a matinee show at some point uh too
I found it already
okay it was it from a couple weeks ago
you can look on the Lex Freeman show
his name is Donald Hoffman
the show is called it's two night number
293 Donald Hoffman reality is an
illusion
how Evolution hid the truth The Lex
Friedman podcast
so his name is Donald Hoffman
from on the Lex Friedman show he's got
nearly 2 million subscribers this is a
big show
good but uh
Friedman is doing a great job you'll
have all kinds of good all kind of good
guests on I recommend that podcast it's
all science
okay
I'm like way behind in the comments uh
Zach says uh I'm glad this show is still
going because you guys are awesome thank
you and your shows have become part of
my regular viewing habits oh thank you
so much yeah some people like talking
about paranormal like they're not really
sure what they believe uh
[Music]
Oscar price says kitty kitty kitty kitty
yeah did we do that did we do a show
about that episode man we were we were
gonna get her on here because like Tom
talked to her online yeah she was like a
little online friend she wanted to do it
but then she didn't want it she's kind
of scared to come on the show she
doesn't want him I mean I don't know
well she got married and has kids now
yeah and uh she kind of wanna wants to
leave all that behind her stepsister was
the was the one behind it she was the
one that was doing it yeah she was just
a poltergeist Focus you know
and she
sent me that damn audio clip of that
thing going yeah yeah it's pretty creepy
yeah
which I probably still have on messenger
I should have recorded it off a
messenger somehow and saved it but I
could go back through that conversation
and find it
was creepy she asked me not to share it
yeah that's the thing it's like and I
don't blame her because like it's her
story she told me not to share it and
you know it's her [ __ ] so it's like I
wouldn't you know talk about people it
said it it sent that to her in a
an audio message on her phone
weird yeah
Mr 88 says when we were talking about
like angels and Zeus and everything
watch the Nightly News in the south of
the Midwest and they still televise
angel sightings as if they are real yeah
that that tracks I've never seen that
well I don't watch the Nightly News yeah
[Laughter]
uh Zach says have you seen Seance in a
wet afternoon I have and I love that
[ __ ] movie matter of fact
um my new channel that I'm putting up
eventually I'm gonna do a video on that
it'll probably won't be out till August
though but I have like a really long
post that like I wrote the script for it
I just haven't like recorded the video
yet
so yes I have seen it and it's awesome
and somebody actually I hadn't heard of
it but somebody recommended it to me
it was nominated our the main thing I
remember about it was that it was
nominated for an Academy Award or at
least like the main actress in it was
the same year that Julie Andrews from
The Sound of Music was and Julie Andrews
won which I'm not [ __ ] on that but I
kind of feel like the this other lady
should have won I'm just saying like
after I saw the movie it's really really
good it's kind of like a thriller I
guess but
oh the lemon cookies at the lemon
cookies at um Dollar General
the DG that we call it they are
ridiculous okay this is like the Dollar
General
is kind of like uh that's Walmart
it's like a step below Walmart it's
Walmart for out in the middle of nowhere
all right it's like dinky as well dinky
Walmart
but they got a lot of stuff yeah it's
weird they got a lot of [ __ ] they got
some cookie section in there all right
with all these different kind of cookies
under their own brand name for a dollar
you get a big pack
of the lemon cookies
and they're they're like Oreos
but the cookie part is like the McDonald
Bland cookies you know those it's like
that with a lemon
filling in the middle and it's together
like a sandwich cookie like an Oreo and
you get a big pack of them for in a day
96 cents
so I'd get like give me give me 10 of
them [ __ ] yeah yeah he'd come back
and I'd look in the fridge and there's
like all this like big packs of lemon
cookies they were like those McDonald's
land cookies but with lemon Frost and in
the middle like an Oreo man those things
were [ __ ] good
they're real good and they also had
peanut butter ones they were just like
Nutter butter
for 97 those were good too yeah I wasn't
a big fan of the chocolate ones but I
don't really like like I like chocolate
cake and stuff like that and I like
chocolate bars but chocolate isn't my
favorite flavor for like cakes and
cookies yeah you know what I'm saying
like I like Oreos but they have to be
double stuffed Oreos because the middle
part is the good [ __ ] yeah and you can
get all the white trash food Staples
all the canned stuff like wrap Chef
where D ravioli a different kind with
the pulled rings for like a dollar all
the uh damn
um chili with pull ring like Hormel
chilies tamale with a pull ring like
it's it's it's like it's like an MRE
meal and they're all about a dollar
they've gone up though they're like a
dollar sixty some of that [ __ ] now
almost two dollars because the food
prices are going up
you could get big old things to [ __ ]
spam
[ __ ] deviled eggs [ __ ] potted meat
like well I've told you get a sausage
all the white trash food Staples a lot
of white trash food groups are there
I've told you that some of the channels
that I like that do these like extreme
like really free budget and they try to
do stuff that's like hey I'm gonna make
like homemade meals from like [ __ ] that
I bought from Dollar Tree or whatever
and if you know what you're doing yeah
you can make like some good [ __ ] from
there I saw like this one channel the
other day she made like a really decent
looking meatloaf from crap she bought at
the Dollar Tree and it was like less
than five dollars and like she made and
it like looked pretty good yeah gotta
say you know what I mean so you don't
necessarily just have to like eat it out
of the can you could like mix it
together with other [ __ ] you can like
because they sell like regular just
regular ass ingredients too just like
you know like tomato paste and flour and
[ __ ] like that so I already says Ari
belly dance is that is that Arielle is
that our Mario oh I don't know because
she may be the dancer
um I didn't even know Dinty Moore was
still a thing until I walked into Dollar
General it is they still sell that I
mean that stuff it's not I don't know
it's just so I know that is okay so so
salty yeah okay we have we have another
friend that's uh I'm friends with her on
on um uh [ __ ] Instagram we have
another friend who's who uh is named
Arielle who's a bear who's a dancer
thinking I thought I got confused
I mean what it is somebody like mowing
the lawn
who's longer like a damn it sounds like
a [ __ ] whose lot are they mowing sounds
like a bunch of trucks going on
no it's been going on for a while yeah
somebody's mowing it's a giant mower I
was like who's [ __ ] long are they
moan it sounds like they're right
outside the goddamn window I know Jesus
Christ speaking of
I had to go get that mower
um I had I'm gonna shake it back prior
to next month or the month after
but turns out I can get a [ __ ] good
mower just on my uh account with uh I
even told you this that yeah I don't
remember um that Lowe's account that I
set up online yeah I got good credit you
know
um but they they said they will give me
any mower I want on a 36 month payment
plot program
so okay so it only gonna it's it would
be less it would cost me less a month to
buy the mower and just mow it myself
yeah it'd be like less than 100 and we
don't have a lot of
bushes no like that have to be trimmed
it's mostly just grass I'm gonna get one
in [ __ ] big ass Comfort mowers with
the [ __ ] headlights on there and [ __ ]
and [ __ ] you know I have a drink
holder and
drinks don't drink in my head yeah
drinking Mo I'm gonna drinking mode
definitely could drink them I'm drinking
Mo at night
yeah okay might as well
DJ Maniac says Top Ramen and spam when
prepared with the right vegetable
seasonings and sauce isn't bad yeah
honestly if you get ramen noodles I just
like Ramen noodles it doesn't even have
to have like the that flavor packet in
it you can make ramen noodles to put
some uh you know some of those heat up
like steamed vegetables in there put
some hard-boiled eggs in there put a
couple like you know some seasonings and
[ __ ] like that shit's delicious you can
even put a little bit of like um that
powdered like coffee creamer in there if
you want like to
to kind of like uh you know thickened up
or you can put we have powdered cheese
too because you do Tom's like it is all
his prep or stuff so sometimes he'll put
like powdered cheese in there too which
you can have that or not I don't really
have to have it it's not really that big
deal
um but you know
Zach says we have a neighbor behind us
who mows every night at nine for some
[ __ ] reason
that's gonna be Tom I I kind of feel
like well maybe not every night but he
might be out there like a few nights a
week being like at 9 00 p.m being like
wooed I'm mowing I can see him doing
that I can see him doing that
Mr 88 says eat enough Dollar General
cookies and you'll definitely start
seeing non-animate objects you yeah it's
funny you [ __ ] I mean they're not bad
like actually the lemon ones are good
and those ones the peanut butter were
good what were those ones that we got
that were just like they weren't sugar
cookies they were they coconut coconut
they were cut no they were [ __ ]
what were those macaroons weren't they
yeah they were kind of like coconut
macaroons sort of but they were like
thinner those were actually really good
too like I said I wasn't a big fan of
the chocolate ones but to be honest I'm
not I'm not a fan of like chocolate
cookies I like chocolate chip cookies
but I don't really like chocolate
sandwich cookies unless they're Oreos
and even if they're Oreos they have to
be double stuff or they have to be like
the ones that are covered in white
chocolate or have like some other [ __ ]
going on because
it's funny because I remember
when I was a kid uh my mom and dad for a
while they ran a daycare
and they would give out the kids to the
kids like cookies and stuff but
sometimes if it was maybe like the end
of the month or they didn't have that
much money or something like that they
would give the kids like cookies but
they'd be like Oreos sort of but like
without the cream so it would just be
like the chocolate cookie part or they
would give you like a cookie that was
you know like the chocolate thing that's
like the top of like an ice cream
sandwich okay well they would just give
you that but just the cookie like
without the ice cream you know what I
mean and I was just like what is this
[ __ ] it's really not good like
without the cream or the ice cream on it
but like I said if I'm gonna have a
cookie I'm gonna have like something
good these These are the oh he had to
bring it back yeah those are the [ __ ]
Dollar General lemon cookies those
[ __ ] are bad ass they are very good
and that was it nice to mess up a lemon
sandwich cookies yeah Fair that's what
they call it Clover Valley Clover Valley
is there that's their store brand that's
their store brand that shit's good man
yeah yeah I mean all of them have been
completely passable like I said I like
those coconut ones too they were like
bigger they weren't like sandwich
cookies they were just like bigger Jesus
Christ that [ __ ] [ __ ] is so loud
grass is not that important wait a
minute that might be Q
what Mr Q the guy I hired to come down
here and [ __ ] mow it well that's what
I said that's what it is yeah yeah okay
my neighbor that's what I said I was
like they sound like they're mowing our
grass it sounds like it's like crazy
this [ __ ] was broken okay his [ __ ] was
broken wait what [ __ ] what his lawnmower
oh okay and I told him that it called
him two days ago so if you get it fixed
just come mow it and I'll pay you oh
okay so that's what he did so is he
gonna come knock on the door like now
Camp guy says uh that he just likes
regular shortbread I do as well honestly
one of my favorite like just off the
shelf cookies are Lorna Dunes yeah I
don't even know do they still make those
man I love learning Dunes but yeah
um so okay one thing I want to do
because what we're 40 minutes in
and you're you still got this [ __ ] out
yeah I've been like damn cookie butter
and man I've been wanting to keep the
keep this downstairs take it down to the
pantry put it here next to these cookies
because it's probably hungry man I mean
dude we haven't even started I know okay
calm down
do you see what I have to deal with
it's like having a toddler he's like
he's not he has like no it is not he has
like super short attention span what is
not we haven't even started talking
about the topic yet you're already like
man I'm so hungry well yeah again I
gotta get that out of my [ __ ] field
of vision so I can do the show
yeah okay sitting there looking at that
damn cookie button well yeah every now
and then I'm like oh I'm gonna like eat
a spoonful of that yeah but
if we're we hit uh hour one yet no 42
minutes okay it's about time we can do
it anyway because that's what
everybody's here we got a good crowd
yeah all right
that's good uh I want to do a couple of
shout outs which I haven't done for a
while now you might not have to go over
there see that pile of books right there
that's on my thingy yeah like bring that
we'll bring the whole pile I just need
one of them but just bring the whole box
well because it's too difficult to like
tell you which one actually I need the
third one down yes the one that I need
okay so all right now the first person I
want to thank we have our first new
Patron in a long time we haven't had any
new patrons in a while but we got a new
one the other day and I was very excited
uh so their name is Elliot so thank you
very much to our new Patron hopefully
you enjoy your time at patreon uh like I
said we do have a patreon if you're not
already I think most of you are probably
already on there but you get to like
vote on move your retrospectives you get
to vote on
uh what do you call it on topics for the
shows you get early access to some
videos [ __ ] like that also I want to say
thank you to
Robert Campbell who sent me a copy of
his book The Legend of the Cove witch
and it is
uh I believe it's signed and everything
like that yeah he signed it for me and
everything so I will be reviewing this
in a couple of weeks not this coming
week because I already like uh read the
book and reviewed it for this week but
I'll be doing that the week after that
also was it Sophie that sent that box
today yep so if you sent me a whole box
okay so today we had a box from Mackinac
Island sitting on our front porch and we
were like she's in it for my birthday
yeah oh and that's another thing yeah
you guys need to come on Friday night
for the Sidetrack show because Friday
will be my birthday it's Tom's birthday
yeah birthday I'm gonna I gotta order
him okay tomorrow 3 or 54 I forgot how
old he forgot to do the math I'm pretty
I'm trying to ignore it he's pretty sure
she's like it's her birthday I don't
know I think it's 53. I think it's 53
yeah oh wait it wasn't bad what year is
it July 1st 1969. yeah so that's 53 yeah
53. yeah I don't feel any different than
I did when I was [ __ ] 40
45. I don't either I feel about exactly
I mean I'll be 50 at the end of
September yeah but you know you're a
couple years ahead of me a couple years
ago
but yeah his birthday's on Friday so
yeah because of all the [ __ ]
paranormal [ __ ] I've done to myself by
injecting [ __ ] weird hormones and
stuff into me I feel better now than I
did at 40. I feel [ __ ] really good
well don't come crying to me when you
start like growing a second head or
something yeah Jenny got [ __ ] in my back
that's about it it's gonna do yeah
you can see no I'm a full supporter of
[ __ ] miss Health with [ __ ] hormone
replacement therapy [ __ ] dude I just
like human health I mean you know it's
not a man woman thing we're not that I
want to yeah
just keep keep yourself [ __ ] in
Balance you live a long time
eventually unless you get hit by a bus
which I hope you don't well
eventually cancer will get you
eventually if you were to lived 120
eventually eventually cancer gets cancer
unfortunately
until they figure out how to like fix
that [ __ ] right
but you know Hugo says Tom we're almost
the same age yeah Hugo was also saying
that those lemon cookies are good you're
hell right those because they are very
good they're very good I didn't even
know you had those in there he's been
like hiding things I got two packs of
this guy I never look in the freezer I
don't have any reason to because we have
an ice machine and then we have the
fridge but it has like the little
freezer compartment you know like the
mini fridge has and I never look in
there because why would I I got uh
Clover Valley copies of [ __ ] Chips
Ahoy in there too
those aren't bad either not bad no those
aren't bad either for like a dollar
it's what you get you get the chips away
I mean they're not they're wired milk
they're not quite as good as Chips Ahoy
but it's not really that big of a deal
you only pay them 97 cents that's what
I'm saying and I don't know how much
Chips Ahoy is because I'm a boss
probably
I would imagine like I said they might
be more than that I haven't maybe I'm in
a really long time like I said you know
I don't when I go to the grocery store
every now and then I'll buy some snacks
but usually I'll buy nuts or something
like that like it's kind of more healthy
yeah
um although I do like the Starbucks
coffee drinks those probably aren't that
healthy but
other than that I try not to like buy
cookies and stuff because like I said if
I have them in the house I'll just eat
them all and then I'll get fat so I'm
just not gonna have him I want them I
just don't wanna
have them around Jenny's at Jenny's at
that age where
you know what I mean you gotta [ __ ]
die a woman has to die I didn't believe
it at first but no
more science
I did the more I looked into it women do
well on calorie calorie restriction how
many times have I tried to tell you that
and he'll like listen to me
the way women work and the way men's
metabolism works is very different well
and the way like everybody's metabolism
is different not as different as you
think but yeah but I'm saying search
they're not that different I'm just
saying that it's like a bell curve you
know what I mean and it's like yeah
there's differences between men's
metabolism women's metabolism but
there's also differences from Individual
to individual yeah but they're not that
big they're not that big I've done the
research the difference is mostly
between male and female oh because males
are androgenized during puberty to be
oriented towards testosterone
and uh that means the anabolic steroids
also work on them better than they do on
women if you start giving women a bunch
of [ __ ] they just turn into men uh and
no one wants right if you want a woman
to remain a woman
but you want to pick her metabolism up
there's certain things that you can give
her to do that
uh all of it has to would fall in the
into the realm of replacement therapy or
hormone replacement therapy and they
don't really want you talking about them
they don't really want you doing it
because it's all black market [ __ ] and
they want you to the laws are pushing
you towards [ __ ] elective [ __ ]
treatments through doctors that want
[ __ ] a [ __ ] ton of money which means
they only want rich people to know that
stuff because they do it
and and [ __ ] celebrities and [ __ ] but
I know what they're doing
I know they're done Linux Warrior says
you both look good for your age thank
you thank you and we did stuff to look
this way
part of its Lifestyle the other parts
[ __ ] training and otherwise it's
[ __ ] therapies drug therapies some of
his genetics some of his genetics we
both have pretty good genetics
yeah uh you know it like I said in some
ways you know my genetics are not great
but in some ways my genetics are tend
toward like youthful looking yeah like
all the females in my family are like
very my mother's sucking for their age
my mother's side of the family are all
immortal like my grandmother died just
recently she nearly was a hundred
my mother's still going and all of her
she had nine sisters and her oldest
sister is still [ __ ] just rolling
along like a tank they don't die
because evil Never Dies
now my dad's side of the family were
[ __ ] um disposable people
usually dead early
predisposed towards diabetes shorter my
maternal grandmother is also still alive
she is in her 90s now my paternal
grandmother uh sadly passed away
when she was 80. I think she was 80.
yeah but my maternal grandmother is
still alive and my mom is well how old
am I 50 so she'd be 68. she's 18 years
older than me yeah and she still looks
fantastic and both of us ethnically are
southern
okay which is different than people
we're not a Scandinavian as Northern
caucasians we're more
Germanic and Celtic I'm a mongrel yeah
mixed with a Native American
and you know and some some of us
actually have African Heritage in us too
so because the South has South was kind
of like the South Africa of America
there's just different different blend
than what you'd have up north
we were the strong ones we're the
workers
although I'm just bullshitting because
up north too there was a lot of
Agriculture they they were the workers
too they were just the factory people
well yeah it's like like I said don't be
like [ __ ] on people up there because
they were like chocolate they probably
had like worse [ __ ] conditions yeah
they actually that's true way worse the
South has the [ __ ] there's the
stereotypes of the South was [ __ ]
poor and dumb
um The South was compared to the north
the north they didn't live well either
okay they lived in cities they didn't
live long and they [ __ ] worked in
factories and died they had Farmers up
there that did well they had guys up at
the Great Lakes doing [ __ ] great
things on like a little miniature sea
the South even though even in even in
the archaic eras and even in my
grandparents era
they weren't High income but they always
ate well everybody could Farm uh quality
of life in the South was always pretty
good and it didn't matter your race
black people did well here
um they actually when they migrated
North that's when their life got harder
for them it was just different times
different times times changed but we're
all children of the South it's all one
culture
you know southern people are all about
the same especially in the past
which Thomas Soul tell you all about
that you can find his Histories on
YouTube
DJ Maniac says self-control there's a
pile of candy bars and protein bars and
chips on my coffee table and I never
touched them unless I really need
something I mean I'm honestly I haven't
gotten that bad once I get into a groove
of like not eating all that much after a
couple of days it becomes much easier
and I don't think about it but I don't
really like having the [ __ ] around so
I'm like tempted you know what I mean
that's why I keep the big bag of candy
and usually like some gum because I'm
like look if I want something sweet I'll
just grab this 15 calorie like piece of
coffee candy or I'll have a cup of
coffee with you know some sweet and low
in it or I'll have like a piece of
peppermint gum and then it's like oh
it's like something sweet and then I
stop thinking about it you know what I
mean so it's kind of like that but once
I don't eat that much for a few days or
like a week or something it's like much
easier and I don't really like think
about it
um every time yeah some other health and
how many teeth they have still I have
all my teeth except one in the very very
back which broke off but other than that
like not like probably like a year or
two ago I had all my wisdom teeth
removed okay from an early age I only
missing one tooth and it's a tooth I
broke by biting into a damn piece of
damn
cinnamon you know that roll a piece of
cinnamon things that bit into one that's
what happened to my back too way back
there a clove got stuck like I bit into
like it was in something that I was
eating and it was like a whole clove and
it cracked I mean obviously the teeth
the tooth was probably like cracked
ahead of time or a clove wouldn't have
done it but it cracked off and then like
I just had half a tooth like and that's
like the way back in the back of the
tooth honestly like my wisdom teeth grew
in
and they didn't like I never had to have
them removed so I guess I had room in my
mouth yeah for them because I know a lot
of people have to have them removed
because you don't need damn teeth they
push to your teeth but they didn't do
that to me like I didn't even really
notice I was working at the barn with
the horses and I was making all their
feed buckets up and each horse was gonna
get a half a stick of cinnamon stick so
I was getting going through the cinnamon
biting the cinnamon sticks in half and
dividing them up in the buckets because
because the the horses don't care about
a little bit of [ __ ] spit you know
what I mean with the cinnamon stick yeah
they're like ew you just bit that but
yeah yeah the horses don't care they
love that [ __ ] the horse will get their
[ __ ] love on your face and [ __ ] but
I'm sitting here doing all the horses
know me anyway they all love me so I'm
making up all the buckets and I had them
biting cinnamon sticks for [ __ ] years
and one day I bit into a cinnamon stick
that was just a little shaved a little
bit too fat [ __ ] up I was like oh what
the [ __ ] happened
and I thought I was all right
and then over a period of a few months
[ __ ] that tooth kept bothering me
about one day it [ __ ]
I drank a bit of cold water and it set
me up the roof and I'd crack that tooth
and killed it and didn't know and it
slowly fell out in pieces
I was mad about that
it was my fault I shouldn't have been
doing that I mean it's not real
noticeable and you're it's not like way
back I mean it's in the back yeah and
mine is like like I said it might be the
wisdom tooth because it's the last tooth
like on my upper jaw yeah
and yeah I bit into a clove and it
cracked yeah like a couple I think it
was two years ago yeah I was having you
bite on that damn plastic pin to break
that tooth out well I kept trying to
because I was trying to like pull the
whole thing out yeah because I was just
kind of it didn't hurt or anything it
was just kind of like annoying because
it's annoying because it was sharp
that's some Southern redneck ways of
doing Dentistry don't go because Dennis
[ __ ] break that tooth out well yeah
well I would have gone to a dentist but
I can't afford it yeah the thing is I'm
not a dental insurance the thing is
though is that the thing is though is
that he would have done anything for you
that really he just would have pulled it
out but he was paid the hundreds of
dollars you got that [ __ ] done yourself
I mean it's still like the root of it is
still in there except mine's in there
too but it doesn't hurt yeah as long as
it doesn't hurt it's a pain in the ass
because like if I eat something it gets
stuck in there but it's like other than
that it's all right you're not missing
enough teeth to worry about it my dad my
dad by the time he was [ __ ] 60 half
of his teeth were gone just because of
diabetes well you know what's
interesting I can dodge that diabetes
bullet that's [ __ ] half the battle
right there my grandmother
she um she had three boys so she was
pregnant three times and she said being
pregnant she's like it leached all the
calcium out of my body and my teeth
started falling out which I I guess was
like not I don't know if it was common
but it wasn't unheard of yeah and when
she was fairly young they had to pull
all her teeth and like give her Dentures
so she had Dentures from like maybe when
she was in her 40s yeah which is crazy
but yeah she had Dentures like as long
as I knew her you're talking about
biting into praying mantises and all
kinds of weird [ __ ] everybody yeah we
know you all have [ __ ] yourselves up
as [ __ ] worse than us or whatever I
mean I've been very I've been very very
lucky in the sense that I've never had
anything
horribly I've never broken a bone I've
sprained several bones uh you know I had
to have a cast on my ankle one time
because I fell down some stairs and like
but it didn't break because my I have
like horse bones seriously they're like
this big but um so I had that so I had
to have a cast for that but
other than that you know when I have a
back tooth I don't to be honest I don't
um I don't get diseases I don't get he
thinks it's funny because I don't like I
I don't react to like medicines or
anything like that the same way it's
just very subdued
I'm not really sure like even when I was
a kid like there'd be oh my God
everyone's got chickenpox I got like
three chicken pox for like a couple of
days and then it went away legendary
double 07 says Aloha from Hawaii wow hey
hey how you doing [ __ ] surf with a
lot of men from the [ __ ] from the
islands one of my one of my uh best
buddies doing the services from Hawaii
his name is Verna nudesco we went to
basic training together to serve all
four years a little short stocky Island
boy man he could kick [ __ ] ass I got
in contact with him recently he's living
on the continent now he didn't go back
to the island
but yeah I guess once you get them boys
off the island and they come to the
continent they don't really want to go
back marry the white girl [ __ ] got a
whole family and everything did with
Vernon New dasco good buddy of mine from
Hawaii looking and he was genetically
from Hawaii he was an island boy
it was good to see you here but he said
he said he subbed after seeing your
video reviews of Richard Layman that
must be something you do yeah yeah yeah
um I plan to do like some more of those
because I have like a weird relationship
with Richard Layman he's passed away
like he passed away many years ago but
his novels
I've done two right I did come out
tonight and I did body rides yeah the
dudes they're very entertaining I will
say that but they're also like
I don't even know how I want to like put
this but yeah they're they're fun
they're fun to review they're fun to
read they're fun to review they're not
good literature or anything but they're
kind of like I don't know it's like a
weird like roller coaster and he had
like some very very strange
fetishes that kept like coming up in his
work which I found like really
fascinating so you know there's that
I'll probably like do some more [ __ ]
because I have a couple more of his
novels that I read like a long time ago
that I'll probably get around to
reviewing at some point but yeah so
there's that so I'm glad you're here
we'll talk more about Richard Lehman
later
all right so we've been going for like
an hour so can I can I actually like
talk about the [ __ ] we're now gonna get
into oh we're now gonna oh did whoever
it was that recommended the F fall
Wilson movie or uh book The keep look I
bought it so is that the movie it's well
this is it's based on this okay so it
was really good I'll be reviewing this
sometime in August I have like two books
that authors have sent me that I have to
do like first but then I'll be doing
that one if you all haven't seen the
movie The keep it's a uh it's a good
movie I think I read that before but it
was a long time ago it's kind of like a
uh it's a Jewish
Horror Story Revenge Type story that
involves the Nazis in something kind of
like a Golem but it was a great movie
and I think Tangerine Dream did the uh
uh didn't they do the the they may have
they did a lot of film scores right
around that time period I liked it right
around this time the keep it's a classic
and it's a sleeper classic because it
was good quality movie I still want to
review the movie as well because I like
to see we got to see that movie and I
really want to I think I read this when
I was younger
um but I didn't have it so I was like
they had like a used one for like a buck
or something so I was just kind of like
okay I'm having that Wicked hack says hi
from Sweden holy crap okay damn even
Sweden's calling us now man we got who's
that now Sweden Wicked hag Wicked that's
a great name John Gore said Jenny should
review some James L Roy oh I'll get
around to that uh yeah legendre 007 says
I was interested in your reaction many
reviewers are fumingly offended by
Richard Layman's sexism but you laughed
it off yeah to me it's uh
it's so
um over the top that it's like hard not
to laugh at like I can't get offended by
something that egregious you know what I
mean it's just I don't know it's just
really funny if you know you know like
if you've read any of this [ __ ] I'm just
kind of like okay Richard you know what
I mean it's very very funny I think it's
[ __ ] hilarious if people get offended
especially by things from a long time
ago there was a really good uh novel of
[ __ ] Illustrated novel that I read
and it was called uh something or other
the Stars the Stars my destination
and it was written in the 50s but I read
the [ __ ] comic book
in the 80s
and it's about a dude in the future a
future
space-faring society that was tribal and
there was a lot of sexism in it
and I saw reviews on YouTube and these
modern girls were talking about how
sexist it was
well what the [ __ ] you talking about
it's like Mad Max in space you know what
I mean well and it was written along it
was written a long time ago but it was
still it was happening in its own
Universe you know what I mean things are
not there is no linear progression in
history per se I mean human history is
[ __ ] close to 8 000 years old we
don't know everything that happened in
the past
things go up and down all right it's
very possible that a futuristic Society
could be [ __ ] sexist or racist
things don't track along a certain
course people have other opinions Wars
happen things change I just don't see a
human species choose that back or
sideways or just anything can happen
human beings are real flexible I mean I
you know yeah a few centuries ago you
had [ __ ] dancing themselves to
death in [ __ ] dancing diseases and
weird [ __ ] witch panics you can't
predict what these crazy [ __ ]
will do I mean I can't I get offended by
stuff that is actually
that will actually like affect laws or
like affect people's lives you know a
Richard Layman novel uh you know that's
not gonna affect anybody's life I mean
and the fact that he writes yes the [ __ ]
he writes is very weird and like sexist
and he obviously had some interesting uh
views about women like the way that he
writes women is like very it's mostly
just funny to me I don't know if he
meant it to be funny like I said he died
so I don't really know but I mean to me
it just comes across as funny because
it's obviously
out there and it's obviously just like
his own fantasies like so I'm not like
offended by fiction like you know what I
mean if I'm reading a novel and there's
like something offensive in there I'm
just kind of like oh okay whatever the
whatever and it's like if it's you know
if it's enough that I'm just kind of
like I don't even want to read this I
don't care anymore then I'll just like
[ __ ] you know not read the rest of
the book and not give a [ __ ] get offend
if you get offended easily then you
should have no well the thing about
talking to talking about or should have
no business reason uh reading [ __ ]
Lovecraft
because Lovecraft was [ __ ]
he was like from another era
[ __ ] was racist and [ __ ]
weird oh my God he was you know he was
racist again so so he was racist against
white people and he was raised against
everybody
except himself a very particular just
Anglo America like anglo-americally if
you were just like a shade darker if you
were an irish-american you were no good
but the thing is is that that
[ __ ] was weird and if he wasn't
weird his writing wouldn't have been any
good yeah we kind of so we did a show
about HP Lovecraft where I was just kind
of like you know yeah today it's like
the way that he writes him [ __ ] like
yeah go read horror at Red Hook um if
you think the dude wasn't racist okay
but I mean he obviously was but he was
also he also had like some severe mental
issues but if he didn't have those
mental issues he wouldn't have written
any good what he wrote Because all he
did he was afraid of anything he was
afraid of everything and yeah and that's
what made him like come up with the
whole Mythos because he she was afraid
of literally everything he wouldn't even
leave his [ __ ] house right he
wouldn't and he didn't like to look at
other people in the eye I mean he was
just that sheltered and it wasn't that
it was like yeah evil it wasn't evil or
hatred [ __ ] was just innocent he
was very innocent and childlike I mean
fearful he was just fearful of
everything if if you were different than
him then die you damn you know he lived
in a world where everything was evil
basically
but he wrote some [ __ ] badass horror
he was paranoid
yeah you know and which helps yeah
unusual people can create great art
you know and it doesn't matter [ __ ]
you know you're like yeah he's
politically man [ __ ] all that that what
that [ __ ] rep rut was weird well
yeah I mean but well because you had to
be somebody you had to be [ __ ] like
way to write that weird ass [ __ ] and it
was good right something not bizarre and
here's there was a Redemption you know
people I don't like the [ __ ] like
Past final judgment on people for what
they believe people believe certain
things and it doesn't matter what race
they are there's a lot of [ __ ] crazy
people believe crazy [ __ ] what was great
about him is that he did kind of have a
little bit of a Redemption redemption or
he married a Jewish woman who kind of
helped
introduce him to other people and he
kind of grew up some he was she moved
him to New York City where she was from
he didn't like it yeah he was very young
he was developed he was very
um like you said Sherry shelter so it
opened him up so yeah and everybody
everybody said as he got older he wasn't
it wasn't that weird it's softened it
softened up he was he realized that
people were people
and and you know what his writing Pro
had he lived longer his writing probably
would have suffered because you have to
have a weird [ __ ] who's in his
own damn world to come with that [ __ ]
yeah pretty much yeah I don't care what
race he was if he was a [ __ ] black
dude writing that [ __ ] out of her lovely
wrote yeah that's weird you know it's
just the way it works
Danny Rowling said July is almost here
can't wait for your Jello film reviews
yeah in case you didn't know my uh
flickers of fear I'm doing all July I'm
doing all geology movies so I've already
recorded two of the reviews yes I'm
gonna do disco path uh at some point uh
because that's on maybe I got it right
[ __ ] Lovecraft must have been freaked
out when he got the [ __ ] he was a scary
Italian like I said yeah he'd have been
scared of it like I said he was scared
of well he was scared of every he was
scared of everything
yeah they're not me yeah oh no we had an
idealized conception of what a person
should be a person should have been an
anglo-american directly [ __ ] with a
lineage direct back to England
yeah Britain
not Ireland
or whales they were all Savages just
[ __ ] Britain you know or England you
know and it was just like a xenophobe
there were some very old English people
that still think that yeah that still
think that the Scots and the will sure
like but what was weird is that that was
not the life he was living I think
that's that was not the life he was
living he was an American and he was uh
I think he was a weird guy who kind of
fetishized
his ethnic Heritage I think he was
making it more in making more out of it
than it really was it was just some kind
of a fantasy idealism that he had
because everything I can come up with
about American history most people
weren't like that
even most most well I kind of feel like
the thing about it and you see this a
lot with like white supremacists and
stuff like that they're never like the
[ __ ] ideal uh thing of like the white
race they're always some like [ __ ]
fat like toothless [ __ ] yeah
like the white racist about I'm like oh
and you're the main example well because
it's because you feel like you don't
have anything else to offer so it's like
my race is the only thing that I have to
skate on I guess so it's just kind of I
kind of feel like that might be a that
might be a factor might be a factor I
think when you don't have anything else
to compete on you're just like some fat
toothless [ __ ] living in a
trailer you're looking at you you're
looking at it a little bit wrong though
what it is is it's coming oh am I yeah
because what it is is you're looking at
it they're coming from an error and
they're coming from the angle of
feelings of inferiority
they're trying to be better than what
they are and that is around well that's
what I'm saying right that's exactly
what I'm saying so you so you're saying
I'm wrong but I'm not that's not that's
pretty much then I misinterpreted that's
pretty much exactly what I said and I
misinterpreted what you were saying I
said they don't really have anything
else to offer in the sense that they're
not really like you know they're not
super smart or they're not talented or
anything like that so it's like the only
thing I have is my race I'm a white
person so it's like they want that to be
like the end-all be-all because if they
had to compete on a Level Playing Field
then they would lose yeah well here's
the mistake it doesn't matter what race
you are if you if that's all you have if
that's all you have going for you is the
identification with your ethnic group
and there's not much to you exactly
that's what I was just saying okay
that's what I was just saying I
misunderstood what you're saying yeah
you did no there's because that's
exactly doesn't matter what it doesn't
matter what ethnic group or race you are
if that's all there is to you then
there's not much there
because but that's why I think people
hit that so hard because that's all they
have going for them that's what I said
that's all they have to do for them
they're not super talented they're not
super smart they don't have anything
else to offer they don't have the money
they don't have any money it's like yeah
I'm I'm a white person and that should
be enough it's like I don't like all
these other like when you look at them
they're not even the good looking white
people that's what I'm saying they're
like the second or third rate
that's what I'm saying yeah that's why
you see that yeah that's why you see
every time that somebody account is only
white power it's always just kind of
like some [ __ ] look at the dude yeah
that's why because that's all that [ __ ]
has to like that's that's the only
pillar that he has to stand on he
doesn't have anything else to offer the
world other than that yeah and it's fear
too uh yeah big time it's always fear
hey well the root of hatred is always
yeah yeah I don't remember the dude's
name that had a black dude who his his
whole thing was to go to Clan rallies
he went to the clan rally to go meet all
these Clan guys and he'd become friends
with him
and he's blacked it
and he'd become friends with him because
he liked classic cars
and he would start talking to all these
Clan dudes about cars and they loved
that dude they made him an honorary Clan
member
did this fight didn't Spike Lee make a
movie about that I don't know but over
time
over time them Clan guys were like well
wait a minute hold on
you know what I mean he's black and he's
our friend
so maybe there's nothing to [ __ ] fear
and this guy wrote a whole book about
the way you dissolve racism is that you
become friends with those guys and tell
them that there's really nothing to fear
well yeah that does usually work but I
will give a caveat to that though yeah
because there is kind of a thing like if
you're really entrenched like for
example in your racism or whatever if
you're very entrenched in that and you'd
befriend let's say you're a white dude
and you're really entrenched in your
racism you're in the KKK or whatever the
[ __ ] yeah
um and you befriend a black person it
takes more than just one because a lot
of times
I saw this happen with a relative who I
won't name
um but it's kind of like a thing where
oh well most of the black people suck
but you're good you're one of the good
ones yeah yeah because I know you right
and you're yeah so you have to overcome
that too because like I said they're so
entrenched in their beliefs that they'll
just like they'll justify anything I
don't remember the dude's name you guys
could drop it in the comment section and
I'll give it a shout out but that guy I
think he wrote books about it
and uh
I'm [ __ ] I listened to interviews
with him he was very interesting he
destroyed an entire chapter of the Ku
Klux Klan by making friends with him
and it took years but a lot of those
guys ended up leaving the clan
because they realized that they didn't
really have anything to be afraid of and
he liked all those guys in the clan he
said their problem was is that they were
just fearful of everything and they
thought black people were going to come
and hurt them well I think that's
largely the problem with a lot of these
kind of dumbass [ __ ] yes is
they're just like afraid of everything
the moral of the story is that you can't
you can't defeat that kind of stuff by
force yeah do you see that's what I
thought Spike Lee made black klansman
that was called black klansman okay yeah
especially made a movie about you can't
defeat that kind of stuff by force you
can you can only do it by becoming
friends with them and say look and
chilling them out that there's nothing
well I think that's why you see you know
you attack them they'll get stronger
I told you they're coming after us
so you can't do it that way and the
thing about it is like you know if you
hear like people like [ __ ] on you
all the time and this happens like with
everything like do you hear people
[ __ ] on like oh black people are gay
people or whatever yeah you know it's
it's just kind of like you don't want to
hear that like said that about you all
the time so it's like you don't like
those people you know I don't like those
people but in a lot of ways it's
probably better to at least like
approach them and like see hey what the
[ __ ] is your deal because like I said
most of them are just afraid they don't
understand they don't know anybody they
don't know any black people they don't
know any gay people they don't know any
trans people they don't know anything
you know they don't know anything like
that so they don't have any like once
they understand that those are just like
people maybe they'll like [ __ ] knock
it off and stop being such douchats but
you know I don't know it's a maybe I
don't know if that's gonna happen though
but we'll see not the way shit's going
nowadays but we'll see
uh DJ Maniac says there's another dude
in more recent times that befriends them
again then gets them to burn their robes
I mean they're doing I don't even
believe in God but they're doing the
Lord's work I mean I wouldn't have the
patience to do that I would just like
you know my first instinct is I just
want to like punch him in the dick but
if you have the patience and the
wherewithal
you know bless you
because I really do think that's the
best way to approach people like the
most of the time some people are just
like lost causes and those people you
should shouldn't waste time on which
just like [ __ ] put them out of their
misery but most people are okay it's
just that they don't
you know in their day-to-day lives they
don't experience anything different uh
so they don't understand and if you
don't understand it then you're afraid
of it so I think that's kind of where a
lot of the problem comes from you know
uh
yeah yeah we really do need to get to
the topic I mean seriously maybe I can
start now that Tom's not here all right
so finally finally after an hour and 17
minutes I mean we kind of like talked
about a little bit
we're going to talk about [ __ ]
spiritualism
all right so
a lot of the uh information we've like I
said we've done a lot of shows about
spiritualism or you know Seance or
something like that we've done kind of
like shows about different aspects of it
different factors of it so I try to like
kind of like give the main like gist but
I also kind of want to like bring in
some like new information or some kind
of new angles on it so hopefully
everybody will uh you know get something
out of it
so I was reading this article this
really good like in-depth article about
spiritualism uh I think it was in the
New Yorker and it was like came out like
in summer of 2021 or something like that
and according to this article they said
even nowadays because I kind of feel
like people think about spiritualism as
you know oh a Victorian era thing which
it was
but so many people still believe in
aspects of it that it's almost kind of
like I mean more people probably believe
in the same kind of like spirituals even
though they wouldn't call it that I kind
of feel like more people believe in it
now than they did back then
because according to at least as of 2021
a third of Americans
say that they've communicated with
someone who's dead like they've talked
to somebody like one of their relatives
that's passed over and
uh Americans also spend about two
billion dollars a year on Psychic kind
of stuff like paying psychics or doing
that kind of like uh thing so obviously
it's still like a pretty widespread
belief right
um and honestly like as far as like new
age beliefs go if you want to go kind of
like all out on the new age stuff
people the amount of people that believe
in it nowadays are probably pretty
comparable to who believed in it in the
Heyday of like the 19th century yeah
like or we're like spiritualism in
general like you know that you can
communicate with the dad or you can
communicate with ghosts or something
like that I kind of feel like a lot of
people still believe in it so it's not
really something that's in the past you
know what I mean so I mean you even have
spiritualists
towns one of which I've been to is right
here in Florida Cassadaga
it's all like psychics I mean people
live there too obviously but it's kind
of like a spiritualist camp it was
founded by spiritualists and a lot of
them still live there and they do like
psychic readings and stuff uh there's
another one in Lilydale in New York but
yeah like tons of those they still have
like all kind of like rage kind of like
lectures and stuff like that and like
thousands of people still go to those
um as far as I know as as of 2021 there
are still like hundreds of spiritualist
churches in the United States uh there's
even more than that in the UK and in
Europe
so people are still doing it the thing
about it is that there's not that many
spiritualist churches because
spiritualism as a belief system
one of the
um I think one of the like most
attractive things about it is that it's
not you know based around the hierarchy
or anything like that you don't need a
church you don't need to go to the
church you can just do like your own
[ __ ] so I think that's kind of like why
people found it attractive especially
like back in the old days which I kind
of want to get into because the context
behind why
the rise of spiritualism happened when
it did
probably had a lot to do with people
that were I mean it's just kind of like
you see in like say the 1960s when
everybody was like looking for new
spiritual Avenues because you know
traditional religions had not really
been
uh you know we're not really doing it
for people anymore and I kind of feel
like that maybe happened too like in the
19th century because
particularly in the United States you
had a kind of a context where we just
come out of the Civil War
um you know and a lot of people had died
and I'll kind of get into that being a
big thing too but I kind of feel like
this Society had become a lot more
mobile as in people were kind of like
moving out west and like cutting ties
with their families and things like that
um which hadn't really happened all that
much like in previous eras you also had
you know the industrial revolution had
just happened people were kind of like
like I said there were people like
immigrating everywhere and societies
were becoming more pluralistic
especially in the United States so I
kind of feel like people needed like a
community but they didn't really like
the sort of hierarchical
authoritarian kind of stuff that
religion had been bringing like up to
this point you know what I mean so I
think people were kind of like sick of
that particularly in the U.S where it
was very like yeah
you know particularly in the US where it
was very like individualistic I think
that
spiritualism was very attractive to them
in particular because you didn't need to
go to a church you didn't need a
minister you didn't need somebody
telling you what to do you could just
believe in the tenets of spiritualism
and no one was going to tell you oh
there's these all these rules you have
to live by or you have to you know tithe
or you have to do this that and the
other thing they didn't like restrict
your whole life it was very
I don't want to say it was like casual
but it wasn't
it wasn't as strict yeah it wasn't
strict yeah the US was always lacks on
it was like an open market for
for religion you know what I mean there
was
there was no state-run religion so it
was an open market for it nobody was
making you do anything
yeah and the thing about it too was like
it was very popular in the UK too which
actually does have a state Church yeah
um because like I said people were you
know you had like the Protestant Church
which was you know kind of like man like
from the Catholic church but people kind
of wanted their own [ __ ] it's like I
don't want to have to go to church every
week I don't want to have to have all
these rules that it's like I don't you
know people didn't really like that oh
I'm going to hell if I do this like
little bitty thing you can see how that
would get tiresome after a while yeah so
I kind of feel like that was
sort of where a lot of the um
where it was coming from and like I said
too I think the one of the things that
was kind of contributed to the rise of
spiritualism at least in the U.S and in
the UK as well was the kind of like
scientific discoveries as we mentioned
earlier you know you had all of this
stuff coming out that nowadays everybody
takes for granted but back then it was
like photography and radio telegraphs
like stuff like that which was
you know to an uneducated person would
seem like akin to Magic so it's like oh
my God like you can take a picture of
something that like captures a moment in
time I can set a telegraph to somebody
like across the ocean and I can't
there's no wires I can't see how it
travels like how does the message travel
so it might have seemed if you didn't
understand it like some kind of magic
and I think that extrapolated outward to
you know maybe people could communicate
with people that have already died it
didn't seem crazy at that time and I can
see why it didn't seem crazy because
people were discovering like you said
electricity city was becoming big
telegraph was becoming big x-rays like I
mean that was a little bit later but
yeah all that kind of stuff where it's
like stuff that was invisible but was
still like having effects in the real
world that you could see and so people
were thinking oh well it's not that
crazy yeah to think that dead people
might have gone beyond some Veil
somewhere and they can still communicate
with us think about this
I can talk into a microphone here
and somebody [ __ ] 50 miles away can
hear what I'm saying somebody in Sweden
Hawaii I hear what you're saying that
would have been paranormal almost yeah
yeah they were like because they quite
it you know the electromagnetic spectrum
radio
to them that was like it was invisible
so [ __ ] that's paranormal it's like the
spirit world yeah which like I said I
give like the people back then because
back I mean there were a lot of like
very prominent scientists which I want
to get into in a bit
um that were spiritualists and they saw
no
there was no conflict
because they're like hey if a telegraph
if I can send a message to somebody
across the ocean yeah without any wires
or without anything and it's invisible
like in between it it's invisible
why not yeah
um which like I said that's completely
that's a completely rational uh thought
process it's just like another dimension
sure you know yeah it's going across
that space there why not into the spirit
world yeah
of course think about it radio waves
into the spirit world
because I can understand why they would
think that yeah exactly yeah that's what
I'm saying so you know it's very easy
nowadays for us to look back at you know
scientists like you know Pierre and uh
Mary Curie and like you know Alfred
Russell Wallace it was you know
evolutionary ballots people like that
who would go to seances and sort of like
believed in it but it was considered
almost like I don't know if it was
considered like scientific but it was
like on the fringes of science at the
time like in a lot of really prominent
scientists did believe in it and did
actually like kind of go to the stuff
and a little bit later like it started
being like detrimental to your
reputation like if you went but in the
early days I kind of feel like all bets
were off because it was very open still
because no one really understood how
everything worked you know so I don't
know I mean yeah but that's kind of like
that's how science works though that's
just kind of like there's always going
to be [ __ ] we don't understand that we
have to like figure out you know what I
mean which you know that's just how it
goes the world is the world the world
the world the universe the cosmos that's
like a lot bigger than us we're just
like some evolved Apes who figured some
[ __ ] out and we're only seeing it
through certain senses yeah
and you know and well
we're only seeing it through certain
senses but we've also at least been
smart enough to like invent some
apparatus some apparatus that will like
allow us to see other sense that we
can't see like you know we've obviously
invented like ultraviolet you know
things like we can't see that radar you
know to see like invisible things so
we're at least smart enough to do that
but we're smart but we're not that smart
so we always have to like keep [ __ ]
going but so I can say I can see why
so many scientists were into this back
in the day because it seemed like this
was like The Cutting Edge of science
we're just kind of like you know yeah we
did Telegraph yeah we did photographs
which like I said seemed kind of like
magical when they first came out you
know and television too like a little
bit later they're like well it's so it's
not that crazy to think that maybe we
can like talk to dead people you know
like that maybe it's not that it's like
I said it's not that out there
I mean yeah so you had people like
Frederick Douglass you had people like
Mark Twain you had Queen Victoria for
Christ's sake like they all showed up at
seances whether they were Believers or
not or whether they were just going
because it was like the end thing to do
it was very very trendy
um during this time period but you know
a lot of people did actually go and the
spiritualism it was like a big [ __ ]
deal like I said they don't call it that
nowadays it's still a big [ __ ] deal
but back then it was like such a big
deal that
um according to this article that I read
they said they there was a new book on
spiritualism being published like every
week pretty much
um and they had the spiritualist
movement had more than a hundred like
magazines and newspapers like of their
own like just where they're like that
came out like all the time like during
this time period
so you know lectures all kind of [ __ ]
all over the country that they were
doing this stuff
now as I said they don't really know I
mean they know when spiritualism started
but they um
but because it's not real codified like
the belief system
um you know there were obviously
precedents to the belief systems didn't
come out of nowhere in other words now
so as we said there was kind of like a
big
religious
flowering Revival whatever the start in
the early 19th century mostly started it
started like up in the uh up in uh New
York State
which was a place later known as the
burned over District
and this was like what's known as the
Second Great Awakening
so this was a Protestant religious
revival uh again started the early 19th
century at least in the U.S and their
whole thing was there the way that they
gave like the preaching and stuff like
that was more like emotional they was
like tent revivals that kind of stuff
and the fact that people were going to
these and the fact that they were tied
to a lot of like social reform movements
like I said anti-slavery like women's
suffrage stuff like that so that like
attracted a lot of people and as I said
a lot of people were kind of tired of
the whole hierarchical you know
traditional religious framework because
it wasn't really working for them
so this was like hugely hugely popular
um and in a way too as I mentioned
earlier I think it kind of
change the religious climate in the U.S
I kind of feel like because
previously you would have traditional
religions where you had a church you had
to go and the minister would tell you
what to do and those rules and stuff
like that but now all of these new kind
of movements that came along were kind
of like well
you know it was more like
individualistic in the sense you don't
have to go to church you don't have to
follow these rules you just have to like
believe this but we're not going to like
enforce it you know what I mean yeah
look before before we go on any further
a lot of times when when we read things
or hear about things like this we tend
to think that it's part of like a
progressive
uh [ __ ] move a progressive thing
that's unfolding to where people are no
longer listening to religion
actually no
we're talking about certain places in
time
it was not a kind of a linear thing
where it slowly got less and less
religious
what we're talking about here is in this
certain place in time you could go back
to the Middle Ages where religion was
relaxed it was a it was a bunch of
Cycles little Cycles it always always
depended up upon where and when what
country what area what time we're
talking about
if you get strict on people eventually
this is going to be pushback and then
people won't buy into it anymore and
it'll get lacks for a while and then the
generations change out and then it'll
try to get a little strict again
so no I just wanted to point that out is
that it's this this isn't happening at
the global scale this is America
where this is happening at this time
well and and the UK and parts of the UK
English-speaking World Europe yeah I
mean there were times in the Middle Ages
where it was kind of like this too
but it would only last for a few
Generations then it would go back it
wasn't any kind of linear progression in
any of this well nothing is like I said
most most things are like cyclical but
if you read a history book they'll make
you think that there's a linear well
because that's the way I mean that's the
way a movie goes and that's how fiction
goes so it's like they want to like keep
everybody like on the same thing but
that's not but it's like a narrative but
that's not that's not the way it happens
in reality
um this is uh local English-speaking
World more or less to certain certain
expense Spain uh maybe a little bit of
the new world they were along with it
but this wasn't happening in China at
this time this wasn't happening in India
you know just it's just kind of funny we
got to take ourselves out of the normal
uh [ __ ] constraints of looking at
things and so that's all I wanted to say
another thing I think that people found
attractive about spiritualism in
particular and like some of the new
religious reform movements in general
was that it sort of like rejected the
idea of hell it gave people like a more
comforting idea of the afterlife like
you know your relatives are still
they're in a better place and you know
you can still communicate with them and
it made like death seem less scary
because like I said you have to think
prior to this time most people were do
you know Catholicism like or hard more
hardcore like traditional religions that
said oh if you [ __ ] up you're going to
hell and you'll be tormented forever
which is not a real good yeah thing to
like tell people to be honest I don't I
don't think it scares people into good
behavior I think it just
they told people that whether or not
they believed it would depend on the
place or time too that's what I'm saying
I I just don't think it's that crazy
thing to like tell people it's like a
terrible it's a terrible terrible idea
whoever came up with that shame on you
I'm sure you're long dead now I think
the evidence kind of shows that the air
that many people didn't believe what the
church said no matter what the time
frame because they did the opposite or
they were just kind of like well
whatever [ __ ] it yeah whatever they
didn't worry about it I think people
mostly didn't give a [ __ ] they're like I
would hope not most people believe that
they were full of [ __ ]
I hope so I hope that most people at
least have that much Common Sense the
ruling class definitely knew that they
were full of [ __ ] they didn't [ __ ]
believe what the [ __ ] Church said
yeah because the early class did
whatever they wanted
yeah like yeah I'm sure I'm going to
hell whatever ruling class can pay the
church to to say things
like I said the
turkey all that kind of stuff they had
to know at some level yeah uh yeah at
least the the higher ups had to know
they were full of [ __ ] because they were
just kind of like oh we're gonna like
people pay us for dispensation and all
that kind of stuff yeah sure whatever
you're a serial killer your sins are
absolved yeah like that well with this
baby that died unbaptized they're going
out in many ways in many ways they were
like the corporate Media or television
of their era you know I mean the really
class told paid them and told them what
to tell the people to keep you know you
tell them that rats are fish it's gonna
be fine well they were trying to keep
everybody in line right yeah yeah you
know if you guys don't think that that's
bullshits no it's absolutely true the
church told people that rats were fish
and that they could eat them on Friday
yeah yeah I remember that
rats are not fish okay well obviously
sorry to break that to anybody that
still thought that in the 20s yes
[ __ ] you know but yeah
one of the things too that I feel like
is not really exploring all that much
one of the things that uh was attractive
about spiritualism in particular was
that it was one of the very few
religious Traditions that allowed women
to be in positions of power
um and like I said spiritualism it's
kind of hard to say because it's sort of
like scatter shot it's like not a
hierarchical you know there's no
I'm not the Cardinal of spiritualism
it's just very kind of like you know
it's just kind of like all over the
place and you could just like join if
you wanted but they didn't have any
qualms about letting a woman like give
lectures or which in the Victorian era
was kind of a big deal and honestly
uh from my research they said that
sometimes
uh spiritualist lectures or you know
seances or whatever that was like the
first time that a lot of people had seen
like a woman like speaking like
authoritatively like in public like
because that was just not something that
was done that was usually something that
like a dude was doing so the fact that
everybody's doing it and everyone was
fine with it
um was kind of like revolutionary for
the time as well uh that it wasn't
really
all that kind of thing because the thing
about spiritualism in particular was
that
it kind of like took what are supposedly
or had traditionally been feminine
attributes uh sensitivity uh you know
things like that and made that like a
positive whereas before whereas before
it had kind of been seen as like a
weakness
um it made it spiritualism was kind of
like oh well women in general are more
um you know they're more sensitive to
the spirits they're more sensitive
that's why you saw more female mediums
than male ones I really did see male
ones too and nobody like you know [ __ ]
on that but
the fact that
you know so it was kind of like taking
all of the stuff that had kind of been
denigrated about like the female uh you
know experience or female attributes and
was like making that like that's good or
that's okay and I think that that was
something that a lot of people hadn't
seen in the Victorian era as well so I
think that was kind of something uh
again that was very attractive uh to
people during this time period it was
just like a lot of kind of like factors
that sort of like uh came in and like I
said you saw too A lot of the early
seances and things like that
you kind of see the relationship between
the spiritualists and a lot of like the
Abolitionist Movement Like the women's
suffrage movement and stuff like that
because you'd see like seances they
would
you know whatever Spirits they were
talking to which I'm sure it was
[ __ ] but all the spirits they were
talking to would be like hey you should
give women the right to vote or hey
let's let's not like you know let's
let's more like let's not have slavery
like all that kind of stuff so you can
tell that it was like those kind of
people that were kind of like getting
involved in it which like I said I
thought that was kind of they were all
like idealists which I thought was like
kind of cool let me say something on the
side to Legendary 2007 or or not 2007
but 007 he said I read most ancient
cultures like the Sumerians the Greeks
thought the cultural change it was in
Cycles like seasons
and that the zoroastrians and the
Christians thought the history went to a
final conclusion uh yeah most cultures
believe in cyclical history and and
things happening in Cycles but the
zoroastrians and the Christians were
kind of like a uh
what you would call a an apocalyptic
mindset where there's a beginning a
middle and an end a final end
which I think is really kind of like the
uh the Genesis of progressivism
that you're here and you slowly progress
up above above and above to some kind of
final conclusion
so uh yeah yeah you're right
um even though a lot of
I would say progressives
like neo-marxist progressives they don't
want to admit it but they're they're
Christian in thinking all this thing's
about lions laying down with lambs and
going to a final conclusion where the
Earth is destroyed by fire and
you know
everything that everything that
everything that [ __ ]
I guess you could say
uh
progressives believe in is a it's a
Christian Motif and there was a lot of
zoroastrian influence
and uh Christianity
there was a lot of Greek influence too
you know
but that's all mythicism and of course
if you've been a long time listen
listener 007 you would know that I'm a
Christian mythicist all right I believe
in
Christian mythicism I don't believe it's
historical at all nothing I don't even
believe that there was a Jesus I believe
that it's basically it's a an
amalgamation of a bunch of myths
all right she's back you ready Jen
Born Ready she's real she's born ready
I'm gonna go the restaurant
yeah
all right so where was I oh there was
another thing too where
spiritualism didn't have a thing
um it didn't have like a monopoly
they're like hey if you're a Protestant
or if you're a Quaker or you're whatever
the hell
um you don't have to like renounce your
other beliefs you can just kind of like
incorporate the spiritualist kind of
really because they weren't like super
like I said they weren't super
hierarchical they weren't super so if
you just want to like incorporate their
beliefs like on top of your existing
belief system that was okay too like
they were very accepting they were very
kind of like yeah man we're just kind of
like we'll take everybody if as long as
you're like cool and you like believe it
so I don't know so I can see how that
would have been very attractive like
during this time period
so as I mentioned uh there have been a
couple speculations including you know
including by Arthur Conan Doyle which
we'll get into a in a little bit because
he was like a big spiritualist as well
and was actually one of their early like
historians
but there were some kind of like older
like religious philosophical figures
that were kind of like precursors I
guess
um probably the one that gets brought up
the most is like Emmanuel swedenborg uh
who's from he was actually born in the
1680s and uh he was Swedish
and uh he was kind of like a theologian
but also like a scientist and an
inventor and also he was really into
like mysticism and stuff and he started
having like he seemed like kind of going
on like the normal track uh that you
would go on if you were like a Christian
uh you know Theologian and a scientist
during this time period but then when he
was older and like about the age of 53
he started having visions now the first
of these Visions were kind of like
really sexual and the fact that he like
wrote them down or like published them
was like very scandalous like at the
time but then he started having visions
of like Jesus
and so he had like this big Spiritual
Awakening uh Jesus Christ apparently
came to him and said you need to write
this thing that eventually became this
book called The Heavenly Doctrine uh to
ref and he wanted to like reform
Christianity essentially
um he was kind of like he still believed
in heaven and hell I think but he said
that Jesus this is not maybe I'm just
being glib but it's like he said that
Jesus gave him like he could like go and
talk to like like angels and demons and
stuff like he could go to heaven and
hell and like hang out with them and
like get [ __ ] info
um and he said that the last judgment
had already happened in 1757 actually uh
because
I mean he he had his Revelation like in
1741 I guess now he eventually got uh
excommunicated but
he didn't get like executed or anything
like that but yeah so he's kind of
considered one of the because he was
kind of seen as like heretical so he was
kind of like seen as like the Earl one
of the early like proponents of
spiritualism or like a precursor rather
there's another guy named Edward Irving
too who was a minister of the Church of
Scotland and he um was actually the
founder of a uh the Catholic Apostolic
Church
but the thing about when most people
talk about spiritualism
interestingly uh you know despite this
being a religious tradition that's not
real concerned with
you know being a religion in the sense
that you know we're having all these
bookkeeping and stuff
but they do have a date of when this
started and it started with the fox
sisters uh pretty much like I said it
didn't come out of nowhere because there
were some other like philosophical kind
of like free there was some kind of like
philosophical framework for it
but the fox sisters is generally
considered like the start of
spiritualism so we I think we did a show
about the fox sisters but we'll talk
about that a little bit yeah it's
ringing the bell yeah I mean well
they're very famous yeah
yeah so March 31st 1848.
there are two sisters
uh Margaretta Fox
14 years old and Catherine Fox 11 years
old
now they lived in this house uh and they
started like it was in um Hyattsville
New York
and they apparently allegedly start
hearing rapping sounds in their house
or so they say
and
what ended up happening was that I mean
the two of them were known as Maggie and
Keith like for short
so they start hearing these rapping and
like their family also hears it
so what ends up happening is that the
two girls
eventually
are like hey we can communicate with
whatever it is this being that's rapping
like knocking on the walls or whatever
the hell they said
they called this Spirit Mr split foot
which is another name for the devil I
mean or it was back then Hooves yeah
yeah because the post yeah
so even though the wrapping seemed kind
of like it was keeping everybody awake
and everybody was getting like kind of
pissed off about it but after they said
hey we can like communicate with it
so they started asking it questions so
what they would do is they would ask it
questions and they had like your usual
like tap you know once for Guess twice
for now kind of situation and then they
established like a longer code where
they had like this many times or
whatever like letter of the alphabet
now
during okay so during this like during
The Question they're like okay well
finally like who are you and apparently
this spirit and I say that like with you
know quotes or like air quotes or bunny
rabbit ears or whatever you want to call
it
um because we'll find out why later
but so they said oh will this Spirit
told us that it's the ghost of this dude
who was a peddler and his name was
Charles B Rosner
and he had been murdered
five years previously and he'd been
buried in the cellar of their house
Now spoiler alert uh the neighbors dug
up the cellar and found a couple pieces
of bone I think these were later
determined to be dog bones so they
weren't like human bones they never did
find a missing person named Charles B
Rosner uh you know anywhere in the area
so you know
but
that didn't seem to matter because I
think that was like a few years later
the wrapping and these two girls
allegedly being able to communicate with
whatever this rapping entity was a
rapping editing yeah
Deborah Harry
Potter yeah
yeah so uh so it already it became like
a sensation yeah because you have to
think in Upstate New York at this time
like I said it was kind of like Ground
Zero of this big like religious
Reawakening you had Quakers you had like
[ __ ] millerites you had like all kind
of like crazy
religious offshoot groups like going on
and they were just kind of like open to
anything they're like okay suppose so
so the fact that these two girls came
out and said hey we're talking to ghosts
now everyone's kind of like okay uh we
can buy that
so the fox family apparently
um they're like okay well this ghost in
the house and the girls are talking to
it and it's a little freaky so they took
off
and they went to another house and the
rapping apparently followed there now
after that like their story started to
spread like outward just from like
Upstate New York like into like The
Wider area so by the time that the fall
of 1849 comes around
in Rochester New York they had an
audience of 400 people
where these two girls were doing like
essentially like a stage show
demonstrating their what they called
wonderful phenomena
and they would do they would get up
there and they would ask questions of Mr
splitfoot and then he would like wrap
the answers to their questions
um and people would pay to come see them
and this was pretty much their main
source of income for the next like
several decades like 40 years of their
life yeah so they would go around
because they were they were very very
famous
you would have like really really famous
people like come to seances with them or
like come to see their lectures and
stuff like that you had like um
William Lloyd Garrison who was like a
big like abolitionist journalist
suffragist guy who was like very famous
at the time uh James Fenimore Cooper the
author uh probably most famous for Last
of the Mohicans like he would come to
you know he came some of their seances
you had um Horace Greeley who was
actually a newspaper editor he was one
of the the publisher or founder of um
the New York Tribune among other things
him and his wife Mary would come to like
the seances too and he would also write
about them in his newspapers huh so he
says why can't fortune tellers have
babies because their husbands have
crystal balls
[Laughter]
that's a pretty good joke I remember
yeah got a lot we got a lot of people in
the chat [ __ ] this is a great time to
[ __ ] show your appreciation to Jan
and go ahead and send a [ __ ]
Super Chat I'm gonna be out here I'm
gonna pimp it's pimping the show out
let's put the cash dollars because this
is our job
oh if I can grab this just shut up
what's up man
pretty sure there's a ghost in Grandpa's
house yeah BB's as in what you shot from
a BB gun frequently dropping the ceiling
in the basement of the man cave you know
it's weird it's like there's that's very
very common in Poltergeist cases like
[ __ ] dropping out of your ceiling like
rocks and stuff my dad had one fall out
of here my dad had one fall out of his
[ __ ] ceiling it was a uh uh it was a
Saint Christopher medallion
okay that's pretty freaky weird and he
didn't know where that came from little
bitty icon
yeah I've seen those yeah
Ben if one fell on the ceiling right now
I'd be like where the [ __ ] yeah you
didn't know where it came I haven't seen
one of them no Catholics in that house
as far as he knows
yeah I don't even know any Catholics to
be honest with you
but yeah so so the fact that Horace
Greeley who published New York Tribune
like published stuff about them all the
time that probably helped because he was
like a big fan of theirs so like stuff
about them would like turn up in yeah uh
newspapers and why not
now so like I said you kind of got
there was a lot of crossover I guess
like with the spiritualist movement and
the sort of Abolitionist Movement
women's rights movement so you had kind
of like you know all these Progressive
movements that were kind of like all
tied together with that uh you know like
I said a rejection of the more like
hierarchical sort of like uh religious
traditions and the thing about it too is
that you kind of had a lot of
people you've had to think in the mid
19th century
um 20 to 40 percent of children died
before they were five years old
now
prior to the 19th century obviously it
was worse than that like child mortality
was way worse than that and that didn't
really like you know uh feed into like a
big rise of spiritualism back then but
you had to think like from the mid to
late 19th century there was also kind of
more of a cultural shift toward
because prior to that like if you had a
kid I mean once they were weaned and
like walking and stuff they're like get
a job brat yeah I mean they didn't
really have a sense of like childhood or
teenagerhood but in the Victorian era
that started to come into play like an
actual concept of childhood so I guess
culturally people started thinking more
about their children
not it's just like oh here let's pop out
another one to like work on the farm oh
that one died let's have another one I
think they kind of started thinking of
them more as like more precious
in a way people started off as
scientologists yeah I mean obviously
like the kids were just adults like
obviously human like people are people
and like humans are human animals are
like this too like you haven't been like
ever like obviously it's always precious
but I kind of feel like prior to
you know better sanitation and Better
Health practices and stuff so many of
your kids died that I'm not saying like
you weren't that you didn't care about
it but you were just like more ignored
to it I guess but once like childhood
became like its own
you know thing I think people started
thinking more of like this kid is like
yeah well that you know what I mean it
was Dad he that started with Rises with
with Rising incomes and uh better
[ __ ] living conditions yeah only
people that are doing well worry about
childhood and only rich people actually
have a concept of [ __ ] teenagerhood
and that didn't come until the 40s 30s
maybe 30s
I think 40s 40s is when you had yeah
well I mean there was the concept of
childhood as a discreet thing now I'm
talking about teenager well yeah that
was a Victorian days maybe teenagerhood
I think that didn't come along until
after the world war after World War II
so 50. yeah natural world war and and
all pretty much only the west and
America
[ __ ] uh where we were doing pretty
well and the beginnings of modern
Modern Life in a suburb
where that was the [ __ ] that was the
the the the the [ __ ] what do you call
it that was like the the archetype
because that's what Hollywood was
punching out and television
Suburban archetype of how to live
we've talked about that in other other
[ __ ] shows a totally
artificial construct of governments
of the US government because you had so
many Savages coming back from World War
II you had to get those [ __ ] in
a Suburban environment with wives
pumping out children and they had to be
working in a factory because the
[ __ ] are too dangerous
to uh
Let it Loose in an urban environment
without a family okay yeah
Suburban life came from as a product
as a product came from the government in
World War II I mean single men are
always kind of your most dangerous yeah
you did not want these these dudes knew
how to destroy cities and civilizations
you had to give them a purpose if not
they'd turn on you
so
Here Comes Father Knows Best and [ __ ]
I Dream of Genie and bewitched and game
shows and get your ass in that [ __ ]
suburb and work for one of these car
companies
raise some children with the hot ass
wife and shut the [ __ ] up drink yourself
to death and get the [ __ ] out of here
because your ass is [ __ ] crazy all
the things and that's what they would
you don't really need a bunch of like
Savages yeah single dudes run around
making life miserable for everyone else
I mean this happens it's not just humans
it happens in other animal like things
too it's like single male animals not
all like but you know some of the
especially the battle experience are
dangerous you don't want them it's like
they just like yeah go somewhere else we
don't like that's you're just like in
the way of everyone which is safety that
whole 1950s
government effort to get [ __ ]
in into suburbs and and to make them
family men was genius
it's a testament to the intelligence of
of that generation that they foresaw
that problem
um and came up with that solution
they knew exactly what they were doing
it all had to do World War II World War
II was a great advancement for mankind
from the American point of view it
wasn't so much for Europe Europe was
decimated well yeah because they got
bombed yeah uh but for the American
point of view
the America you know would have never I
mean they bounced back but they bounced
back good I'm gonna say yeah we didn't
get we didn't get bombed over here right
yeah you know right yeah America does
not know War
not the way the Europeans especially the
Russians the way they know it no because
this never happened really here in
modern memory the closest thing we ever
had to that was the war between states
also known as the Civil War and that was
still confined mostly to certain areas
well because that was before the era of
like widespread that was just kind of
like mostly little skirmishes here and
there well they did burn down a Sherman
burned down to [ __ ] cities and they
did [ __ ] [ __ ] up a lot of women they
raped a lot of women killed a lot of
[ __ ] yeah I'm not trying to minimize
just like horrible [ __ ] here and then
like a lot of people died right and then
there was concentration camps after that
which is a lot of people [ __ ] don't
want to talk about that
um but um the uh the war between the
states was um but the war between the
states happened so long ago there's no
living memory of it okay that's the
difference
and it didn't happen and it didn't
happen at the time
where the Industrial Revolution was
really at its strongest so it didn't
make that much of a difference
World War II happened during the
Industrial Revolution which that made
the huge that made a huge difference
because everybody saw it there was no
mass media then
you know people up north had no idea
what the Civil War was about they didn't
see it
well I kind of feel like a lot of the
well and like we said like a lot of the
anti-war sediment that came out of like
the 60s and stuff like that was because
the Vietnam War was being shown on TV
yeah they saw it I mean you were your
relatives were even over there which a
lot of my relatives were or you saw it
in the night they showed that [ __ ] yeah
yeah no I don't like that here's here's
the [ __ ] strange thing people
that was in the first Gulf War I wasn't
in we're technically I wasn't in the
second one night and I was only in the
support
in the support of [ __ ]
um on the peripheries of uh of the
Afghanistan war really what happened in
the Gulf wars in Afghanistan if you
combine the two it was worse than
Vietnam but the average person today
doesn't have that sense because you were
shielded from it in a lot of ways people
television was not as dominant
people yeah it's kind of more spread out
like just like everything else there
were more television stations and people
could kind of Escape it
uh Vietnam was concentrated because
there was only four channels
you know yeah you kind of saw it we
couldn't escape they were not right but
no the the uh the second invasion of
Iraq and Afghanistan was far more brutal
than Vietnam a lot of [ __ ] Iraqis
died
innocent Iraqis died in that war and
then you guys will never know about
man yeah and and for a bad reason really
not a good reason
yeah we lost both worlds that whole [ __ ]
was right that was a [ __ ] [ __ ] show
yeah the whole thing
you weren't going to bring democracy to
them they didn't want that they wanted
Islam
yeah well the reason they even attacked
them in the first place was [ __ ]
yeah it was all [ __ ] so it was just
about making money yeah and forming a
One World Government which will never
happen
countries do not like foreigners coming
into their land telling them how to live
it doesn't matter what country you're in
you would not like a foreigner coming
into your land and telling you how to
live and to tell you that your beliefs
are wrong it's just not going to happen
but let's go oh let me go get some more
ice I don't want to sidetracked too much
you don't yeah now they're already two
hours in uh but he doesn't want to get
sidetracked I don't believe that for one
second but yeah so like I said I'm not
saying that people prior to the
Victorian era didn't love their children
obviously they did but you just had to
get used to the you know having a bunch
of them and having a bunch of them dying
so even though it was sad you were like
more a nerd to it I guess but once the
Victorian era came along even though a
lot of people's kids were still like a
lot of them were still dying
um but you had more of a sense of
childhood you had more of a sense of
like each child being precious being
their own person so it was like more of
a tragedy I guess like when they died
now let's talk about
um and when we talked about like famous
people that were like into spiritualism
let's talk about a very famous example
who was maybe brought into it initially
because of a child dying and that was
Mary Todd Lincoln I kind of feel like a
lot of people know about this now she
wasn't even I mean obviously she saw her
husband get assassinated like right in
front of her face which is like pretty
uh traumatic but she had had like some
really shitty stuff happen in uh her
youth like throughout her life as well
um her mom uh died when she was very
very young three out of her four
children died like I said and you know
this is quite common uh in this time
period and as I said her husband was
assassinated in front of her face so
it's as most people know
now after her second youngest son Willie
died in 1862 she actually turned to
spiritualism now Willie was only 11
years old he died of typhoid fever
so probably understandably I mean your
kid dies I can't imagine uh what that
would be like
so she turned to spiritualism and
started going to seances
so she gets introduced to this group of
mediums called the lorries and they were
in Georgetown like uh you know part of
DC
and she got so much out of this that she
very famously started hosting her own
seances in the White House in the red
Brim
uh they think that she might have hosted
as many as eight seances in the white
house uh Abe Lincoln prior to him being
assassinated obviously uh attended some
of them as well I'm not really sure what
his beliefs were on that score however
um that's what I mean so I kind of feel
like a lot of people are really like
comforted by the fact especially because
like I said of the Civil War and all of
a sudden there was so much death
um that people were like they wanted to
feel like oh I can still like contact my
loved ones again
um and that was just like really
comforting for people and it just came
along like right at the right at the
right time
now because she I mean she was pretty
open about her spiritualism hey it's
Pookie yeah
you want to talk about you want to talk
about spirits bulky
he's already talking about spirits you
want to talk about spirits can you see
spirits I saw her attacking something in
the corner of my room in the man cave
when I was [ __ ] laying there to
listen to shows and I hit a flashlight
in the corner to see what it was she was
trying to catch there was nothing there
somebody
earlier on was saying that they see
ghosts they don't see ghosts what it is
is its imagination
she was imagining she was catching
something they play like just like a
little kid there was nothing there
although I always kind of tease her like
because sometimes she'll like space out
and be like looking up at the ceiling
I'm like is there go step there Pookie
and then you start swatting things and
you're looking to hit a flashlight and
go what is she trying to catch there's
nothing there they're playing there's
the magic they're playing there I don't
think they see ghosts
she's probably like ooh there's a big
bug right there yeah she's imagining
there's a bug in the corner and she's
getting it
I do teaser about it though like is that
uh but yeah so even though she was
pretty open about it Mary Todd Lincoln
I'm talking about um even though she was
pretty open about it initially like I
guess she got like a little bit of like
you know blowback on it
so she started like chilling out but in
1870
she uh now it's kind of well known but
back then she kind of kept it on the DL
she goes to a spirit photographer
named William mumler
now William mumler at this point because
Spirit photography was like [ __ ] huge
around this time period
at this point mummler had already been
accused of fraud for doing what the [ __ ]
he was doing but she went to him anyway
because she wanted you know a picture
and like [ __ ] so the picture that he
produced of her with Abe Lincoln like
standing in the background like with his
hands on her shoulders very very famous
like most people have probably seen it
now the thing about mummler though he
had actually he was from Boston he had
been a jewelry engraver at first
and his story was how he got into Spirit
photography
was that he had taken a self-portrait
he's like oh I took a self-portrait and
there was what they called an extra like
somebody showing up in the picture that
wasn't in the picture that you thought
that you took
and he's like there was this little girl
that turned up in this chair that was
like in the photo and he's like and I
thought that it looked like my cousin
who had been dead for like a dozen years
now like I said this is probably like
[ __ ]
because what he would do as they
determined later on in the early days of
photography
you had to expose like the pane of glass
right like to the to the chemicals you
like put the light on or whatever so it
was very very easy like for a
photographer to expose
the pane of glass first
and then like when the people came in to
have their Porsche taken to use that
same pane of glass
and take a portrait of them and then
there'd be like a double exposure you
know what I mean yeah but the thing
about it is that photography was such a
new medium
that nobody really considered
the way that photography I don't know if
it was necessarily sold like this to the
public but the way that the public
perceived photography was like
um it's capturing reality like it's
capturing like a little bit of reality
nobody really understood that it could
be manipulated
by photographers even though it
absolutely could be and it absolutely
was like even from the very early days
and back then
I mean people talk it's very easy
nowadays obviously because we have like
Photoshop and everything else but like
back then it was like pretty easy too
like I said all you had to do was like
expose like if you wanted like a ghost
if somebody's like relative or some [ __ ]
like that you just had to have somebody
come in there sit in a chair expose the
plate
put the plate aside when the person came
in you would just like take a picture of
them with that plate and then there'd be
a double exposure so it would look like
the person's like you know image and
then like in the background they would
be like another image and they'd be like
oh my God that's great at Carol or
whoever the [ __ ] so yeah so it was like
very very common I mean the thing about
it is that particularly after the Civil
War like the market in spirit
photography like exploded
I don't know how many of those people
it's just kind of like I'm not really
sure like how many people nowadays
actually believe
in mediums or believe in psychics if you
I mean
when you go to a medium or a psychic if
you pay that person do you actually
believe that that person is like talking
to your dead loved one or on some level
do you know that they're just
you know blowing smoke up your ass and
essentially essentially like just to
make you feel better I'm not really sure
but people are willing to pay for it and
there was absolutely like people that
were willing to do it like for money so
Spirit photography was very very famous
uh very very popular at the time
and it was just also kind of like
feeding into the whole thing of
Victorian
uh you know death photography because
you know photography was very new
technology it was very expensive so
sometimes like if you had a kid and the
kid died when they were a baby or a
toddler or whatever you had never like
been able to afford like taking a
picture of that kid like before they
died so you would take a picture of them
after they were dead it's like it's
morbid but you wanted a picture to
remember them by and that was all you
could get because you know now they were
dead and you took a picture so Victorian
boarding photography very very famous so
it's kind of like an outshoot of that an
offshoot of that I guess
so you know so like I said particularly
after the Civil War I mean it was it was
what like 750 000 people dead maybe even
more than that
um and people a lot of times like the
you know they didn't know where the
people went or they didn't get their
bodies or something like that so it was
just kind of like very very common that
people would have that
um you saw the same thing happen in
Europe like particularly after World War
one uh which was you know the worst
thing that every that anybody had ever
seen at that point in time and it's just
kind of like a lot of people were just
like blown away and they were you know
they're lost in the ocean or whatever
and they never found them so you could
see how it was like really comforting
for people to like oh I have a a
photograph of myself with like the
spirit of my dead son or you know it was
that kind of thing so I you know I can
totally see like why that would be like
comforting for people how many of those
have you eaten I don't know
I'm not really into Taffy she sent us
Taffy what else did she send us Taffy
fudge and peanut brittle yeah I'm into
the fudge and the peanut brittle I'm not
so into Taffy though like I said if I'm
gonna have like some calories of candy I
would rather have something I really
really like like fudge or peanut brittle
which are my favorite
now they're little see yeah but yeah
[Laughter]
this is at Mackinac Island Taffy yeah
handmade
Tammy says the YouTube channel ask a
mortician oh I love that channel she's
great uh has a great video showing how
the photographers did it they actually
recreate one I honestly like all those
photos are fake obviously but I really
like them they're still like creepy even
though you know that they're fake I was
at I was in New York like several years
ago and at the Met they did um like a
like a special like installation of
Victorian Spirit photographs and they
were so cool it's like so cool to like
see them like in person
and you know that they're fake and some
of them are like really obviously fake
but they're still like cool to look at
it's cool because like I said I kind of
feel like people didn't understand
because photography was so new I don't
think they unders they understood like
how photographers could manipulate the
images
back in the old days or they pretended
not to understand that's what I mean
yeah that's what I was saying while you
were gone I was like I'm not really sure
and and I don't really know like
nowadays people that pay psychics or
whatever I'm not sure how much of it is
just you want like reassurance oh yeah
like if you don't actually believe that
that psychic is like tell it was like
relaying messages from your dead
relative I think a lot of them were fake
because you'd have to submit a photo of
the loved one
first to get that image on a plate
okay so I think it's just me yeah it's
just made people feel better knew that
they submitted that particular photo
yeah they're like oh hey that's that
yeah the same photo yeah I mean it'd be
different if it was a famous person
because there were probably like other
photos of that that like the
photographer could be like oh I'll just
take this one this will look like but
yeah they had to like Source the photo
from somewhere right and because
photography was like more expensive back
then it's like it'd probably be
I don't know like nowadays it's much
easier because photography is like cheap
you don't even need like paper or
anything not back in those days but back
in those days yeah it was like really
expensive because that's what I was
saying the the reason that I mean
because photography was so expensive
sometimes the only like the victorians
everybody thinks it's like creepy and
morbid that like they took pictures like
dead babies and whatnot but I was just
kind of like well
they couldn't afford to like take
pictures of the babies of the kids while
they were alive so it's like that was
the only photograph they had of them so
the feeling that it's [ __ ] up but I
have a feeling about the the the
supernatural photographs I have a
feeling word novelty back then
yeah I kind of feel like it was just
kind of like trendy I don't think like a
lot of people actually believe that that
was the ghost I just thought that was
like they thought it was kind of neat
yeah or it was kind of like comforting
to them it's like oh look it's like you
know my husband or wife or whatever you
video or like watching over me yeah we
would call it a tribute video nowadays
like when Kaylee died
little swole made a tribute video to her
and put it up on YouTube that's what I
think a lot of the uh the spirit
photography was it was a tribute photo
yeah
they knew it wasn't real
they didn't care though I think yeah I
think probably most people did and like
I said they probably just like kept it
in their house and they just like like
to look at it because they're like oh
look look they're watching they're
watching over me yeah it just made
people feel better right which like I
said that's fine and if you know that
and you're paying for it then that's up
to you I'm pretty sure that's what it
was I don't I mean I'm not a big fan of
I'm not a big fan of like psychics and
stuff like that because I think a lot of
them like all of them are charlatans and
they're like taking advantage of
gullible people or they're taking
advantage of like vulnerable people but
if you know what you're getting in for
and you're just paying for entertainment
or you're just paying for Comfort or
something like that you don't actually
believe it then I don't know I guess
it's okay but you know what I mean I
don't I just I don't like the I don't
like the whole thing about like fraud
where I'm saying yeah I'm actually like
talking to your dad no you're not I
think most of it wasn't fraud I think
most of it was like I said tribute
you know what I mean yeah I think most
of that paranormal [ __ ] that they were
paying was more of a tribute type thing
I mean I kind of hope that's what it was
I kind of feel like that was kind of
because it was very very trendy it was
very trendy people weren't stupid back
then and they understood how to how the
Technologies worked if you submitted a
photo and later on a psychic gave you a
photo of you with the re with a [ __ ]
with the same food the same damn photo
they look all ghostly guys they knew
grandpar said A buddy of grams died a
few years ago and his widow went to a
psychic the psychic told her Bob was
fine nothing to worry about what Bob was
not fine he was dead
see that's what kind of kills me is that
that's all the psychic ever tells you
yeah they're fine they're happy they say
oh they love you and stuff like that I'm
like yeah well tell me some tell me some
juicy [ __ ] they're not dead they're
alive in the spirit world tell me some
juicy [ __ ] that only they would know
don't just tell me oh they're happy and
singing Kumbaya out with the other
[ __ ] spirits in the afterlife I'm not
gonna buy that sorry yeah in reality
they have they have in the Star Wars
terminology they have become one with
the force
or what a what a mythologist would say
is that they've they've rejoined they've
re-entered the pleuroma
they're gone
yeah which like I said it's but that's
kind of the issue that I have especially
like nowadays and nowadays like I'm not
[ __ ] on people back in the old days
because like I understand like they had
like a different kind there was a
different cultural context they had a
different like scientific understanding
nowadays there's no [ __ ] excuse
everybody knows how they do that [ __ ]
um it's fake and it's just kind of like
if you want to pay because it makes you
feel better that's fine I'm not the
[ __ ] on that you can spend your
money on whatever you want but
I don't know like just don't that's it's
not a real it's not your relative
they're not that's all they ever say
that's all they ever say yes they love
you if you haven't checked out going
Guillermo del Toro's nightmare alley
talks about this thing oh nightmare
alley was so good yeah I love nightmare
alley actually I kind of want to watch
it again I think it's on Hulu we saw the
theater matter of fact
I liked it a lot
but yeah I kind of want to read the book
which one was that we saw in the theater
yeah that was the one that like the guy
at the carnival and they were okay can I
remember oh yeah yeah yeah yeah that's a
great movie yeah it was really good it
was really good I liked it a lot
yeah so uh as I was mentioning earlier
because uh of the whole thing about
photography which like I said
photography was uh still a relatively
new medium around this time
and to maybe some people that didn't
really know how it was how it was done
it seemed like magical I mean it does
kind of seem like magical hey I'm gonna
like flash this [ __ ] thing at you and
then I'm gonna like expose this plate
and then hey I have this piece of paper
with like hey I captured your [ __ ]
likeness yeah so I can see how if you
didn't really know anything that'd be
like what the [ __ ] how'd that happen
right yeah like there was nothing yeah
you take it for granted we do but like
back then that must have like blown
their [ __ ] minds yeah right so I can
see why people back then were just kind
of like oh okay well we can take
pictures of ghosts and [ __ ] like that so
it's not crazy well if you can take a
picture of a living person why not a
dead one that's what I'm saying it's not
crazy so I'm like not [ __ ] on people
back then because it's like the whole
Zeitgeist at the time all of this
scientific progress was happening and
particularly there was a lot of progress
in stuff that you know was like
invisible radio waves you know
photography [ __ ] like that that to us we
take for granted but to them it was just
kind of like oh my God there's nothing
yeah in between in this there's like you
know what I mean there's telegram I'm
very confused about what's right what is
it right so it and the fact that they
discovered like I said you did you know
Telegraph we can send a message it's
wireless like from here to like another
country and there's like nothing in
between
it just goes through the air
I mean that must have seemed like really
crazy and it must have opened up a lot
of scientific possibilities so I can
totally see not only why regular people
got into the whole spiritualist idea but
why scientists did as well
because it seemed like the possibility
was there they were finding all kinds of
invisible forces quote unquote
if you read old spiritualist [ __ ] from
the [ __ ] even the 1970s they were
still kind of confused about the way
science worked the way in in the way
that [ __ ] time space continued when
mass energy worked you know they didn't
really know the average person didn't
really know
although you could say well the [ __ ]
average scientist nowadays and doesn't
really know either but
but that's kind of the whole point
though is that I mean science they were
yeah is constantly Builds on what came
before right science presumes right we
don't know everything it's easy to
understand the misconceptions that they
had in this period sure because you know
it I can understand it yeah but that's
what I'm saying I'm just kind of trying
to extrapolate myself back to that time
period which was you know a flowering of
sort of like scientific uh progress and
you know and it was very widely known at
least among educated people like all of
this stuff that was coming out it's like
and they were fine like all of these
findings that were true like of things
you couldn't see but that still like had
an impact in the real world and so
normal people would see that and they'd
be like holy [ __ ] well maybe that means
we can talk to dead people that's not
crazy I don't think that's crazy at all
like to think that but like nowadays I
think there's like no no excuse because
we know a lot more than back then but
back then I don't think there was
because it's a lot more gray back then
sure that's what I'm saying yeah I mean
you have to think that like by the time
that the fox sisters came along with
their you know with their rapping and
whatnot
the telegraph had only been introduced
four years earlier that was very new
technology
and the telegraph was kind of like a big
deal and honestly like a lot of the
early spiritualists
um compared themselves to telegraphs why
do you think they're called mediums
because it's like a communication medium
like a telegraph or something like that
or like a photography they kind of like
made an uh analogy
of a human being like a receptor or a
conductor or the same way that a
telegraph was
so they just like I said it's not a
crazy belief to have it seemed
completely rational to them and like I
said if I you know if I try to put
myself back in that mindset it does seem
completely completely rational I would
not have seen that as crazy or out there
or anything like that that was just like
they were working within the framework
of what they knew at that time
now yeah so like I said there's a really
interesting like symbiotic relationship
between
spiritualism and Technology it seems
like a lot of breakthroughs maybe not
necessarily but maybe just kind of like
around the outside or like on the
fringes or something
and you know particularly in
Communications technology we're either
engendered you know or had to do with
like scientists that were into
spiritualism or were like looking or
we're open to the possibility of like oh
we can communicate with the dead you
know what I mean
um you know because there was so much
stuff going on at this time I mean and I
wanted to get into a little bit like a
particular example uh William Crooks who
was a British chemist and physicist uh
back at this time he was the guy that
discovered phthalium he was a guy that
discovered the cathode ray tube among
many many other things
uh he was also a spiritualist and he
went to a bunch of seances after his uh
younger brother died in 1867 so like I
said a lot of because a lot of people
had you know uh experience with a lot of
death you know that obviously that was
really like attractive to go and like
see if you communicate with them
so he went to a lot of seances and even
though he was a scientist
um you know he still wanted to believe
it so he did actually believe that a lot
of the stuff that he saw was real but he
still had enough of his like scientific
training to
want to investigate the Paranormal in a
scientific way like he wanted to remain
skeptical he wanted to like follow the
scientific protocol he wanted to do
experiments like in controlled
conditions trying to see because he
really really wanted it to be true right
so he decided he was gonna like do this
now he did actually end up going uh to
examine like a bunch of mediums and he
did actually end up
um you know exposing a lot of people
that were fraudulent
uh which happened a lot which we'll get
into in a little bit
but uh he also
sadly he also gave credibility to a few
who were also probably brought well
almost certainly fraudulent but were
good enough tricksters that they fooled
a scientist uh back then so you know one
of the ones that he was convinced was
real
was a dude named Daniel douglas douglas
Hume
now
so William Crooks had he was very very
empirical about the [ __ ] like he had
designed like all of these experiments
and he like all of these tests to make
sure they were real
so he had human there
and he's like I'm gonna test your
abilities to manipulate objects at a
distance which one of the things he
supposedly did and another thing that he
did was modifying the weight of an
object which I guess was kind of a big
deal
now to do the first thing he had this
experiment where he had like an
accordion and it was uh in this drawer
that was like under the table and the
medium was only allowed to like put his
hands on the side of it like he couldn't
like [ __ ] but he was supposed to like
make the accordion go up and down so
that was like his first test and then he
was supposed to
alter the weight of this wooden board
that was on a scale
he was supposed to just put his fingers
on the side and it was supposed to like
be super heavy now to crooks's
astonishment
uh Hume passed both of the tests
now later on we'll be saying these
weren't like the greatest [ __ ] tests
of like psychic ability but okay but
Crooks was convinced anyway
so he thought well this guy has some
kind of like force or whatever that was
not you know within the bounds of
natural law now after he came out and
said this like the rest of the
scientific scientific community
community were just kind of like really
bro and they were kind of like I don't
know I don't know if I'd say like
crooks's name was mud after a while but
the scientific Community were like not
really having it now interestingly Hume
was uh incidentally one of the most
famous mediums in the era one of the
things that he was best known for like
he did all the regular like Seance [ __ ]
like the medium [ __ ] but
a couple of the things he was best known
for
was one that he would perform his [ __ ]
in like a lighted room which was kind of
like unprecedented because most
obviously most saying such sanses were
conducted into the dark because much
easier to like pull some [ __ ] off when
no one's can see you but he would do
[ __ ] well at a room
and I think like his other most famous
thing was his levitations
now reportedly these were pretty
impressive I've seen like some [ __ ]
uh drawings and stuff from the time
where it shows them like floating up by
the ceiling and [ __ ] like that which is
a little
uh uh that's a little over the top I
mean compared to like what people said
now apparently at one Seance According
to some witness testimony
he floated out the window
of uh like a third story room like the
third story when he floats out the
window at that room and then comes back
in through the window of another room
now supposedly three Witnesses at the
Seance do that but if you look at the
statements of the three Witnesses really
only one [ __ ] said that the
other two like said some other [ __ ] that
weren't really impressive that's what
I'm saying so if you read like a lot of
the because and the you have to think
too that like a lot of people are coming
to Seance is yeah you got like the
Skeptics that were in there trying to
debunk the [ __ ] but most of the people
that were there
were Believers and they were really into
so sometimes I think they would
confabulate or they would kind of like
make [ __ ] seem more impressive than it
actually was
because from what I could determine of
all the stuff that I read about people
that were at his seances that
um that wrote about their experiences
maybe he levitated six inches foot
couple feet it wasn't like floating up
near the ceiling like in broad daylight
it was nothing like that and even if he
did that I mean that would be impressive
back then I mean yeah magician could do
it now and it would be like yeah I don't
know how he did it but it's obviously
magic you know it's it's an illusion you
got what's his name [ __ ] Chris what's
his name Chris Blaine David Blaine David
Blaine Chris Angel Chris Angel David
Blaine yeah
blame was better than Angel Chris Angel
was obviously that she was obvious
[ __ ] special effects from straight
from the [ __ ] movies but
[ __ ] Chris Angel
I mean yeah so the thing about it too is
that you have to think like a lot of the
impressive [ __ ] that probably happened
in these seances
is that you know probably 90 of the
people that were there wanted it to be
true and believed in it so and they
would lie 90 95 of the [ __ ] happened in
the dark too so that's gonna be like
yeah we saw some [ __ ] we didn't see and
then like they're probably writing it
down later on too and like people's
memories are like not real reliable
gonna say that so you might remember
[ __ ] is like way more impressive than it
actually was so I kind of feel like I
think it's interesting
that one [ __ ] said yeah he
floated he levitated and floated out the
window and then came in the other window
like in the next room but the other two
[ __ ] that were there that
supposedly with who they said yeah we
didn't see that but it was like I think
it was kind of like a thing you know
that levitation illusion they do where
it's like you kind of go up on one toe
and it kind of looks I think he did that
[ __ ] yeah and everybody was like left
the window came out come in no
no I'm not buying that no not at all and
there's no no cooperating Witnesses now
yeah it was like one [ __ ] said
that yeah that dude was like tripping
yeah that it was driven but uh and he he
wanted to believe I think he had a
situation where people wanted wanted
this [ __ ] to be real and they wanted
other people to think it would be real
oh yeah I saw it no for real went out
yeah
I can see it I can see it well like I
said if you're going off somebody's like
people's perceptions
are not that reliable
to be honest with you yeah I mean yeah
people's senses are more or less okay
for perceiving reality but you don't
know
what that person's preconceived notions
are you don't know what [ __ ]
substances that person is on you don't
know like what that person wants to
believe maybe like later they remember
stuff is like more impressive than it
actually was I mean I've had [ __ ] happen
and I'm like a really rational like
skeptical person I've had dreams
where that seemed really realistic where
I remembered like telling people some
[ __ ] and when I woke up like a day or
two later I couldn't remember if that
really happened or if I had dreamed it
so and that's me saying that so if you
really wanted to believe that this dude
was had magical powers
and could float
and you were at this Seance with other
people like like-minded people that also
wanted to believe that and then you saw
him maybe like go up on his sins be like
I'm floating he'd have been like oh my
God that [ __ ] just went out the [ __ ]
window like he might have just like
every time he told it it might have got
like more like a game of telephone it
just might have got more backwards some
of that Poltergeist stuff was happening
at the old house Jenny [ __ ] woke me
up in the middle of night swearing that
the doorbell rang
that she then it rang twice I didn't
hear it
I don't know if it's true she did it
ring well here's the thing what happened
was yeah I heard the doorbell rang which
was a very distinctive sound yeah and it
woke me up right
and so I laid there and I was wide awake
and I laid there and I said okay now
because like I said I'm a very rational
person yeah did that doorbell really
ring or did I just dream that it rang so
I laid there awake
and then it rang again
and I was like okay I must have heard it
yeah and then I woke you up I didn't
wake you up the first time but did you
dream all of that no
because I was awake after that I was
absolutely awake after that I grabbed if
I [ __ ] I grabbed a [ __ ] gun and
[ __ ] search that whole [ __ ] house
I wouldn't have woke you up if it didn't
ring again I wouldn't have woke you up
because I wasn't sure yeah I thought
that I'd heard the doorbell and it had
woke me up because it was like it was
three something in the morning I just I
didn't hear it but I just had to trust
her I [ __ ] had Walther in hand but I
laid there for like a while yeah and I
was like okay I might have dreamed that
I said I'm gonna lay here awake and see
and then it happened again and I was
wide awake there was nobody at the door
no there's nobody there there was nobody
else that was during that time the poach
guy stuff was happening though but I
didn't I didn't hear it yeah and I you
know I've seen weirder [ __ ] than that so
I'm just gonna trust you
yeah it did ring okay like I said had it
not rung a second time I would have just
said oh maybe I just dreamed it right
because I've had [ __ ] like that happen
before that was about three in the
morning yeah it was three three Thirty
in the morning something like that
so I mean at that point I didn't think
it was a ghost or nothing like that I
thought somebody like some serial killer
is out there like ringing the [ __ ]
doorbell that's what that's what I
thought but there was nobody out there
no I went up there I didn't think there
was a way I could see the door through a
window
there was nobody standing there
and then I [ __ ] checked it from a
couple of other windows and then went
out front there was nobody there and I
came back and I said there's nobody
there and she was [ __ ] mad
she's freaked out it was weird
I was funny yeah I I was like I said I
was kind of spooked I did not think it
was paranormal I thought it was a serial
killer yeah and then I think about it I
thought it was some [ __ ] coming
or ringing the doorbell trying to get us
to open the doors and I think what was
it a couple days later the garage door
opened in the middle of night didn't it
yeah I don't remember it was a couple
days later but it was around that same
time period yeah it was weird
yeah garage door open yeah
yeah uh yeah
so yeah I don't I don't think this dude
floated out the window but that was kind
of like what he was known for as his
levitations like he did other [ __ ] too
like the table tilting and all that kind
of stuff but I kind of feel like that
was kind of and like I said he did have
a good schtick because most of the
seances were ooh we have to turn all the
lights off because the spirits don't
like the light or whatever but he would
do [ __ ] in
in the light like he would just have
regular lights on and he would still do
some [ __ ] so Props there but I kind of
feel like what happened was that
after Seance has got like really popular
uh you'd have to like up the game
because it was like some competition it
was just like magic shows right it's
like competing magic shows so it's just
kind of like if you wanted everybody to
come to your [ __ ] you had to like
[ __ ] you had to lean it you had to
like [ __ ] bring something different
you had to like
you know do something better if all of
them were doing [ __ ] in the dark and it
was just kind of like hey I'm gonna
rattle the tambourine or some [ __ ] like
that you had like oh I'm gonna do it
like in the [ __ ] daytime and a little
float out the window I'm gonna do this
and that you had to like bring it you
had to like make it bigger and that
everybody had come to your [ __ ] so I
kind of feel like that was why he got
more popular you know what I mean I'm
not saying his Illusions were naturally
better I mean I guess they had to be
because they were in the light rather
than in the dark because in the dark you
can get away with a lot more stuff but
I'm just saying that's kind of I think
that's kind of how it evolved that's
kind of how it evolved from
you know hey we're just like talking to
weird voices to oh now we have to have
like ectoplasm and we have towels it was
just like a an escalation because you
were trying to get everybody to come to
yours because you had like some
different [ __ ] you know what I mean
so so yeah so William Crooks he
apparently thought this guy was
legitimate
um he couldn't like debunk it so he was
convinced
uh he was also real into this other this
is a little problematic
he was also real into this other uh uh
medium who happened to be a 15 year old
girl named Florence cook now she
supposedly
could materialize the spirit named Katie
King now I want to get into like Katie
King a little bit
later on because Katie King was like
supposedly this spirit I don't know if
I'd necessarily call her like a you know
Spirit control but she would like a
spirit that would show up in numerous
mediums seances like during this time
period so she was kind of like a famous
Spirit but yeah
so he went to her thing and he was just
kind of like uh convinced she was real
also
now William Crooks went to her seances
and said that he saw this spirit and he
took a bunch of pictures but he didn't
get any pictures now at this point
um like I said scientific Community was
kind of just like bro what are you even
[ __ ] doing and there were also some
rumors I don't know if they're true or
not or if everybody was just like being
an [ __ ] but that William Crooks might
have maybe
um engaged in an intimate relationship
with a 15 this 15 year old girl and he
was like kind of an old man so no not
great I don't know if that's true or not
but you know
so uh at that point because his
reputation was taking such a beating
he started uh from 1875 on he's just
kind of like yeah I'm I'm gonna knock
off this whole I mean he didn't knock it
off but he just like
we didn't make it public he's just like
I'm not investigating the Paranormal
anymore so he went back to his more
Orthodox like science kind of methods
and the same year 1875 he invented the
radiometer which is like a light Mill uh
you know that it you can still buy one
nowadays it's like a glass bulb and
there's like a little veins in there and
like if you put like electromagnetic
radiation to it they like spin around
yeah he invented that and then like
later 1878 he actually invented the cafe
ray tube so hold on one second what
Straw Dogs are saying I have recurring
dreams of exploring old houses with
secret passageways or endless cavernous
hallways those dreams went on forever
and then Ariel belly dancer all right
and then my little buddy there this is
the same but my tend to feature
labyrinths tucked away into attics weird
Grooms there were also somehow Outdoors
mind [ __ ] since I was a kid was weird
underground [ __ ] like
I'm in the
I'm in my bedroom and go to my [ __ ]
closet and I walk into my [ __ ] little
closet notice that there's buttons on
the inside of the [ __ ] wall and go
man these look like elevated buttons to
elevator and I press a [ __ ] number
and the [ __ ] door closes and my my
[ __ ]
closet my closet
elevator I'm seeing other floors of
different versions of my house in it and
I'm going down deeper and deeper and
some of them look like caves and then I
get out and I'm in these weird 1970s
Apartments deep underneath the ground
that's walking around and then I [ __ ]
go back to the elevator and try to go up
but I keep falling down
until I'm in a [ __ ] underground caves
where I hear may like I'm in a maze with
[ __ ]
distant screamings of [ __ ] dinosaurs
[ __ ] echoing off the roof and [ __ ]
giant man-sized bats it's like some [ __ ]
out of those old [ __ ] movies like
dirt Journey to the Center of the Earth
those British movies that we used to
watch coming up as a kid you know it was
like that yeah so I know what you're
talking about my dreams are similar also
like that ancient mysterious rooms in
your own house that you remember how'd
this get here you know [ __ ] like that
yeah weird
yeah I kind of it's weird because I kind
of feel like I dream about when I dream
about houses yeah it's almost always my
grandfather's old house which I lived in
for a short time it's been torn down now
or my grandmother's house which I also
lived in for quite a long time it's not
it's still there but like other people
live in it
it's really weird I don't dream about
like any I don't dream about this house
I don't dream about an old house I dream
about my grandfather's house or my
grandmother's house
and some but sometimes it'll open out
into other areas yeah you know what I
mean like it'll open up into like some
[ __ ] video game looking Silent Hill
looking [ __ ] yeah it'll look like that
you know what I mean yeah it's like
weird [ __ ]
look I think the landscape inside those
dream houses has something to do with
the reflection of the your interior
landscape it has something to do with
the way you're you imagine
the interior of your own mind in some
weird way they were I think it's a
reflection of you
of going deeper into the subconscious
something like that kind of what it
feels like
it always felt like
different versions of the house that I
was living in or had lived in
which might might mean that it has
something to do with different versions
of your own personality that you're
somehow
do y'all like in your dreams do you
actually like feel like you're you or no
yeah have my own point of view but I
don't
I don't really remember my past in the
same way that I normally would you know
but it's definitely me looking
I feel like a lot of times it's not me I
don't know who it is but it's not me
all right well I don't know it's like
it's a very very strange yeah camping I
said I like dreams don't have many
I have look I go through periods where I
have a lot and then like periods where I
don't really have any or don't remember
any you know what I mean a lot of my
dreams are kind of like boring but then
like sometimes I have like really like
Vivid ones
I don't know but I do kind of feel like
a lot of times
I'm not necessarily not me but I kind of
like feel like I'm looking through
different people's perspectives you know
what I'm saying yeah I don't know it's
hard
to know it's hard to explain
so yeah so what did I say okay so
William Crooks despite his uh love of
spiritualism he actually did invent like
a a bunch of [ __ ] that still impacts us
nowadays he wanted the crooks tube which
is like I said the cathode ray tube uh
which actually led to they discovered
the electron and the discovery of x-rays
like later on
so the fact that he uh invented the
cathode ray tube the scientific
Community are like okay well you can
come back and sit at our lunch table
again so you know what I mean but he did
actually remain a spiritualism uh you
know into spiritualism until he died so
and he even like went to say houses like
after his wife died in 1916 but yeah he
was he was still into it so um I'm sure
probably most of you know but Nikola
Tesla and Thomas Edison we're it we're
real into
uh looking for like radios to talk to
dead people
you know yeah uh so there was another of
course of course get a radio and talk to
dead people of course well like I said
it didn't seem crazy back then no
because you're getting like disembodied
voices so which seems like from The
Ether right they're like why not dead
people put the channel moving on over to
the [ __ ] afterlife and you'll you'll
hear him talking that's it makes sense
when you think about it that's what I'm
saying it's not crazy I don't like I
don't [ __ ] on any people back then
because like it totally sounded
plausible right like it's not plausible
now but back then it would have been
well you know you know what well you
know what the radio spectator is now
like I said they didn't and they didn't
really know what the possibilities or
the limitations of it were so I'm just
kind of like even scientists back then
um you know they were working within the
limitations of their time period so I so
I don't think that's crazy at all that's
a it's completely like rational to think
that back in that time period the strong
dog says yeah that's what I was thinking
it's like exploring the subconscious
trying to out other com uncover
something very somewhere in there in
there that's what he's saying to me and
Ariel yeah that's what I think it is
that's what it felt like when I was
having those dreams that you're going
into your subconscious parts of you that
are not in the normal waking
sits the other versions of you
it's what it seemed like it was symbolic
of of
yeah okay good I mean [ __ ] I've written
like some short stories like based on
like some weird-ass streams you're not
one Consciousness you're uh and this is
that same dude that I recommended that
on Lex Friedman said you don't have one
conscious you have one conscious and
then you have a bunch of
unconsciousnesses and it's like a group
of them and they're talking to each
other
and they're all different versions of
you they're like we've done this like a
[ __ ] committee it's like a committee
in there so when you're going those
dreams symbolize the rest the other
versions of you in that committee and
not all of mine are good some of them
are like Venom you know they're just
talking about killing you
and it it hates me and it's trying to
destroy me and I would be nothing
without it it says the same things to me
is that it says that dude in venom but
it actually hates me that's one of them
that's weird man I think a lot of people
have it
I mean I don't have that I have one that
tells me I suck all the time it's that
one but that one it's not like violent
or not well whatever your worldly
experiences were they're all learning at
different rates and and and that one of
me is real intense it [ __ ] hates me
and it hates you
not you and potato but just everyone it
hates it hates the outside world you
know what I mean it wants to kill
everything and me you need to like calm
down with that well no it's just it's
just well it doesn't have any power
because I don't have that it doesn't
really have any power I don't have that
right like I said the worst that I have
is like some other little it's not even
I don't perceive it as another person
but you you know you have that little
voice and you say like you suck you're
not good enough you're not like I have
that but I don't have anything that's
like I'm gonna kill the whole human race
I don't have that yeah I think that's a
you probably well it's it's not like
that all the time you know what I mean
it uh it's weird it's that thing out of
Venom I know same thing Jack Torres has
when he's walking like I said that's a
little that's a little worrying yeah
because I honestly like I I do not have
that like I do have the voice that tells
me how much I suck but it's not like I
wanna like annihilate those no no the
other one wants to you know yeah wants
to kill me I don't have that it wants to
I don't have one that wants to kill me
yeah yeah I just have one that tells me
like I that I am not that I'll never be
good at it no they want you that's the
worst that I have well that's
it hates me and wants to kill me because
I'm too weak
okay that's part of it it's weird it's
weird but it comes and goes you know
it's not it's not constant I don't know
how it's just how the mind works you
know well that's how your mind works
yeah
Well mine's just more intense than I
think other people but I think there's a
lot of people that it's that it's like
yeah I'm not saying that other people
I'm just saying I don't have this one
reason why I have fans is because I talk
about [ __ ] like that because they
probably have that too it [ __ ] hates
me I mean I get where you're saying but
like mine's not extreme is extremist I
don't know I do have ones that are like
now I do have ones telling me to kill
myself I do have that but I don't I
don't have that whole like oh I want to
kill everybody or I hate everything yeah
I don't have that this one's like a it
wants it hates me it's more like an
internal right it's more internal no no
it's that same one you're talking about
it hates me it hates everybody else
it's it's uh demonic it's like it's like
a thing from Venom yeah see my whole
thing is like why would I hate everybody
else it's like I'm the problem you know
what I mean no it just hates everybody
else
because they're trying to raise me too
much now you can't reason with it it's a
it's a demon basically it's like an
eternal Beast
but it doesn't have any power
that's the thing it only has the power
that you give it
I think it's a come on we gotta get back
on the show
it's it's just part of the checks and
balances that are happening inside the
human mind it's just like [ __ ] on the
the skinny puppy album
mind the Perpetual intercourse that's
what it is it says constant conversation
between all these [ __ ] different
facets of you one of Mines is pretty bad
that's why I didn't like any of that
damn
Poltergeist [ __ ] because I don't know
which one is actually in charge
well yeah that's what I mean it's like
and the fact that you have that that
it's that out there right is that's the
only thing that worries me about right
because like I said I have actually that
one I don't know that's what I'm saying
like I have that [ __ ] too but it's like
not that right well that that uh the
Poltergeist when it moved things it
never did anything that was uh
that
but I'm just I'm scared of it because it
might you know I mean you can't tell
what's going to do it's not predictable
well yeah you don't know you don't know
what it's going to do right I mean you
know I know you you just like you could
[ __ ] bust out any minute no you don't
know I could bust out any minute yeah I
didn't know
I could bust out any minute yeah yeah
well you know I'm gonna bust out live on
[ __ ] YouTube maybe well I don't know
do I I don't I don't know I gotta this
is still preservationary I don't know
what the [ __ ] you're gonna do yeah go
ahead and send this to Super Chat people
send Yeti is stupid
I don't think anybody has that no they
know it's all right it's all right
they're not sending this to anybody
today this is a free show
Rebecca says I watch Tom and Jenny
before sleeping LOL yeah I think a lot
of people do I mean we're on for such a
long time watching this before us
leaving yeah
Bruce Jackson says we evolved from the
Animal Kingdom we have part of that
pattern of thought yeah yeah that's true
yeah big time of course we're still we
still are animals
yeah I mean yeah we're not I mean we're
not really that different no
um you know
and I don't say that to like denigrade I
don't think that like people are just
kind of like uh you know I I think
because Tom likes to say it's like oh
people are like just evil hairless
monkeys I don't
the thing about it though is that the
flip side of that is that even apes and
stuff like that have concepts of
fairness and cooperation and stuff like
that so
you know there's kind of like two things
going on you can't just say like oh you
know we're just like animals but animals
have
a lot of the same emotions and the same
thought process that process that we
have we've seen this like I said pookie
who's a cat yeah I mean she has an
understanding yeah of certain rituals
and certain emotions and it's like you
can read her facial expressions and you
can read her you know when she makes
little vocalizations you can tell what
she's
saying and you can tell what she's
thinking Ariel belly dance says 10 out
of 10 agree I think she's talking about
what we were talking about with uh the
the the imagery in your mind when you're
dreaming and you're going down deeper
into these unexplored houses different
versions of yourself I think that's what
she's talking about but yeah that's what
it felt like to me and I think I'm
pretty good at analyzing myself
and so when I dream I'm pretty good at
analyzing what it meant what it meant
you know it had
it's that damn committee talking
you know and you get feelings about what
that meant
when you're going Subterranean you're
going deeper into yourself and the other
versions of you
but love just like old boy said okay we
got more Super chats thank you very much
Camp guy thank you okay thank you very
much uh when you're going through when
you're going into dreams you're
analyzing yourself you're going into the
more animal versions
it's more emotion an instinct
symbols coming up
it's like the fruity and unconscious or
no we're not 40. what's his name uh
young yeah Yankee and unconscious of
yourself yeah
aerial belly dances i dub dog dare
someone to watch my cat and tell me that
he doesn't have feelings like humans do
no they they absolutely do
um who Pookie is like
a human child
in a lot of ways a lot of ways she's
like a human top like not even toddler
she's kind of like a five or six year
old kid asking for attention and wanting
interaction thank you John Robertson
thank you John
thank you and I mean she's very clear in
I mean she's very clear in communicating
like what she wants she wants you to
look out the window with her spend time
and let's play I mean if she wants you
to go to a particular area she will find
where you are she will come to you she
will put her little thing and she will
look at you and be like rare like come
on yeah it's funny because and then
she'll be follow me and then she'll go
to the place where she wants to do the
activity it's funny because you know
we're always worried about what's human
and human beings
when you look at life on planet Earth
all your mammals are real similar
alien would look at us and go those
creatures are very much related yeah you
know uh so yeah you can have a cat and
the cat's communicating with you I know
I know and it's like a little kid you
know but she's very much like a human
yeah we're not we're not all that
different even amongst across species
now
horses are a little bit different but I
can understand them and I've worked with
them because they're more of a hive mind
you know they're more
uh a herd mentality they're not the same
as a a cat or a dog
things that are more generalists are
more like humans because we're not we're
not we're not really a pack animal
well and cats and dogs too are more I
guess the horses have domesticated but
they've been around humans a long time
yeah cats and dogs have been around
humans a long time so they have evolved
kind of to like know how to communicate
but you look at a monkey or a or a
[ __ ] a gorilla or an ape and you can
read their expressions and their faces
yeah their body language and stuff like
that you know what they're what they're
thinking that yeah you know you know
what they're doing it's not out there
right like I said even even cats yeah
I see her facial expression I see
you know vocalizations that she makes
it's like you know what she's getting at
yeah she's very good at like
communicating yeah with people and I
think like other and dogs are maybe like
better at it yeah dogs are might be a
little bit better
well just because they're more pack
animals yeah and they are more social
Pleasers yeah trying to communicate a
lot but like I said I mean we've had
pookies since she was Tiny yeah and
she's I don't think she knew her mom so
no we're her we're her parents basically
she was found when she was like a tiny
kid so you know okay so let's go ahead
and continue all right so like I said
we're talking about uh Tesla so Tesla uh
even in the early like early 20th
century 1901. he was apparently working
on something that I think was later
called like his Tesla Spirit radio or
whatever now if you Google Tesla Spirit
radio
there are plans for making it
uh you can make one if you want to uh
it's all over the internet
now apparently the [ __ ] that he was
working on back then uh a quote that he
said about some [ __ ] some discoveries
that he'd made and this is what he wrote
my first observations positively
terrified me as there was present in
them something mysterious not to say
Supernatural thank you very much Straw
Dogs everybody's sending us money thank
you thank you and I was alone in my
laboratory at night thank you very much
star dogs
so Tesla says this in 1901 now it's
speculated they don't really know like a
huge amount about it
but it was speculated that because he
was an early proponent I mean Tesla was
talking about Wireless technology
uh back in this era you know what I mean
so he was not he did not think it was
crazy at all
um that people could possibly like
communicate with dead people
and apparently uh some radio technology
that he was working with he kept like
picking up
disembodied voices and he wasn't really
sure where they were coming from like he
didn't really understand what they were
saying so he didn't really know uh if
they were dead people or if they were
like an alien civilization or something
like that
so he was kind of like very open with
that like I said if you uh if you Google
Tesla Spirit radio they're you know
obviously it's like better technology
nowadays you can like hook it up to your
computer or whatever but you know
they'll they'll give you instructions
how to build it or what he was
supposedly building but they think that
Tesla was maybe the first person to have
experienced what is now commonly known
as EVP like [ __ ] that was coming over
your radio
also in 1920
Thomas Edison
came out
and told the magazine and this is a
quote I've been at work for some time
building an apparatus to see if it is
possible for personalities which have
left this Earth to communicate with us
so Thomas Edison was also trying to
build a spirit radio
now
he says that he
um he didn't think again like I kind of
feel like this was sort of par for the
course for a lot of people that were
like signed more scientifically minded
in this era which is kind of I don't
think it's like Supernatural or it's not
a cult or anything like that I'm just
saying that it's like it's a scientific
thing that we need to explore and I want
to build an apparatus to maybe like uh
come up with it
so he said he was working on it and he's
like yeah I kind of hope to have it up
and running like a few months from now
or whatever like that was kind of the
thing that he said in the magazine
So eventually this idea of his uh came
to be known as the spirit phone
now
even back then in the early 1920s
the media were kind of like they would
just they made a joke about it I saw
that there was a bunch of like
um
the like uh you know [ __ ] comedic
sort of like drawings or like cartoons
and stuff like that that came out about
it
um they thought it was a hoax they just
thought he was like you know joking
around like he wasn't serious and I kind
of feel like what fed into that was they
didn't really have he hadn't made like a
prototype of the spirit phone that
anybody knows of he didn't have any like
blueprints or you know plans for it or
anything like that
now
so while we don't know if he actually
tried to build actually a spirit phone
or if he had like plans for a spirit
phone
um he did kind of like they think that
he did experiment with the idea probably
now in 2015
uh a rare version of his diary was
discovered and this includes a chapter
that was not printed in the 1948 English
edition which is called diary and Sundry
observations of Thomas Alba Edison which
have been you know published back then
the missing chapter was actually uh
talking about thank you Jeffy Art thank
you
thanks people thank you you're making
the show continue okay
but yeah so uh yeah so this missing
chapter allegedly was all about his
explorations the spirit world and his
kind of like ideas about building like a
spirit phone or Spirit radio which was
trying to he thought that he you could
like contact the spirit world
Ernie e just got here says that this guy
here thought you fired me irony I
thought you fired Tom no how long ago
was that I don't know when she's how
many times have I fired you many times
yeah yeah and yet you still still keep
coming back she can't fire me I'm gonna
[ __ ] live in this [ __ ] I'll show up
I'm gonna drink right next to her
it's only Wednesday you can't fire me on
Wednesday
really I kind of feel like it's probably
more likely that I'd fire you on
Wednesday because because Wednesday we
actually have a topic when are we gonna
oh that you cannot stick to what do uh
look Friday's my birthday I know what
are you gonna do on your birthday
we're gonna eat cake we're gonna show
but you wanna you wanna go to mannequins
yeah we can okay we'll go to mannequins
and when it we're gonna uh although I
want some I want some I will warn you
that I want some sushi too okay I will
warn you though I'm just telling you
ahead of time yeah that this Sunday yeah
is Memento we're gonna go to that too
okay I'll go to both of them okay yeah
I'm just telling you ahead of time I'm
jacked up we're gonna go I don't have a
[ __ ] we're gonna go well it is you'll
like your birthday weekend and it's
Fourth of July weekend Fourth of July
weekend so it would be like a holiday
weekend it's Tom's Birthday everyone
we're celebrated across it's Tom
Independence Day Tom Independence Day
when we go look when we go when we go to
momento memento's The Goth Knight okay
and it's now in the warehouse District
it's [ __ ] close to our house when we
take these toll roads we've got the new
Total we shoot right there it's not in
public
and everybody's wearing skimpy outfits
now because it's not in public
but yeah we don't have to like walk
through downtown
and they don't care if you're [ __ ]
partying out of there thank you Aaron
fire him on his birthday then just
kidding down
thank you for the Super Chat here thank
you and um
I might we'll see how it goes all right
we need to take a video when we're there
we'll put it on the show okay so do it
okay
we need to take that where's that little
camera I have another camera over there
but I don't know I don't like to take my
[ __ ] I don't like taking my [ __ ] well I
mean I can take video on my phone but I
don't really know how like I don't have
a lot of memory yeah so I'm saying we'll
take that little camera because this
thing's too big
you know that camera is Big too I can't
but it's not as big as that do you want
me to like fit everything in my purse
I'll [ __ ] carry it I don't care all
right all right we're gonna take that I
already gotta like [ __ ] take the
person we'll put it up on the show
I mean yeah okay we'll let everybody see
what we're talking about
I told them like tomorrow I gotta order
a cake from the Publix Bakery and he's
gotta go in there he's gotta go pick one
out we're gonna get some cake because I
said well he told me he's like well yeah
he's like well there's one on there that
he likes but I was like well I want you
to like look at all the possibilities
because I don't want to just like a
lemon strawberry cake but they don't
have that one
last time we like chat Ki we last time
we had Strawberry Creek kiwi on the kiwi
no it was
uh
uh I thought it was mango or peach or
something peach peach kiwi it was some
kind of fruit we're gonna find look look
we gotta get back to show y'all are
y'all are throwing her off sidetracked
we gotta [ __ ] we're gonna get to the
show and we'll talk about it oh he's
blaming y'all yeah I'm gonna blame y'all
look we getting a little super chats and
actually we saw that one already yeah I
saw that one already okay calm down okay
but yeah so yeah so Thomas Edison like I
said probably allegedly reportedly
building a spirit phone and spirit radio
um but he didn't want anybody to know
about it I guess
so
his whole thing he thought that
um and this isn't a crazy thing like a
lot of people thought this he thought
well uh his quote was quantity can never
be increased or decreased like life is
indestructible
so our personalities therefore have like
a physical form
made up of essentially like atoms or
like molecules you know what I mean so
he kind of like thought that
so after your body dies he posited that
your personality would be kind of like
in these little like globules these
little bath beads of personality and
they would kind of like exist after you
were gone
and like all these little memories and
thoughts that you would had and so if
they collected together in what back
then they would refer to as the ether
then they could be
accessed somehow like through radio
waves or something like that and if you
had a device that could amplify them
like radio or a record like photograph
or something like that then you could
like communicate with that person still
so that was kind of like how he was
coming at it you know what I mean
so now he had apparently uh made plans
and like had all kind of stuff for these
devices although nobody knows if he
actually built them or tested them or
anything like that but he did reportedly
like draw at least like um you know had
like ideas for them with like conceptual
kind of like uh things
he never named this machine he called it
the valve
uh and it was supposedly like real
sensitive to like vibrations and stuff
and it kind of looked like a phonograph
as it would with like with the horn and
all that kind of stuff it kind of looked
like that
so
so like I said even like the main
scientists of the day were kind of like
experimenting with these ideas and
that's kind of going back to what we're
talking about like that's not [ __ ]
crazy that people like thought that
now let's get into a little bit
um because there was so much scientific
interest in spiritualism and in seances
in particular
obviously people who are skeptical of
the [ __ ] were gonna be all up in this
[ __ ] as well because you know all these
photographers were coming in taking
pictures and stuff like Lou look at the
ectoplasm and stuff and meanwhile like
Skeptics are in there being like that
looks like cheesecloth to me it was like
some luminous paint on it so nice try uh
you know so there was kind of like a
constantly evolving kind of like war
between these and like I said the whole
Spirit photography thing that got called
out pretty early you know what I mean
so during this time period as we
mentioned before very very trendy to
have seances and I feel like it wasn't
even
was it even people that were like
showing up hoping to like talk to their
dead relatives or was it just like
another entertainment proposition
because I kind of feel like if people
did I'm sure people do it now just for
entertainment
but the whole experience of it would be
super cool like you go and you sit in a
dark room and like there's a medium and
there's like creepy [ __ ] like voices and
like horns and floating trumpets and
whatnot that's cool I like all that
stuff I don't believe that's like dead
people talking to me but it's just like
a cool like entertainment thing so some
people might have just been going for
entertainment I think it was a mix I
think it was too I think it was a
mixture I think it was damn some people
kind of saw it as entertainment but they
kind of were curious about it like could
this be real you know it was
entertainment though yeah well and you
have to think too that a lot of times
like at a lot of the seances
um normal rules of like social propriety
I guess it didn't apply right so you
could get away with a lot of stuff like
oh I did all this crazy [ __ ] but that
was dead people making me do it so you
could like you had plausible deniability
right so I kind of feel like people went
just to see what crazy [ __ ] would happen
and there was sexual [ __ ] that would
happen oh yeah big time people pulling
things out of their coochie and [ __ ]
like that
I think we talked about that like on the
Houdini show yeah but uh and and Seance
and Seance [ __ ] medium chicks so I
can say in spicy things to dudes in the
middle of the [ __ ] Seance and you
know that was just I mean I think it was
mostly entertainment yeah and I think I
think your average person kinda was
entered I think most people were
entertained by it
definitely
and it was a mixture of people believing
and people kind of hoping
and some people just not believe in it
you know there there was plausible
deniability though maybe it was real I
mean back in the day like you have to
put yourself back in this time period
there was no TV there was no internet
radio there was nothing like nothing you
could read a book that was pretty much
it
um so somebody comes along I can talk to
dead people and it's like you're gonna
have like all kind of crazy [ __ ] happen
like you know there's gonna be trumpets
floating around it's like [ __ ] maybe
some exoplasmal emerge like there'll be
spooky voices it'll be super creepy and
I'm sure like a lot of people are like
yeah that sounds like a fun [ __ ]
Saturday night I would go back then yeah
I would have gone I was like yeah that's
a good time
now was it all fake
yes
there's a chance where there might have
been some paranormal [ __ ] happens but I
think most of them were basically kind
of like Carney's
yeah and that's like a good uh analogy
because honestly uh yeah most of the
stuff was just like magicians tricks and
to be honest even magicians of the day
like Houdini and like other people could
replicate the [ __ ] that they did and
Houdini did on purpose uh he would go on
stage and he would replicate all of the
stuff they did at uh seances but it
didn't really seem to like deter
um people that just wanted to go yeah I
mean like I said I do kind of feel like
there was a there was a percentage that
were genuinely thought yeah I'm
communicating with dead people but I
think like probably most people are just
kind of like oh they just wanted to see
what would happen in the modern era the
only thing that was close to this would
have been the skull experiments
school
experiments didn't have any independent
witnesses to it
yeah so it's suspect
chances are it was faked probably faked
I kind of feel like all the all the well
all the sound stuff
um it's all like magicians tricks yeah
is pretty much all it is and some of
them are cleverer than others creative
writing sure
mr88 says Edison never had plans or a
name because no one invented it before
him he was Notorious for stealing other
inventors Creations see Louis The Prince
and the motion picture camera I've been
wanting to do a show about Louis
liprints for a very very long time
ruthlessness was a virtue back in those
days okay I'm not saying that's right or
wrong but you were supposed to steal
other people's [ __ ] if you could bring
it to fruition and develop it quickly
and bring it to market then you were the
man
that's just the way it was back then I
mean we we were watching that Series
yeah uh
uh food that what was it called the food
that made America yeah yeah and yeah
like back in the old days of the robber
barons or whatever it's like you came up
with an idea you didn't sell that [ __ ]
someone's gonna take it yeah and that
happened in particular with like Kellogg
and like post and all that kind of stuff
if you watched that episode yeah this
whole thing about well who did it first
and who invented it and who that's a
modern concept they didn't give a [ __ ]
who came up with that [ __ ] first it was
who got it to Market first and if you
stole it then that just meant you were
more of a man they loved that [ __ ]
because you were weak you know what I
mean that was just that was the
mentality because let's be honest
the [ __ ] that they were inventing wasn't
wasn't all that it really wasn't all
that complicated
it was the fact that
the world was wide open all right and
and anybody could basically make
anything
they weren't that smart when it came to
coming up with new products well the
what was smart was is could you bring it
to Market could you Mass produce it
that's really where the trick was I mean
the thing about it I mean the reason why
Kellogg and posts and stuff like that
could make like 40 bajillion dollars on
corn flakes for crisis was because
nobody had done it before yeah but they
just it was like the dumbest like
simplest thing and it just they came
across it like accidentally right and
they it really what made the difference
was that they could manufacture it in
quantity quickly and deliver it well in
an advertising an advertising that was
all part that helped a lot making the
product itself was a tiny part of it
because it was wide open everything was
wide open because nothing had been done
nothing had been done so they would buy
anything
and what [ __ ] stuck stuck
they're talking about Corn Flakes and
all these famous [ __ ] products that
we still use today and but they're not
talking about all the ones that are long
gone and forgotten that also sold back
then
uh there's [ __ ] that people came up with
it was around for a few years and it's
long gone but you don't hear about it
you know yeah you only yeah well you
don't hear about the stuff that endures
stuff that endured sure right but you
could come up with anything back then
and you make a lot of money
because everything was just kind of like
everything was new this everything was
new so now everyone's like yeah I've
seen it yeah yeah
so you you you're only impressed by the
things that stuck that are still around
yeah but everything was ripped off
and it wouldn't have mattered because
any old jackass could come up with some
crazy [ __ ] and it would sell
everything was new
the ice cream bar oh big [ __ ] deal
somebody would invent that eventually
yeah you know put a banana on a stick
and freeze it and dip it in [ __ ]
chocolate and freeze it
you know and everybody just thought that
wow somebody eventually would have
figured out with that [ __ ] anyway it
wouldn't have mattered yeah I mean the
show about ice cream bar like the fact
that somebody like made a popsicle which
like I said seems Seems
counter-intuitive and it's just like why
would anybody pay for that but it's like
nobody had thought of it before right
it's like look some like fruit juice
froze in my [ __ ] porch and I was just
like myself and here it is yeah
but hey I'm gonna sell these but what
made the difference is is not the
invention of the popsicle is that he was
able to bring the popsicle to Market and
delivered it yeah that's the difference
and everybody was into it yeah because
nobody else had thought of it but like I
said it's trying to go by playing music
and you ran up and you go let me have
that popsicle let me have that that's
What mattered not the invention of the
popsicle
it was the delivery of the popsicle to
the market That's What mattered yeah I
mean you could have the best idea in the
world but if you don't have them you
can't deliver it I mean if you don't
have the means to make it or advertise
it or you know get it to a larger
audience then you're not gonna get it
1900s and 1800s they didn't respect
inventors
it was easy to invent back then
real easy
and there was a lot of overlap within
what they really inspected was
production delivery supply chain well I
kind of feel like that's probably still
the case because if you're like some
poor ass [ __ ] and you invent
something super awesome yeah if you
don't have the money yeah to advertise
it or you know diffuse it to a larger
population like some people want it then
you're kind of hosed it doesn't matter
that you were invented it which is sad
but you need money to like yeah
or No One's Gonna know about it right
but yeah so
what were we talking about okay so
seances like I said you know you go
there it's like kind of a fun time it's
like you sit in the dark with a bunch of
people you don't know it's like maybe
like you know girls and boys and it's
like super scandalous and there's like
bells ringing and it's like super spooky
and there's maybe apparitions and
there's also maybe ectoplasm which like
I said I think we talked about this
maybe I kind of remember us talking
about this maybe it was on the Houdini
show but that was a long time ago
I always kind of wonder where the
concept of ectoplasm came from where
does the concept of I'm going to cough
up some white jizz out of my mouth or my
nose or right yeah yeah and that forms
into a ghost yeah
where did that concept originate I'm
very curious and I've never really found
the answer to that I'm gonna say what it
is that it
because that's so weird realize that
they could stuff a [ __ ] white rag up
into the badge it must have been and
then they made that a thing they have to
make that a thing right I can pull this
out of my badge and that's what they
were doing pulling out of the badge I
could pull it out of the badge and then
and then make it and show it to people
and we're gonna have to make the
explanation for that it's ectoplasm it's
nakedness
coming out and it's becoming the spirit
it's the spirit that was inside me and
it's coming out through my various
orifices and it really can't pull it out
of their mouth because you were talking
out of the mouth it's hard to pre-load
that but uh from my readings remembered
most of it was up in the up in the vag I
mean you could you there were some
photographs from the time period that
kind of looked like they were coming out
their nose or their mouth or something
you could kind of like stuff a little
one like up in your sinuses I guess if
you were real one of The Telltale into
it one of The Telltale stories man it's
a long time ago man I was [ __ ] it's
in the 90s that I read this
where
the person at a seance said that
ectoplasm came out of her [ __ ] cooch
and she's and that that dude smelled the
smell of cooch
therefore it was real the smell of yeah
it was real yeah and I'm going yeah she
really pulled that out she really pulled
that but [ __ ] that's not her but then
the thing that's not a ghost smelled
like yeah I mean probably I don't know
I'm thinking of the day was not like
thinking you know the thinking of the
day I mean nowadays obviously everybody
was like why does this smell like your
cho-cha yeah yeah
back in those days they would be like
you know I mean a woman would never well
really pull a [ __ ] rag out of her
cooch
[Music]
that was one of the selling points of
the seances yeah because like I said you
have to imagine
like the majority there was no the
mediums yeah yeah there's no porn yeah
the majority of the mediums were women
yeah
and they were doing all kind of [ __ ] and
they could justify it because they were
saying hey like I'm just possessed by
Spirits man I'm just like conduit yeah I
don't know what I'm doing
um so one if Skeptics were there here's
one thing if Skeptics were there they
would allow themselves to be strip
searched
to make sure they weren't scamming so
who knows what that entailed right you
had to like take all the clothes off
maybe they were sticking their hands up
their snatch or their butt or whatever I
don't really know you need to [ __ ]
get some get get some action great so
I'm saying so there was that going on
and also sometimes uh some mediums
depending on their proclivities would
also like say hey I've been possessed by
a spirit and it's like hey I'm gonna go
around and like maybe perform oral sex
on some of the people that are like here
at the yeah Seance well yeah like um Eva
C did that yeah kind of one of the yeah
well I don't know if it was but yeah it
was something like that something like
where she would go around but like I
said after she was like oh what happened
yeah yeah I wasn't even here suck a dick
that's what I mean so I think that was
one of the appeals like nowadays it's
very very obvious that that's probably
what they were into because you know you
couldn't like come out and just say
nowadays you could just come out and say
and people like all right we get it bro
it was a scene but back then you
couldn't come out and say that because
it's like that was very very yeah that
was like some impropriety like big time
but the fact that well and this is an
era too where it wasn't even really
acknowledged that women had like sexual
needs no women don't like or desires
right so it was just kind of like if
women had like some weird like [ __ ]
fetishes and stuff oh it never happened
yeah everybody thought that didn't exist
or that didn't happen they're all
virtuous right yeah yeah
I hope nobody thinks that anymore but
yeah that's a yeah that's not but I
would never enjoy sex we talk about
they hate crazy crazy they hate it yeah
I know right they hate it but yeah so
the fact that she would just like go
around maybe but allegedly like SEC
random dudes dicks and said that wasn't
me and that was like the spirit doing
that sexy dick yeah
you can see I mean you can start to see
like the appeal you can start to see the
appeal I'm just saying that's funny
that's what I'm saying but ectoplasm has
always fascinated me because I just want
to know
like I said maybe somebody came up with
hey maybe I could like stick some
cheesecloth up my couch
and then pull it out and that'll like
look like oh it'll all look all Ghostly
and [ __ ] like in the photographs maybe
that was maybe it was as simple as that
but it's and then it became a thing
because it's like oh well one person did
it now we all have to do it too because
it was just kind of like I think what it
was it was a magic trick something had
yeah it had to appear from nowhere right
so you have to load that trick and
there's a bunch of different places and
a woman but women back in those days
wore skirts so it's kind of it's kind of
the the next [ __ ] obvious conclusion
I mean is you put some of it you snatch
Nature's purse yeah it's Nature's right
right so but then they start doing this
as Seance as they're pulling things out
of their snatches
and some of the people there are [ __ ]
they buy it and other people are just
mystified because they're like man she
pulled that out of her snatch
I smell it
it's kind of sexy that's just paranormal
because we know we know women don't pull
things out of the snatches it's against
their nature oh my God they're so this
is normal [ __ ] happens there's so much
storage there that's what I think yeah
that's what I think was going on
and I yeah I've seen the photographs of
the ectoplasm I have as well they are
[ __ ]
kind of creepy when you first look at
him and you think of a miniature
little photographs inside the cheese
cloth and cotton it's obviously cotton
and [ __ ] cheesecloth and well what
they did photographs that they cut out
yeah or it was a puppet like sometimes
they would do like a puppet because I've
seen those ones too yeah because I've
seen they're patrolling man ectoplasm
photos yeah and honestly like I watched
a documentary earlier today
that uh BBC and I think it was from like
the early 2000s and there were like some
older people they were in their 90s and
they had been raised in spiritualism so
they were spiritual they were like well
we're not really into the Seance thing
but you know we went to some but we were
raised as spiritualists and they had
like some other and they seemed like
super cool they they seem like nice
people
but one of them said
that when he was a kid he had been to a
seance and he had seen I think it was
his mom like his mom was a medium and he
said I saw my mom like ectoplasm came
out of her mouth
and then went down on the floor and like
puddled and then like built up into like
a spirit that like reached out and like
touched his hands and stuff which if
that's true that'd be impressive it
would be a good trick yeah
um but I still think it's probably a
trick I'm not like [ __ ] on that dude
or anything like that I mean he's
probably dead by now because that was a
long time ago I mean well and he saw it
when he was a kid so I kind of feel like
he probably like built it up in his mind
because well the thing about it is that
ectoplasm what Rebecca says wait a
minute women getting wet is ectoplasm
makes me spiritual yeah it does Rebecca
says [ __ ] a supernatural experience
exactly yeah exactly now back in those
back in those days probably back they
didn't really understand a lot about
female physiology yeah
um so I kind of feel like everything is
like everything that comes out of your
snatch is like kind of like
serious Mr 88 goes well hold on I
thought oral sex was invented in this
night
no no the Romans knew all about this
[ __ ]
there yeah there was some freaky ass
[ __ ] they just didn't talk about it well
the Romans did the Romans [ __ ] made
statues about it they did they were
Shameless yeah but like yeah the the
medieval time period like up until the
victorians they did they didn't talk
about it they did it yeah but they
didn't talk about it yeah are they just
like everything was like euphemistic
yeah but they were doing the same kind
of [ __ ] and I kind of exchanged people
that's what I mean every the people have
been the same league forever yeah but
that's why I kind of feel like nowadays
it's very easy to look back at like the
Seance experience
and be like well obviously this is a
space
where
it's a mixed genders it's like women man
whoever and it's like everybody shows up
and you kind of have license
to behave however you want it's a safe
space let's let's say that because you
can do whatever you want like the medium
particularly
and later on you can just say well it
wasn't me it was just like the spirit
that was possessed me was doing that so
you have like you know it's not you
that's doing it that's what I'm saying
so it gives you like some anonymity it
gives you like that [ __ ]
arm's length you know it just it has
that kind of thing and like I said it's
very obvious nowadays because some I'm
not saying that all the seances like
ended up in like [ __ ] sexual [ __ ] but
some of them absolutely did and I think
there was absolutely a sexual component
to particularly the ectoplasm thing yeah
like [ __ ] came out of their mouth and
stuff but
like I said a lot of times exoplasm came
out of their coach
because that's where you could hide it
yeah it's kind of hard to like stick it
in your mouth if you're trying to like
talk you're talking right
you know you definitely women are gonna
be like well man I can fit all kind of
[ __ ] up there you can have it online
don't want to put it up in your ass
because you pull it out it's going to be
discolored and it's gonna you're gonna
smell that and go oh [ __ ] bro
so yeah yeah coaches wear acidoplasm
usually came from according to what I
read that's what I'm saying so I kind of
feel like it's funny they were saying
that the female the female mediums were
so much better that they could [ __ ]
materialize [ __ ] and it's because it was
it was the coach action now
look
I think some people bought into this but
I also think there was an element of
[ __ ] people knowing what this was I
mean it's still kind of like some of
them had to know yeah come on not
everybody could have been that it was a
mixture of you know people being kind of
scared hey man something might happen in
this one and then other people thinking
it was kind of it's kind of sexy you
know that's what I think was going on I
kind of feel like yeah yeah it was
definitely a neutral component sure yeah
I mean because you had this one medium
which like I said I wrote down this one
medium uh known as Eva C or Eva carrier
that wasn't a real name her real name is
actually more the Barrow
um and she was kind of like one of the
big mediums of like the early 20th
century
and she was actually the first person to
do the exoplasm thing so maybe she was
the one that like invented it what's up
Sly welcome to the show bro hey there
you are yeah where you been
agneslam says ew
that's kind of yeah I was just kind of
like man I don't it was the 1800s though
how badly would I want to make money
yeah to be like hey I'm gonna actually
have some cheese cloth this went back to
the 1700s they were doing this and I've
been up in my [ __ ] up in my [ __ ]
squishment yeah they did this they were
doing this in the late 1700s too 1770s
they did this it's just that it got it
it went to the height
in the late 1800s this this technology
but uh you know it is what it is
yeah so I feel like because Eva C who
was very famous and she was kind of the
first one like maybe she was the first
one to like make
she was like the Instagram influencer of
the day that made exoplasm a thing yeah
and she was a stone cold pervert
I mean she would like run around the
[ __ ] like naked uh would like apparently
do sexual things to like other people
that were at seances yeah so obviously
like everybody would show up at the [ __ ]
and be like all right yeah
um she's trying to give an experience
just a show that's what I'm saying and I
and I was saying that earlier it's like
this is almost kind of like I'm not
trying to like denigrate if people like
spiritual spiritualist beliefs or
whatever but it's like seances were a
performance it was you were paying
people were paying to be there like
performance art yeah so you had to kind
of like if somebody was doing some cool
[ __ ] you had to get famous you had to do
some cooler [ __ ] right yeah you know
what I mean so you had to like fun how
can I do some [ __ ] better than that
right
and it was just like I said it was like
competing magic shows you have a better
magic show yeah and you know this went
back to ancient Greece like that [ __ ]
is David Blaine I gotta do some
Copperfield they're gonna do some Chris
Angel I gotta do whatever you gotta like
[ __ ] like bring that this goes back
to ancient Greco-Roman religions they
were like this too
girls breathing gas and [ __ ] and having
[ __ ] what they call oracles you know
they do this kind of [ __ ] too
so it makes it makes sense
I mean you don't have technology so
special effects have to be some
performance art
you know
if you come from a background of Theater
which you know I'm trained in theater
you can impress a crowd of people
just if you know how to act and how to
speak how to put on a good show
and you know if you have a small group
of people in the house and dimmed lights
and [ __ ] you can put on a great show mix
in spiritualism and sexuality and
[ __ ] Kink all kind of happen and
mystery all happen at the same time
that's what these girls that's what
these women are doing yeah yeah
and they're making a lot of money and
getting big fans well and you have to
experience they're paying for in this
time period too there's not you have to
think there's not like it's not like now
where you can have like pouring at your
[ __ ] fingers they don't have that
right back in the old days yeah you have
to think in the Victorian era most
people had never seen women presiding
over anything or like in charge of
anything so it's kind of like them going
to this Gathering and having a woman
being in charge of it and like maybe
getting naked or maybe pulling [ __ ] out
of her badge or maybe doing so like that
was like [ __ ] mind-blowing yeah yeah
I mean you look at it now and you're
laughing at it but that might have in
those days been the most impressive
thing that that person had ever seen oh
yeah you know what I mean that's what
I'm saying it probably was yeah they see
that and they're like whoa I never saw
anything like that
and you know the spirits are talking to
through her and some [ __ ] flew out of
her vags and she was naked and [ __ ]
nah I contacted the spirit world
I contacted yeah yes yeah
that couldn't have been natural it was
all Supernatural
and that was the and like I said you had
to think too that like even dudes that
were married and were presumably having
more or less regular sex were all that
versed in female physiology no I would
imagine no uh there were it would have
only been a few guys that would call
[ __ ] on it I think yeah I've been
like yeah this is a hoax probably not
but it's actually startling how little
like dudes knew about yeah but actually
nowadays people the dudes don't even
really know that much about female films
yeah back then it was like 100 times
worse the dude the dude that would be to
be in the crowd going this is a hoax
would have said this is a hoax but it's
[ __ ] cool I'm coming back I don't
even care I'm coming back next week I'm
gonna [ __ ] see this [ __ ] again right
yeah Rebecca says here we are talking
about what people did for kicks 100 plus
years ago yeah but many of us would
still do it for kicks 100 plus years
later probably honestly
um I think there are still some groups
that do like old school Seance
experiences yeah I think when we did the
show about Houdini
yeah well that you know who did a lot of
sans debunking
and I was like I would love if like
somebody nowadays would do like the
whole old school Seance experience I
don't think it's real or nothing like
that but it would just like be fun to do
yeah and there are some groups nowadays
that do that yeah so you can go you can
pay you can I want to say some [ __ ]
right now
these seances that people were paying to
see were they legitimate paranormal
experiences I'd say no no no no no are
there legitimate paranormal experiences
yeah there are I mean you can't pay your
way into it those are two different
different things so I'm not [ __ ] on
paranormal stuff it's just that
people were paying to see this instant
paranormal experience that would stick
with them and it was trendy and you had
to use trendy and you had people that
would provide that
so uh but if you want a real paranormal
experience that's not this
but this is interesting what they were
doing it was funny like I said I loved
it I would love to see it I would too I
would love to go honestly I love the
whole aesthetic yeah of Victorian era
Seance [ __ ] I just love everything about
that I would like to go through it and
see the show I would too and that's what
I'm saying see how they did it it's like
if somebody around here did it I don't
think they do I know there are groups
that do it but it's like pretty small
scale if somebody around here did a
whole old school
you know Haunted Mansion type [ __ ]
thing with like special effects and
everything yeah I would totally go I'd
go to it if anybody wants to if anybody
does I mean for a living contact us and
we I'd like to go see it I would like to
do that yeah I'd like to do it if I had
the money yeah and the reason to review
it and we'll do review it on the show if
there's a pair if there's a because I
love experience I love like Victorian
era yeah I love all that kind of stuff
me and Jen even have the [ __ ]
the Wardrobe to dress up Victorian you
have the outfits we'll go to that I
wouldn't mind go to to go and do it to
see what it was that they went through
just yeah if somebody could do like do
all the tricks that they did have like
the spirit cabinet and like the horns
and all the photos without the table and
everything like I said I don't think
it's really paranormal but like man that
would be so fun yeah I think it was a
show so fun
pretty sure it was a show yeah it was 99
but like I said it's still fun though
yeah well like I said it's like going to
the Disney Haunted Mansion right which I
also love
but it would be like that
maybe people back then thought about I
don't know I I kind of feel like back
then probably maybe most of the people I
remember reading some stuff from people
from the late 1700s saying that it was
[ __ ] that it was a show but that
they liked it so that's what I'm saying
I kind of feel like some yeah some
people went because they thought it was
real but I kind of feel like a lot of
people went just because they thought
because it's like cool and fun like we
would go now right exactly like it was a
wrap they weren't dumb yeah no they
weren't they weren't
um Rebecca says don't they do seances uh
at events at the Winchester Mystery
House yeah they might they might I mean
but that's far away
I kind of wish somebody like did it here
we were actually watching
uh a show last night it was the William
Shatner show was it not the Unexplained
yeah we've been watching [ __ ] William
Shatner on the X-Plane it's on he's good
yeah it's on Hulu it's a good show I
think it was from just like a couple
years ago yeah it was 2018. we're on
season one
and he did a show about like yeah he's a
show about Winchester Mystery House well
I thought we had seen it before but no
that's a different show that's his old
show but this is a newer one yeah
he's clearly wearing a girdle clearly
he's like he can barely breathe well he
that [ __ ] can't breathe yeah I laughed
because like I was taking it but I
didn't say it out loud like when he
first comes out into the studio and
there's like a long shot he's like
walking like this yeah a little bit and
I was like that [ __ ] got like a corset
on yeah I know that walk because I've
done that walk many yeah
you know how it is you can't really move
he can barely breathe and I went yeah
and you can't really you can't move you
can't digest anything so it's just kind
of like hey what's up so it's like he's
doing that and I was like that [ __ ] got
like a girl or of course not and then
like we're watching the show and then
like later on in the show Tom's like
does he have a corset on I'm like that
oh my God that's exactly what I was
thinking because when he walked out he
was kind of like
and I was like yeah I know that walk
I know why but he's chatting the [ __ ]
out man William Shatner is always great
whatever I mean he's doing the voice
acting and the [ __ ] talking about
paranormal and Supernatural [ __ ] this
[ __ ] is like Supernatural yeah or is it
yeah
yeah I'm into it it's about this [ __ ]
course well the first one I think was
well it was all like creepy locations we
did like a hokikahara like the suicide
forest like they did all kind of like
[ __ ] that we talked about on the show
yeah it's super fun it's super fun
yeah so what was I talking about oh yeah
Eva carrier so
she was apparently I I don't know she
was the first one to come up with
ectoplasm but she was like the first one
to like uh you popularized it I guess
and her uh seances were real sexual so
you know
very popular Arthur Conan Doyle
who like I said he wrote Sherlock Holmes
so you would think that he'd be like
super
um
you know logical and stuff but not so
much not so much he believed in fairies
and he was like a big believer in
spiritualism as well
and he was a tiresome uh tiresome like
tireless is what I meant to say advocate
of a lot of different mediums who later
on were found to be like completely full
of [ __ ] uh probably including this one
but yeah so he was like a big advocate
of hers
I'm sure he probably had a really good
time with those seances now some other
seances let's talk about some other
famous ones
so we have one in 1874.
which is by a very famed medium named
Cora Tappan Cora LV Tappan
now what had happened was that she I
mean she was well known before this but
she had channeled a London judge who was
very like well known named John W
Edmonds he had died a month before and
she gave like this big Seance this big
kind of like public you know whatever
where she channeled
uh him or so she said and she did this
like this big eloquent speech
everybody that was there that knew him
were like oh my God that sounds exactly
like some [ __ ] he would say and it's
like that sounds exactly what like one
of his speeches and it was like a huge
big deal so you know there was that
was also another case of a woman named
uh Georgina Haughton she was an artist
and she got into spiritualism in the
early 1860s
um after her younger sister died
so what she decided to do later on was
she was gonna combine like the artistic
kind of side of things with the
spiritualist side of things and she
started channeling Spirits allegedly to
do her paintings so she would do mainly
watercolors but I think like some other
ones as well
um now originally she said well I have
like dead family members and I'm like
channeling like the artwork through them
but as more people started paying
attention probably
she's thinking oh I could maybe cash in
on this [ __ ] I'm not saying I'm just
saying that's probably like what what
she was thinking uh so she started uh
claiming to have contacted
famous artists like Titian and corengio
people like that they're coming through
me and they're painting [ __ ] like
through me like I'm channeling them now
I will say that her pain her paintings
are actually quite cool
and uh are still displayed uh as of this
day so she's not like nobody but the
fact that she said that
famous artists I don't know I'm always
just kind of like skeptical of that
also you have the famed poet William
Butler Yates now he was the uh member of
the Order of the Golden Dawn
and he actually ended up meeting a
spirit medium named Georgie Hyde lease
at one of the meetings of the Order of
the Golden Dawn and he married her later
on and they did a lot of seances uh you
know over the course of their
relationship and one of the seances that
they conducted allegedly led to him
writing his poem Vision which he
supposedly did through automatic writing
and did not remember
uh writing at all
here's another kind of famous I don't
know this is famous
Seance but famous like spiritualist
Alcoholics Anonymous founder co-founder
rather Bill Wilson Bill W
ow he was rolling to spiritualism as
well so much so the Deanna room in his
house uh which he called The Spook room
which was
all about like Paranormal and mystical
[ __ ]
and he said that he would go into that
room and he would contact spirits and
stuff and they would tell him things and
he said that his contact with the
spirits in that room was what helped him
get over his alcoholism and he said that
one of these spirits that he contacted
was a 15th century monk named Boniface
and he said in his autobiography that
this Monk and other spirits that he
contacted uh in his book room
was one of the things that was
responsible for him coming up with the
whole 12-step program
so you know okay just just thought I'd
throw that out there
so now as I said so okay
so all these people are into it so
you're gonna get scientists
uh and magicians and [ __ ] like that that
are kind of like well yeah we need to
look into this situation
now one of the most uh the biggest
things that was going on at the time
that spiritualism was big
Scientific American which was one of the
most respected you know scientific
Publications at the time like at least
for the popular audience
they offered five thousand dollars in
those days money which was a huge issue
that was a lot of money
forty thousand I don't think they ever
thought that they would give it and
indeed they did not so
they probably weren't worried about it
they were probably like we will give you
five thousand dollars in Old Days money
to anybody that can produce psychic
phenomena uh that will convince a
committee of like scientists and
magicians and [ __ ] like that like I said
they never gave it away and I kind of
feel like they probably thought they
would never have to so they were like
that's why it was such a big sum and
indeed they never did
uh Harry Houdini was uh on their panel
and like I said we talked about this on
the old show I'll get into it a little
bit but Harry Houdini was uh he was
trying to bust that [ __ ] bigger well and
the thing about it is like I think it's
like a little reductive to say he was
trying to bust it because he wanted it
to be real he was trying to contact his
dead mother yeah he thought that it
wasn't real yeah but he was very willing
he's like look if you can actually
really
put me in contact with my dead mother
um then I will accept it
uh he was willing to believe it up to
like him and his wife Bess they even had
like a um like a code they agreed with
each other like look whichever one of us
dies first you know I'm gonna give you
this code like after you go and try to
see if I send you the message and then
we'll know if it's real or not so he
wanted to believe it he just wasn't
willing to which like I said that's kind
of where I'm at as well you want to
believe it but
unless you see like some better
uh evidence of it you're just not going
to so I kind of feel like that's kind of
the best he was keeping an open mind but
he knew that it probably wasn't going to
happen so he was kind of like one of the
dudes that was on and he was very very I
think he was very offended
um because of a lot of psychics and
whatnot that he'd gone to like following
his mother's because he was very close
to his mother
so a lot of psychics and stuff that he
had gone to following the death of his
mother had given him like some [ __ ]
information and he was just getting
offended he's like look you're just
taking advantage of people's
vulnerabilities after like their loved
ones have died and he didn't like that
um but he wanted it to be real so he
left like that possibility open but he
knew that it probably wasn't
you know what I'm saying I know exactly
yeah I kind of feel like he's still
trying to bust him because they were
[ __ ] taking advantage of people yeah
I and I kind of feel like that's kind of
like the best way to go about it like
maybe some people thought that he was
being like too much of a dick or
anything like that but he really did
expose a lot of frauds
you know and he wasn't saying across the
board look this is this doesn't happen
or this doesn't exist I suspect he
probably thought that but he didn't like
that he that people were taking
advantage of like vulnerable vulnerable
people like him people that were
mourning loved ones and he's like look
you're just taking their money and
you're telling them a bunch of crap and
he didn't really like that he's like I
can replicate all of the [ __ ] that you
do it's not really that impressive so
you know he did want to be real though
so he kind of had like he had his own
career but that was kind of like his
side thing that he would go to
um that he would go to like seances and
you know kind of like bust that [ __ ]
so you also had other prominent
scientists who were trying to debunk
Spirit mediums uh one of whom was
Michael Faraday a faraday cage Fame
right uh he was a very promised Metro
magnetism English scientist yeah very
into the study of electromagnetism
electrochemistry
um and in the 1850s he came out and he
was very very vocal uh about uh kind of
going after pseudoscience in general and
spiritualism in particular uh which were
very rampant in England at the time
maybe even more so well to the same
extent or maybe even larger extent than
the US
the thing that he was most mad about was
that a lot of spiritualists were saying
that
the manifestations that uh came forth
during the seances were caused by
electrical magnetism or anything like
that and he's like that is absolutely
not true so he would try to come out and
say like you know a lot of like table
turning and all that kind of stuff
so he was very big and like look I know
about this [ __ ] and he would like make
things that he would go to like seances
and be like you know prove that that's
not what was causing that so you know
the thing about it uh even though he
actually devoted a lot of his time to
debunking this stuff nobody really
listened they never do
um as James Randy said people that want
to believe this stuff are like what did
he call them Unsinkable rubber ducks
because you just whatever you want to
believe you just want to believe that
you don't give a [ __ ] like what evidence
like people throw your way you're just
kind of like yeah so as much as he came
forth and said yeah this is this is how
they're doing the table turning this is
how they're doing this this is how
they're doing that nobody wanted to hear
it
there was another guy named uh Michelle
Eugene Chevrolet
okay he was a chemist from France
obviously uh he was also really not into
this whole what he called charlatanism
he wrote a paper in 1854 on this whole
subject and he was very into like
divining rods and all that kind of stuff
like proving that that was [ __ ] and
he was actually the one that came up he
didn't call it this it was another dude
that came up with it later that called
it that but he was the one that showed
that like Ouija board stuff and like
divining rods and everything was the
idiomotor effect
um and then there was another dude later
like uh William Carpenter who was a
doctor who named it the idiomotor effect
but actually like uh Chevrolet was the
first one to identify it you know what I
mean like experimentally where he's
saying like look if you point out that
people hey if you're like if you have a
divining Rod it's like if you make them
aware of it it doesn't work anymore
you know what I mean so he's kind of
like he was kind of one of the one that
identified it even though he didn't name
it you know what I mean yeah so there's
that uh there was another guy named
Charles Mercier who was a psychiatrist
uh and he was really not into this whole
like uh the scientific [ __ ] thing
like I said this is during the era of
the thing so there were like a lot of
people that were not into it
um
his whole thing was like debunking
trance mediums and his whole thing he
really did not like the whole automatic
writing thing that was his particular
thing that pissed him off the most
because again he thought that most of
that was
idiomotor effect that's just you like
another side of you it would be easy to
fake that because yeah you have a pencil
in your hand sure yeah and so that was
but like I said back then people were
like oh he's channeling a spirit or
something like that it's like no that's
just like yeah you could fake that
that's just you yeah I mean that's maybe
another side if you're not like aware of
it that could be like your subconscious
or whatever right so he was like the one
that came up with that wouldn't be
paranormal no not at all and like I said
that was kind of like his big thing
right
now Houdini as we mentioned before uh he
debunked a lot of mediums during this
time period but probably he was the
master at debunking him though he was
well because he was a magician he knew
all the tricks every single thing that
he saw at the uh you know seances he's
like well I know how they did that or he
would he could replicate it and then we
back up and tell these people
he was debunking professional mediums
okay yep
a professional medium is someone who's
doing this [ __ ] to make money
if you wanted to make money
and you didn't really have a specialized
skill in the industry becoming a medium
might be something that might attract
you okay nowadays you called a magician
or a mentalist you could make a lot of
money with that that one like that
Guillermo del Toro flick that we saw
never mind yeah yeah that would be a
good way to do it and they were doing
that back then yeah it doesn't mean that
there there isn't paranormal stuff
that's not what that means it's just it
means that you had people
that wanted to make money
with that
uh [ __ ] gig you know what I mean you
could you could do it that way well cold
reading and tricks like that go back a
little bit long way sure that's not the
same kind of thing as a paranormal
phenomenon that's mentalism and you can
teach mentalism to people especially uh
a real uh a real uh [ __ ] uh gifted
person at reading somebody else it's not
paranormal it's just [ __ ] it's normal
it's observation yeah it's observation
you just have to observe things that
other people maybe aren't aware of right
that's all right at least a lot of it
too like cold rating has a lot to do
with fishing and you will see this a lot
like with TV psychics and stuff like
that they'll throw out a lot of
um statements like really quickly
um and they're seeing if somebody picks
up on it what they're doing is I'm
seeing like a female I'm seeing someone
with this name with this that starts
with this letter and they're seeing how
you react to it and then they're kind of
like going back and forth depending on
how you react does that look like that's
getting a response no that I'm gonna go
in this other direction that's kind of
how that works we grew up with them if
you're our age like on Sally Jesse
Raphael what was that chick's name she
said that those girls were [ __ ] that
one girl was dead no oh [ __ ] Castro
had her ass locked up what was that
bitch's name
um Sylvia Brown Sylvia Brown
yeah yeah Sylvia Brown okay
Sylvia Brown was pretending to be
for you youngsters okay
people our age a little bit older know
exactly what I'm talking about Sylvia
Brown was the most famous television
psychic she would show up on a [ __ ]
Geraldo and [ __ ] all these daytime
talk shows right after the game shows
they would [ __ ] put Sylvia Brown up
there and they'd have all shows centered
around her she was a pretty good
she put on a pretty good show but the
[ __ ] was lying she would uh
okay like one of the one of the best
ones that she did was is the you know
they'd have they'd get on there and ask
her about dead relatives and she could
come up with all kinds of crazy [ __ ] oh
no they're bad you know you're you're
your uncle is your your husband is in
the after world and he loves you and all
this kind of stuff and they would ask
her about [ __ ] Crime Victims that
have vanished
and she's oh no yeah she would [ __ ]
say certain things and on one of them
she was telling that oh no she she's
gone she's dead
and it turned out that no that
particular girl was still alive and
[ __ ] old Castro had her ass [ __ ]
tied up in his Sex Dungeon she survived
and let her out later
but it's just uh
it's just [ __ ]
wanna
I can't I don't know where I'm gonna
[ __ ] go with this but she's just like
Sylvia
Sylvia Brown and what was funny about
Sylvia Brown is that she wasn't even a
good Mentalist
he was not that good a good Mentalist
she really wasn't no no I don't know why
she got like famous they just liked how
she looked or in the way she put on a
show but she wasn't even that good
um there evidently were some real good
ones in the past
but it could have been this Sylvia Brown
was famous because she kind of
was always available so she would always
do a show so therefore she got a lot of
exposure I mean she would just kind of
like whatever the case of the day was
she's like yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna
weigh in on that yeah she would do it
and I think some of the classic
mentalists
of of Forgotten eras were a lot more
conservative about what they would get
involved in because they knew that
they'd be uncovered if they went out
there and consistently made tried to
make prediction predictions over and
over again you'd get caught or maybe
they were doing that back in the 20s and
the 30s it's just that there was no
internet and there wasn't television
even so it was harder to catch them well
and most people wouldn't follow up like
if you made like some dumbass
predictions that didn't come true like
ever by the time like some [ __ ] was
resolved they everybody would have
forgotten it I forgot about it right you
know what I mean but in the modern
probably easier to get away with in the
modern era you couldn't get away with it
because although it was recorded yeah
but the thing about it is that even
nowadays
um you can show videos that hey you said
this and like this turned out not to be
true yeah
um even nowadays like 50 of people would
be like well that's fake yeah yeah so
but in the early people are still stupid
nowadays in the early 1900s there was no
ability to record right what somebody
said well like I said nowadays there's
no excuse yeah I mean if you're stupid
nowadays you're just [ __ ] stupid
that's on you back then they got you
recorded saying something back then if
somebody recorded you say like nowadays
they record you saying something they
show it to like your detractors or
whatever or somebody that still believes
you and then he's like well I still
believe what he said that yeah but
you're well yeah you're still [ __ ]
stupid you're dumb you're so [ __ ]
stupid yeah but back in those days back
in those days you couldn't work anything
and they could say I didn't say that
nowadays there's no excuse yeah
why Sylvia Brown didn't didn't last in
the long run she did though she's dead
now she's dead now she left she was
famous till she died
he died before they found those [ __ ]
people that she said were dead
did they though because I think she died
before the Castro made victim was found
maybe Sylvia Brown I think died in the
90s didn't she late 90s early 2000s oh I
don't remember I think she did I thought
she died after because they let nobody
confronted but think about it like I
said this is going back to what I said
about Unthinkable rubber ducks is that
if he really seriously believe in that
stuff you're gonna justify
you're gonna justify it yeah if she says
some [ __ ] up [ __ ] you're gonna like
and you believe in her
then you're gonna say oh well she said
this that and the other you're gonna
like find some like positive spin on it
that's just like how that's how it works
um Rebecca says wasn't Houdini and
Arthur Conan Doyle constantly depending
yes instead of the supernatural yes I
think it would more accurate a more
accurate depiction was is that at least
when it came to Houdini
he was
he was debating what what [ __ ]
so-called psychics were saying well and
really to be fair it's like it's strange
because Arthur Conan Doyle
even though he was the creator of
Sherlock Holmes you would think that he
would be like this big [ __ ] logical
[ __ ] but he fell every dumbass
[ __ ] he fell for that cottingly fairies
[ __ ] yeah he fell for like every psychic
[ __ ] that came along he was very
very gullible which is like that's crazy
to me yeah Doyle was into the Paranormal
he was he'd believed anything I mean I
think he was a spiritualist till he died
I think he absolutely and he went to a
lot of seances with mediums that were
subsequently debunked by not only
Houdini but others and he still like
went to bat for them and he absolutely
believed that from what I from what I
remember Houdini didn't say this didn't
say paranormal didn't exist no he did it
he was saying that people professing
these paranormal Powers were fake
Houdini seems like the ideal kind of
like mindset to have yeah he was
open-minded enough to say hey like prove
it to me like he wanted it to be true he
thought it probably wasn't but he's like
if you can like prove it to me like
without it right a doubt then I'll
believe it right but he just never found
anybody that did back in those days
people faked that [ __ ] it was a living
they could make a living off of fake
well yeah because spiritualism was a big
that was a big money maker a magician
chances were kind of like a big like
trendy thing and says and Houdini was an
escape artist slash Illusionist and a
magician so so he knew he knew about
trickery and he knew about [ __ ]
mentalism you know and Stage presence
even though most of his tricks were real
he really did escape from all that stuff
yeah I mean a skateboarding is Right
distinct magician because that's not
well a magician I consider like an
Illusionist you're making people look
like you're making something look like
it's magic right escape artist that's
kind of different because most of them
are actually doing that [ __ ] I mean
they're doing it they're not telling you
how they do they're just not telling you
how that like I you know I swallowed the
key right up and I [ __ ] all right
so they can get it so it's hidden and
they have like you know things to help
them out right they're not doing it like
supernaturally but that's not really the
same as an illusion right it's kind of
like along the same line it's just not
the same as a mentalist yeah that's also
different a mentalist is almost kind of
like a professional salesman
they're they're manipulating people into
getting a certain outcome that looks
magical looks like they did
[ __ ] it looks like they did [ __ ]
psychic powers on a person it didn't
they they know the [ __ ] power of
psychology and suggestion and they got
someone to do something that they did
well the thing about
psychics yeah in general
I kind of feel like even in this day and
age when we have so much like
information on our fingertips I don't
think people realize how easy it is
to read other people and to uh
generalize to extrapolate like cold
reading hot reading like all that stuff
actually hot reading is very very easy
to do nowadays now that we have the
internet because you can find out pretty
much anything you want to know about
anybody you can just go to their social
media you can find out whatever you want
to know about them back in the old days
they'd have to do cold reading like I
said what they would do is they would
look at you and they would assess well
how is this person dressed like how does
this person carry themselves what do we
think like statistically what is likely
uh to be this person's like personality
or background or whatever they're going
to start with that
if you give them positive feedback then
they're going to go more in that
direction if you give them negative
feedback they're gonna try another yeah
tactic now Sly is asking about what you
think about Palm readers so they're
legit absolutely not no it's the same
thing as a mentalist absolutely they've
taken what you said and [ __ ] they've
I don't believe in anything you have
guided them into something into doing
something kind of like a horoscope
and a horoscope can be very generalized
but it's a it's it's a perceived
this is these are all products and and
they've [ __ ] they're trying to make a
product to sell you based upon a
procedure that they put you through
[ __ ] asking you questions
and based on your answers they'll slowly
kind of form something that's so General
it would have fit to anybody but because
you're talking to them they can narrow
it down more and more into
uh some kind of message that
that they're going to give to you that
you will accept and like because they're
giving you what you want they're telling
you what you want to hear that's all it
is well what they do and they've done
experiments like this
um where they've written a horoscope
and they've given it out to like they've
done this in colleges like psychology
classes they didn't one of my psychology
classes actually and they've done it
like uh around the nation
they type out a horoscope and they give
it to everybody in the classroom but
they tell everybody that they got
different ones depending on what your
horoscope sign was
so it's like this is like because I'm a
Libra so they're just kind of like oh
well this is what it says about Libra so
then like there's a horoscope about it
it's like oh my God that's not just like
me but then like at the end of the
experiment when everybody's like well
how accurate was that it was like oh my
God that was super accurate they're like
guess what every single person in this
room got the same thing exact one see
that that Del Toro flick that came out a
couple years same exact one what's it
called again nightmare alley nightmare
see nightmare alley I mean it's a remake
of a old movie but it's about like
carnies about this dude that joins the
carnival it's an old technique right old
technique and he's because it's not as
hard as you can slash Mentalist he even
gets power over a billionaire back in
the damn 20s and he comes in contact
with this sexy ass chick who's a [ __ ]
psychologist and she can do the same
thing
[ __ ] [ __ ] up people's minds it's a
great movie
and and in the end he has to pay the
price for what he did
uh because he tried to make a bunch of
money off a [ __ ] evil billionaire
it's a good movie I mean the thing about
it the reason that psychics are able to
thrive is because people generally are
not that different no
um and if you tell people what they want
to hear if you tell people
um like I said if you if you uh kind of
like
well massage their egos telling somebody
isn't quite even enough because I was
trained under the [ __ ] discipline of
Robert L shook which is also [ __ ]
known as Hardball sales technique and
you're not telling anybody anything
you're just asking questions and you
continue to ask questions framed in a
certain way to get a person to filter
down to a certain direction to get them
to buy something and they think it's
their idea
very much is the same kind of it's the
same tactic well and if you know what to
look for you gotta know if you watch
like somebody like somebody famous like
John Edwards or somebody like that if
you watch like an old TV show
with him or some other psychic that's
like working a room
you can see exactly what he's doing and
the thing about it and every time I
watch it because like I said I'm a
skeptic so I'm just kind of like
those people in the audience are giving
him all these way more information but
then it's crazy because they'll give him
all this information and he just
basically like feeds it back to them
yeah and then like later on they're like
oh my God he knew this and that and I
was like [ __ ] you told him that right
yeah in front of my face I saw it on the
camera you told him so I see nightmare
Ally
you'll and it will it's a [ __ ]
education on how to do that on how to
control people's minds
and then how mind controllers can have
their minds controlled by another mind
controller it's a [ __ ] it's an entire
movie about scams
it's good it's a good movie we saw it in
the theater I like that movie it's a
masterpiece we talked about it on the
show we've had people in the comments
sections like man thank you for [ __ ]
it was really good thank you for [ __ ]
recommending that I mean like I said
they made it before like back in the
what they make in the 40s I think it's
like a ridiculous 40s but yeah it was
like Carney tricks and they're doing
this and I love movies about carnies
yeah Carney tricks or anything
psychologists propagandists [ __ ]
everything is in the damn movie it's all
about how to how people scam other
people and they don't even know it
okay and that's what advertising and
propaganda is all about same thing well
it's all yeah it's all of the same song
Like the Way psychics work the way this
kind of like seances work it's all kind
of like you're just telling people yeah
what they want to hear you're solving a
problem for them yeah there's a bunch of
different ways I mean they still tell
you that with advertising nowadays sell
it like you're solving someone's problem
because that's kind of like what
everybody wants to hear like I have a
problem please fix it so it's just kind
of like that's the same thing that
psychics are exploiting I mean as long
as you know
it's very easy to see like it once you
know but
if you don't like maybe it's like easy
to fall for but like I said that's
that's the same reason like all the
psychics and stuff like that work they
know that like look you have a loved one
who died and you would love to be able
to contact them and that's a completely
understandable like human reaction to
have but they are exploiting that uh in
the way that it's like I have a solution
to your problem I can talk to them I can
be a channel through which you can
communicate to this person and it's like
can they no obviously not but
they know their Market you know I'm just
gonna say that you know like I said if
you know what you're getting into you
know that it's [ __ ] and you just
want to feel better
that's up to you spend your money
however however you want but please do
not think that they are really talking
to your dead love them because they
absolutely are not but yeah so we talked
about Houdini before
I don't remember if we talked about I
mean he debunked a lot of a lot of
mediums back in the day because that was
kind of like I don't want to call it a
crusade because like I said he was
actually like trying to find
a genuine one he just never did
um so but he was like very very
stringent about how he would go about
you know you know testing them
so his debunking of the very famous
medium named Mina Crandon is probably
like the best known example
of like the whole skepticism versus the
Seance uh kind of thing now if you guys
remember I did a book review I don't
remember how long ago it wasn't that
long ago but I did a novel called
enamorata by Joseph uh gangemi gangemi
however you pronounce his last name not
entirely sure he's a screenwriter but he
wrote like a couple novels or maybe just
this one but it's like a really good
novel and it was a fictionalized account
here Houdini is not in it like he's
mentioned in it but it's sort of like a
fictionalized story about this
time period and about this series of
events you know what I mean like it's
about me and a Crandon but she's not
called that and it's like sort of
fictionalized it's a really good book if
you haven't read it I feel like nobody
talks about it but I really liked it a
lot
so anyway
uh samita Crandon was this really really
famous psychic
she was married to this surgeon who was
like a big [ __ ] deal and so all these
people she lived in Boston and like all
these people like up in Boston Elite
society would like come to the uh come
to the seances
now her big thing was she would Channel
her dead brother's voice like I guess he
was like her spirit control I guess we
want to call it that yeah
um and she would also do like the you
know the regular things everybody would
expect like levitating tables she got
like some ectoplasm uh come out her
mouth and also from her coach because
that was just what you did back then uh
she also did some naked [ __ ]
which like I said probably didn't hurt
because by all accounts Mina was a very
very attractive woman so and she was
younger so I'm sure like a lot of people
would come and be like ooh we're gonna
see like some ectoplasm come out of like
a young hot woman's couch so you know
like I said they didn't really have porn
back then I mean they did but it's like
it wasn't like nowadays where it was
like super easy to get to no Sly uh
nightmare alley is kind of based on real
[ __ ] that they used to do back then but
it's a fictional story it's uh you can
learn a lot from Nightmare Ally it's an
old story
I've always well you know what I'm I've
always been really interested in I we
did a show a while back called secrets
of the sideshows yeah I've always been
very very interested in like Kearney
culture yeah I really really like
because that's like a whole subculture
of its own and they have their whole
they they have their own like uh you
know slang they have their whole
there's a whole thing that goes along
with like and I love that and a lot of
it has to do with magicians are like
Conjuring or yeah you know just the way
that you're trying to like get money out
of the rooms is exactly what you're
trying to do slide that's what it's
about it's about getting money out of
[ __ ] rooms okay and they show sad to
say they show kind of their whole thing
in that movie how Carney's okay
propagandist psychologists and
billionaires it's all the [ __ ] same
thing they're they're all carnies the
only difference is the damn social class
and you'll you'll love it pretty much
you'll understand you'll understand it
when you see it they're saying the
[ __ ] life and Society is a con job
it's mind control well the whole thing
like I said basically all carnies are
trying to do and it's the same thing
they're like corporate corporations are
trying to do but it's like on a on a
bigger scale yes the difference is like
I said the differences I don't denigrate
like Carneys because it's like they're
doing the same thing just on a like
smaller you know scale that's all just
see it came out what is that a year ago
yeah we're living in this house I think
would have so it must have been 989
months yeah
I was [ __ ]
um nightmare alley it's a masterpiece I
think it's on Hulu now if you want to
watch it like I have Hulu so I can watch
it but
um yeah yeah it's a very instructional
movie
so it's like I was I was into it like
from minute one yeah no matter who it is
they're all trying to make you the geek
they're all trying to make well they're
just trying to like part you from your
money yeah yeah and like I said as long
as you know that that's what they're
trying to do if you have a good time
like I said I'm not gonna be mad like if
I pay money to go through like a haunted
mansion or something like and I have a
good time I'm not mad about that right
because I know what I'm getting into the
only problem I have is if you're selling
me something you don't know what it is
that is not what you're claiming well
that's what that's making you the geek
and that's yeah and that's kind of like
what the whole thing is but like I said
Carney culture they're just kind of like
hey look we have this like deformed baby
in a jar which is probably like made of
rubber
um but you know because a lot of them
are but yeah like if you're interested
in that at all please read there's a
book called
um secret I think it's called the
secrets of the sideshows and it's by Joe
Nichol and he talks all about because he
uh you know was real he's very he's a
skeptic and he writes a lot about that
but he like worked in a lot of sideshows
when he was younger and it's like a
fascinating look into and how they make
all of the like the babies and like all
the freak Show stuff and like because a
lot of it's most of it's fake obviously
yeah
about Robert L shook yeah Robert L shook
you wrote A Hard Ball
most of the world works on Hardball and
he was kind of a carney-like figure
just [ __ ] go watch the go watch go
watch [ __ ] uh [ __ ] Damnation Alley
you'll like it
nightmare nightmare Ally go watch
nightmare Ally [ __ ] the new one
you'll like it you'll understand
did you guys see the Flim Flam man
George C Scott from 1967 I don't think
I've seen that yet actually
I've heard of it but I haven't seen it
but yeah so the thing about it like Mina
Crandon is she was very famous and she
was very um because her husband was a
surgeon and he was kind of wealthy so
she maybe kind of got away with a lot of
stuff because there was you know a lot
of Rich she had a lot of Rich patrons
and stuff so she's like pulling
exoplasma on her couch and
people are like scandalized but it
wouldn't be like if a poor person did it
you know what I'm saying it was because
it's kind of like that kind of thing
but the thing about it is that I kind of
feel like one of the reasons that the
church was opposed to a lot of this
stuff
not necessarily because well one because
it was competition I think that was the
main reason but two you know were they
concerned oh this is like of the devil
or whatever because they're like
contacting maybe demons or whatever yeah
maybe that was like a lip but I think
like the main concern was that there's
like some pornographic [ __ ] going on in
there we don't like that so I don't know
there was that I think that was their
main objection was that there was all
kind of sexual [ __ ] going on
but so uh so yeah the thing about it was
that so the Scientific American people
like I said five thousand dollar prize
if anybody could show them like actual
psychic abilities
so Mita Crandon was one that they went
to numerous times like I said if you
read the novel enamorada it's
fictionalized but that's that's what
it's based on and this is all real [ __ ]
that happened
so a bunch of them go there and the
problem arises when
one or more of the members of the
Scientific American team
uh became
uh infatuated with Mina granted because
like I said she was kind of young and
hot maybe one or more of them allegedly
became sexually involved with her so you
know there was that also uh so you know
there goes their objectivity out the
window
uh so there was like a lot of [ __ ] going
on there so now Houdini at this point
had already written a book called a
magician among the spirits in which he
debunked a bunch of psychics now he did
write a pamphlet later on uh in which he
discredited Grandin talking about all of
the tricks that she used like to
facilitate her uh stuff that she showed
during these Seance and he also took a
bunch of the [ __ ] that he that she did
during the Seance and did it in his
shows like he even did like a whole tour
where he's like hey I'm gonna do all the
tricks that they do at seances and he
did them all like he replicated all of
that
despite that people still [ __ ]
believed in the [ __ ] anyway
even though he could replicate all of it
and said hey it's not Supernatural look
I'm just like an Illusionist and I'm
doing the same [ __ ]
he's not he didn't tell people how he
did it but he's like I'm saying it's not
Supernatural but people still believed
it anyway
so because of Houdini uh Mina did not
win the five thousand dollar prize
actually I don't think anyone ever won
it like I said that was probably why
they felt safe offering it because it
said nobody's ever gonna well it was
just kind of like how you know James
Randy like in more recent times offered
a million dollars to any psychic that
could come there and like demonstrate
that they had actual psychic or
supernatural abilities under laboratory
conditions that they both agreed on and
nobody ever won it nobody ever won it I
don't think everybody anybody ever even
came forth they did did they lots of
people do lots of people did all right
from what I remembered no lots of people
did uh and they tested them well the
thing about it was that
he was very adamant he said look both of
us have to agree
on the the experimental protocol before
we go into this if we both agree on the
protocol
good and then we're going to go into the
product to the to the experiment he's
like most people would have ran the
protocol but then they wouldn't show up
for the experiment okay
um or if they showed up for the
experiment they would fail nobody ever
ever won it but a bunch of people did
try a bunch of people did try so I don't
I don't know where you heard that but a
lot of people didn't show up nobody even
showed up yeah they did a lot of people
did he said well a lot of people didn't
get past the point of he's like it's
weird because a lot of people would ship
well it's not weird but a lot of people
would show up saying yeah we agree to
all your demands he's like look do we
agree this is how we're gonna do the
experiment this is the protocols we're
going to put in place they're like yes
we agree to that okay at this date we're
going to show up and we're gonna do it
like this
everybody would agree
most of them wouldn't show up yeah
that's what I remember the ones that did
show up okay failed yeah fail so nobody
ever won that money and James Randy
actually uh died recently but I mean he
was very old he was like he was all back
then he was a hundred and well he lived
until he was a hundred was he 99 he was
all he was almost 100. he was old my
whole life yeah he was almost 100 when
he died he lived a long time yeah I was
always a big fan of James ready he was a
little cranky but I kind of like that I
kind of like that you know what I mean
you know yeah well whatever
yeah well whatever he was just some old
dude I didn't really care one way or the
other from what I saw well no I read a
bunch of his books and it's like I read
a bunch of his writings it's like he
seemed like a good dude you know what
I'm saying I mean you probably didn't it
was no I didn't know much about it
that's what I mean you didn't know much
about him but yeah so I thought he was
cool but anyway
so yeah she didn't get the Scientific
American prize and later on uh her case
would kind of like be another dividing
thing because
so because the you know all the
Scientific American people they couldn't
agree on the [ __ ] because I think at
least one of them was maybe allegedly
like sleeping with her so there was that
whole issue so that didn't really work
out but
later on uh the American Society for
psychical research was founded in 1885.
now the British equivalent of that had
been uh founded a couple years earlier
so their whole thing was we're kind of
like we found we did this Foundation
we're gonna like look into spiritual
phenomena and we're gonna look into it
scientifically so they were taking it
seriously like back in the old days
now uh for the most part most of the
stuff they did back in those days was
they would just disprove stuff
however there was one kind of like I
don't know if it was famous but it was
kind of like a well-known case where one
of the members
of the uh American Society for psycho
research William James who was a
psychiatrist
uh he was kind of like okay one of his
famous quotes was they asked him why do
you guys keep this debunking workout
his famous quote was if you wish you
upset the law that all crows are black
you mustn't seek to show that no crows
are it is enough if you prove one single
Crow to be white
so the case that he called his
quote-unquote white crew
was a psychic named Mrs Piper Leonora
Piper to be more specific
now she was a Boston housewife and she
had turned trance medium
now because For the First
couple maybe Decades of her career let's
call it that she hadn't been debunked
so she was able to command very very
high fees
um she was very well known in the U.S
and in England and made all kinds of
money like she was touring all over the
place
now what happened with her
was that in 1885 William James the
psychiatrist member of the American
Society of Google research
his son died so like I said this seems
to be like the Catalyst for a lot of
people like someone that particularly if
their child dies
um they're looking for answers and a lot
of them look to it uh look to
spiritualism to give them those answers
his whole thing was he was an agnostic
but he was kind of like well
maybe like there's some other like I'm
keeping an open mind in case there's
some kind of like scientific maybe there
is some kind of like way for the dead to
contact us uh you know and maybe there
is an afterlife he wasn't like uh
traditionally religious though
now the thing about him was he seemed to
have gotten swept up
into the whole Leonora Piper
fan club I guess
he thought that she came up with stuff
that could only have been discovered by
Supernatural means
his quote about her
after attending several seances that she
had presided over was my own conviction
is not evidence at least he knows that
it seems fitting to record it I'm
persuaded of the bdm's honesty
and of the genuineness of her trance and
although at first disposed to think that
the hits she made were lucky
coincidences
or the result of knowledge on her part
of who the sitter was and of his or her
family Affairs Bingo that was me I now
believe her to be in possession of power
as yet unexplained
see at this point I kind of feel like
the death of his child had blinded him
to what he would normally because he
seems to be like
he seems aware
of
how he could go wrong and yet still yeah
interestingly though what's interesting
about his whole like uh approach to the
subject
he didn't actually believe that she was
talking to dead people or talking to
Spirits
he thought that she was telepathic
which like I said seems that's still not
all that believable it says more
believable than talking to dead people
though
so at least he was kind of like I don't
think that he's actually talking to my
dead son for example I think that she's
pulling information out of my head right
yeah and like feeding it back to me so
at least he wasn't like completely far
gone because like I said that does seem
a little bit more believable than
talking to dead people you know because
that seems like a a way more like uh a
way higher like wall to climb let's call
it that
um so he didn't really find like that
much independent evidence to support it
but because he believed it he just kind
of like believed it you know what I mean
so there was that
now unlike Mina Crandon who had been
debunked and another prominent medium in
the time eusapia Palladino who was also
very very prominent but was also caught
using trickery many times
uh Mrs Piper was never actually
officially like fully discredited I
don't think that's because she was a
fake because I'm sure she was but nobody
was willing to nobody caught her in the
act like most of the mediums at the time
I don't know what you've heard but most
of the media the times were caught
um doing like some magician type [ __ ]
like sometimes there was one medium
camera what her name was but she um she
would do a thing where it's like oh the
ghost is going to talk directly at you
did we have this trumpet that has like
this luminous like paint on it and when
somebody like a skeptic was there
because she would do the [ __ ] in the
dark obviously they usually would
when somebody who was a skeptic and
she's like oh the spirits really don't
like like uh flashes or like any kind of
like light or anything
but when one skeptic like actually like
lit a match and like took a picture he
got a very clear picture of her talking
into the big end of the spirit horn yes
and like the little end was right next
to the ear of the person that was like
the target of like who the spirit was
talking to and she was like like
Whispering into like yeah so he got why
were they he got a very very clear
picture of her doing that
um so you know so I kind of feel like a
lot of mediums back then were caught
doing [ __ ] like that but some people
still believed it anyway more reasons
they always do yeah like I said they
always know that the spirit [ __ ] they
weren't talking that day so I had to do
something to like well I had to like
console this person they always have an
excuse they always have an excuse always
how did they fall for such [ __ ]
simple [ __ ] tricks that's what I'm
saying I kind of feel like a lot of them
probably just wanted to yeah they wanted
I mean I can't imagine like I said I
can't imagine they were tripping
if your child like a child died I can
that's like the worst yeah and I can't
imagine I don't have any children other
than fur children but it's like I don't
have any human children so it's like I
can't imagine what that would be like so
you grab the [ __ ] you grab the
[ __ ] thing you start whispering you
pointed at somebody's ear and then they
go which yeah I heard it it came from
another dimension it was a [ __ ] yeah
because it sounds ghostly spooky sound
that [ __ ] I can tell Came From
Another Dimension this is good
people were [ __ ] well people were
easy back I mean it's so sad well no
like people still they fall for it now
it's like it wasn't it's not like a long
time ago people still fall for that
stuff now and to me it's like it makes
me come out of the world it makes me sad
like it makes me sad like I get it I get
it like if you're particularly like I
said a parent whose child does because
that's [ __ ] up and that shouldn't
happen
when that happens I can see how you're
looking for anything and you're looking
for and especially if your child died in
a violent way like if you were murdered
or something like that so I can see like
if you'd go to a psychic and that would
like make you feel better because it
would give you some
you know some kind of closure like some
kind of certainty because I kind of feel
like people like certainty they're very
uncomfortable with like not knowing [ __ ]
so it's like if you don't know like what
happened to your kid like maybe it's
very comforting for somebody to say oh
well you know they died but they're
still there and they're watching you
blah blah and maybe that's like really
comforting it's probably like it's not
true probably yeah but
I don't know like I don't know how I
would feel if something like that
happened like I've had loved ones close
to me die
but
and I'm sad that they're not around
anymore but I don't think I would ever
fall for like somebody telling me that
they were still around and they were
talking to me that to me that seems very
exploitative but like I said you know
everybody's different
yeah I'm just kind of like I don't know
how it would feel if I had a kid and
they you know disappeared or some [ __ ]
like just hypothetically and like
somebody came and said hey I know what
happened or they're fine or whatever
it's like that might be really
comforting but I don't I don't know I
don't see that because like I said I've
I've had very close people close to me
die and it's like I don't
I wouldn't find that very comforting to
like have some stranger come to I was
like well if they Well here here's the
thing like if I had a kid hypothetically
and they died and I was like why don't
they just talk to me
why would they talk to like some random
ass [ __ ] who's like looking for
money for like why would they talk to
some would just talk to me directly look
look here's the thing
we're we're only receiving stories from
the past yeah that's what has happened
okay
chances are a lot of this is [ __ ]
probably the average person didn't want
anything to do with the people that had
passed away like and didn't have
anything to do with [ __ ] seances
we're only getting messages from the
past about you know what I mean
there's stories about the past yeah
about people wanting to talk to their
loved ones I don't think chances are it
didn't happen
this this might be propaganda
you know what I mean well what what
exactly like an advertising propaganda
in other words you're hearing from the
people trying to sell seances that other
people came to the Sea outs and talked
to their loved ones and and that they
that they liked hearing from them you
don't know
well that's what I'm saying and I think
that because seances were such a big
like trendy thing back in the day I
think like a lot of people that went
probably just went because it was like
something fun thing to do right and it
was like a fun thing to do this is our
chances are were they trying to talk to
like a dead relative probably not they
were just wanting to see you later
happening right like I said just like
going to the Haunted Mansion like Disney
World oops I'm gonna like see some like
creepers it's more likely I think it's
more likely that this is all a show and
it was a show even back then and nobody
bought into it even back then or very
few people bought into it oh I'm sure
some people did I think some people did
yeah but Conan Doyle and the people that
yeah some people did and the people that
were recorded in history that we're
getting but I I would have I have a
feeling that the average person knew it
was a [ __ ] [ __ ]
maybe I think so well we'll we'll see I
mean you know how long we've been on the
show
four years left four hours
not much okay I mean do I really I'm
hungry man I'll make us something to eat
okay maybe we should just eat okay you
wanna if you want to eat so is there
anything else you need to tell them I
mean not really I think I was kind of
like I mean there was [ __ ] left but it
wasn't really all that it's not all that
important okay well it's on it's on you
you're running the show I'm just saying
if you're hungry I'll make something to
eat if not you can close it down
they're talking about Miss Cleo what are
they saying about Miss Cleo is she still
around did she die I forgot all about
that
Springer [ __ ] wasn't she like a fake
Jamaican I think it was just yeah yeah
bacon yeah
psychic on Jerry Springer wouldn't it
well she had like um no that was like I
don't was she on Jerry Springer well she
had like those um what do you call them
infomercial infomercials right yeah but
that was always playing
like late at night in between Jerry
Springer [ __ ] episodes yeah yeah I
can remember what it was like back in
the [ __ ] 90s
looking after you get off your [ __ ]
work schedule and it's [ __ ] three
o'clock in the morning and remember back
in the old days when they didn't have
like 24 7 like streaming or like TV and
stuff and it's like after like midnight
or something like that it would all be
infomercials infomercials that was all
you had to watch you only had
infomercials and Jerry Springer and
[ __ ] daytime it was the Dark Ages
there's the darkest and you were forced
to watch that [ __ ] you'd be sitting
there after your work shift [ __ ]
three o'clock in the morning go God damn
there's nothing going on tonight you
turn that [ __ ] on a [ __ ] old color
television in some little [ __ ] place
you were renting when you were [ __ ]
20 20 something years old and you're
watching that [ __ ] [ __ ] eating
Ramen God [ __ ] [ __ ] man I can't wait
till [ __ ] Saturday night
yeah it was just it was the [ __ ] oh one
thing I did want to say like to wrap up
the show okay so remember how we talked
about the fox sisters yeah and how they
started the whole spiritualism movement
yeah okay well uh toward the end of
their careers if you want to call it
that yeah uh one of them
Maggie yeah came out on stage in front
of it she's in her 50s at the Academy of
Music in New York City
and came out and said spiritualism as a
whole is a fraud and demonstrated how
they had done the whole thing that
started the whole thing with like the
wrapping and everything she's like look
I did it by clicking my toe joints they
just clicked their joints and that's
what they would do they'd ask a question
they go click click click now
you would think that this would have
killed spurge and to be I mean it kind
of did like because a lot of um media
came out and it was just kind of like
making fun of it and stuff but
spiritualism didn't die like it's still
around today so obviously it didn't like
[ __ ] on it forever but the fact that
Maggie came out and said yeah we faked
it all this is how we did it
but then the thing about it was that
like a year after that she recanted that
recanting yeah so then the spiritual is
like oh we'll see yeah
they're saying there wait here where
[ __ ] they're just saying oh yeah man
it's a [ __ ] blast in the past with
the net 1900 number yeah yeah
I can't read yeah like I've is she I
thought I heard that she died yeah but I
don't know if that's true or not I don't
remember where I heard that or why I
know that
Arielle belly dancer's going uh yeah
that she was uh was she was a fake
Jamaican psych late night 900 numbers
yeah those that was another error man
these young people don't know about that
[ __ ] yeah remember like the P the 900
numbers yeah the 199 numbers after yeah
you had infomercials and it was just all
kind of call 1-900 blah blah blah like
for a psychic show well there were sex
lines too but it was just like a lot of
it was psychic [ __ ] and then the [ __ ]
party lines and it was like three what
was it like three dollars three dollars
for the first minute you know like a
dollar per minute yeah you could talk to
any other kind of losers that didn't
have anything to say this time and do
you know like I don't know if you guys
know but it's like the people that were
doing that they were just like some
chicks like living in some trailer park
somewhere yeah and their whole thing
they're working from home working from
home their whole thing was they have to
keep you on the phone as long as
possible yeah yeah so they would just
like keep asking you about your [ __ ]
they wanted to make as much money out of
they didn't give a [ __ ] about you that
was the same as all the [ __ ] phone
sex lines remember yeah
they just wanted to keep you on the line
as long as possible so they could charge
your [ __ ] credit cards well and the
thing about it that's sad is that like I
kind of feel like a lot of people
they're calling that we're just [ __ ]
lonely and they just wanted somebody to
talk to yeah at this point I'm just like
dude just talk to yourself it's free
yeah Agnes lamb says this is a good show
guys
because I had to water the guard [ __ ]
Agnes was in there [ __ ] flirting with
me earlier so you flirt with me I said
yeah I flirt with you the slide jumps in
because no no flirt with me is y'all
need to knock it off if any of the
author says God I feel old yeah who said
this I mean me too but yeah yeah oh yeah
yeah the sex lines were on just about
every channel after about 3 A.M yeah
yeah around 3 A.M yeah you're back from
[ __ ] work
well yeah I well I used to work in a
newspaper and I didn't get off until two
in the morning in the morning so I'd
come home and it would be like 2 30 or
three right and you turn on the TV and
all that was on was like infomercials
and you're like 25 or 26 and broken [ __ ]
[ __ ] renting a room out of [ __ ]
some house you and your friends are
living in and [ __ ] you're like damn
I'm [ __ ] starving [ __ ] hungry and
then you try to make a Ramen and back in
the old days it wasn't like now where
you could just like call up and be like
hey like uber like Uber Eats me so yeah
no it wasn't like that oh like the
doordash the only thing you could get
was [ __ ] um either pizza or [ __ ]
you couldn't even get pizza because that
closed at like 11 or midnight I was in
Boston at that time so I could get
Chinese delivered okay I could get
Chinese
you couldn't do that every night you'd
be [ __ ] spending four or five hundred
bucks a month on [ __ ] Chinese so you
had to eat ramen I mean we couldn't even
get delivery pizza after midnight and
even well weeknights you couldn't get
[ __ ] past 10 or 11. like yeah Friday
night Saturday night you could maybe get
like pizza up until like midnight but
after that no way there was nothing
there was nothing I was eating Ramen you
either had to like drive out to [ __ ]
Denny's
throwing Vienna sausage in it or you'd
have some [ __ ] spam in there [ __ ]
cutting slices and [ __ ] on toast and
[ __ ] watching [ __ ] Jesse lake or no
wasn't it Ricky Lake
Sally Jesse
Robinson Williams Montel Williams might
tell you Williams was like America's dad
at that time he would jump in there and
[ __ ] tell you what it was you were
supposed to do all the while the
[ __ ] run around in a Humvee
banging white broads he'd have like two
or three of them at a time Montel was
the man and he's telling everybody he's
telling everybody else how to live a
moral life and [ __ ] [ __ ] don't tell me
that [ __ ] was
Montel man no but I liked Montana was
the [ __ ] man I knew Montel was [ __ ] a
player I could tell you it wasn't as
over the top as some of the other ones
uh yeah well Montel came up kind of came
across as just a regular guy if you ask
me some of the other ones I think people
the reason that I don't remember like I
remember Montel Williams but I don't
remember like a lot of the [ __ ] that
happened on his show it's probably
because he was a lot more restrained
yeah Montel was reasonable
huge reasonable the thing about it
though was that some of the shows like I
kind of feel like Sally Jesse Raphael
yeah kind of had an excuse me well no
but she had a good angle on it because
she seemed very reasonable she would
like very be very serious that she would
adjust her big ass glasses yeah in the
[ __ ] race what is it like that you
were doing now and then but she would
have like the craziest [ __ ] [ __ ] on
yeah not as crazy as like Jerry Springer
yeah good I met Jerry Springer down the
French Quarter of New Orleans he was at
my [ __ ] friends [ __ ] club it was a
goth fetish club and Jerry Springer was
[ __ ] cool he's very cool me and him
are [ __ ] sitting next to each other
this is back in like uh 98
and we're watching this couple go
through their whole fetish thing and
he's [ __ ] sitting there he bought me
a [ __ ] couple drinks there's only
like 12 people in [ __ ] at Pierre's place
it was called [ __ ] hellfire club and
and he would come to goth fetish clubs
goth industrial fish clubs uh he loved
the French quarter but he would leave
at towards the end of the night he'd go
up to uh
he'd go to the mainstream bars on
[ __ ] Bourbon Street
but he was he was saying man I love you
guys he was like that I love you guys
you guys are [ __ ] great you know all
right and [ __ ] yeah he was yeah he he
uh yeah he loved the [ __ ] underground
scene Gary Oldman would hang out up in
there and [ __ ] so would [ __ ] uh
Marilyn Manson and uh dude from Nine
Inch Nails [ __ ] and it was I I told
stories about that already but if I can
be up there pierce place a [ __ ]
hellfire club [ __ ] the Decatur Street
Decatur and Esplanade it's gone now he's
long gone
and [ __ ] we were sitting there
watching this [ __ ] hot blonde
[ __ ] up on the damn rack and dude
[ __ ] paddling her and [ __ ] and it was
all this [ __ ] Sensational [ __ ]
seductive [ __ ] soft [ __ ] bondage
and
Springer [ __ ] bought me a drink I'm
sitting next to him this big wicker
[ __ ] thing and you can understand
something I was not a famous
[ __ ] Okay not like I got a show
now I'm just a regular dude in the
corner just a regular you know in in the
scene of the time I knew the peop the
bartenders and the and the club Owners
and uh it's funny I mean it was like
[ __ ] it was all meta and [ __ ] I'm
[ __ ] hanging out with Jerry Springer
he's much older than me and he's like
man I love you guys this is a great
scene I love you guys in fact we're
looking at this chick's ass this is
[ __ ] weird you know it's a it's
really weird because now that you
mentioned that because we were at
mannequins last Friday yeah and they
were having a fetish party yeah
and I was thinking this because we had
like our friend uh I'm not gonna say
whose name is but our friend and his
wife yeah were doing like their fetish
thing like up on the stage they had like
the big X thing and yeah
and it's like so we're and like no one's
even paying attention no because like
yeah let's play it out so but the thing
about it that was funny I was just like
standing there by the bar like drinking
and waiting for a good song to come on
and this Normie dude comes up and he's
like this is the first time I've I love
this scene I've never been here before
and I'm just kind of like
uh we grew up in this [ __ ] man this is
boring Where Have You Been yeah like for
the last yeah 30 years
did you just like wake are you a caveman
have you just like woken up from some
like what yeah yeah yeah I didn't really
get it no like I wasn't gonna be mean
but I was just out I'm just like looking
at him like yeah I don't know where
you've been I actually during that era
though [ __ ] watching television you
know coming out of the army and it's
between the [ __ ] my service and then
911 hadn't happened yet I also liked
Ricky Lake
I thought Ricky Lake was was of like a
friendly and fun somebody pointed out
she was in Serial Mom who
well she was in uh like the John Waters
movie Hairspray as well not the remake
with John Travolta but the original I
didn't know but no I thought she had a
good show she played Tracy term lead I
didn't see it uh yeah you did we watched
it together really yeah you gotta
remember it I didn't know it at that
time I didn't grow up with that movie
but uh no I liked I liked her show
because she was just kind of fun
and bubbly kind of personality
weird it's weird because you're watching
that [ __ ] back in the day you don't
think everybody else is watching it
because it's the middle of the night
when you're seeing it
you know what I mean there's a bunch of
other weirdos
yeah
a bunch of other insomniacs yeah like my
ass like watching it it's like well like
I said but for a long time I worked
night shift and I didn't get home until
like 2 30 or three in the morning so a
lot of times I was like watching and
even when I was like a teenager
you know like most teenagers I was up
most of the night so I was like watching
and back then like in the 90s uh in well
late 80s early 90s when I was a teenager
you were kind of like there wasn't
anything to watch we didn't have
streaming we'd have any so you were kind
of like stuck watching whatever Danny
Ghostface says Girls Gone Wild I
remember that ad yeah remember that [ __ ]
yeah it's funny I mean all this like
[ __ ] sex line yeah ads were like so
[ __ ] funny yeah I mean some of them
like catered to
I never saw this one I only know about
it because Mystery Science Theater
referenced it apparently it was a
Midwestern thing but apparently it was a
what do we want to call it a water
sports
what we tell them
peeing like people that are into like
who is this and I saw like there was a
there was a sex line okay
it was apparently only advertised in the
midwest I never saw it
I only know about it because of MST
because they made references to it so I
looked it up so I was like what does
that mean and I was like oh okay but
apparently there was a sex line and it
was advertised in the midwest it was for
water sports water sports
like like peeing on people yeah but I
didn't know they had a sex line for that
they did
and the sex line was oh it was 1 900
something p
and I was like
they didn't even like try to hide it
which I thought was that's why I looked
it up because I thought that was because
I thought that was hilarious so I was
like did they really okay they really
did all right imagine what the world had
been like the internet never happened
and it remains television oh my God it
would have been thousands of channels in
each one I was like I never saw I never
saw it with that most of the all the sex
lines we saw were like very very generic
it was just kind of like hey I have like
sexy lingerie there was no there was
nothing interesting nobody was into like
bloodletting or peeing
furry [ __ ] or anything like nobody was
in anything weird it was always just
kind of like hey I got sexy lingerie I'm
like boring one 900 my breasts are too
big and they got these girls I can't
close my top call me
falls out the other side
of my button could you hold these
together for me [ __ ] it that's what that
[ __ ] would have been pretty much it was
back in the day pretty much but like I
said that seems like like that's very
very
that's very like surface level yeah I
would have liked to see some sex lines
that had that branched out that did like
some weirder [ __ ] but I never saw
anything like that they were all just
very very I said they'd only come over
they would only come on in uh in the USA
at the tent yeah yeah that's what it was
yeah pretty much okay look let's go
ahead and shut it down oh my God we've
been only five hours yeah five hours of
[ __ ] we gotta go people we mostly got
into the stuff yeah we we it's finished
all right we'll see you guys win uh
your Friday my birthday Friday my
birthday we're gonna talk friday is
Tom's birthday
Tom's birthday Edition we'll do we'll do
a little bit of a show and then we'll
[ __ ] head out to uh mannequins and uh
I'm gonna get you a cake yeah we're
gonna go you can get some sushi and I
can get some tempura it's a Friday
[ __ ] get an old show it's getting old
okay I'll have to remember [ __ ] getting
old today
that's what we're gonna call it all
right so hopefully you guys enjoyed the
show this evening I tried to stay on
topic but you know how that goes uh so
yeah come back Friday celebrate Tom's
birthday with us yeah [ __ ] getting old
[ __ ] get old yeah thank you very much
for tuning in thank you very much for
super chats we will see you guys on
Friday bye